REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER. WINNING IN RESPONSE THE
COPA NINETEEN EMERGENCY O
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS A
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY IF THEY
SHOULD CHOOSE TODAY ALL THE
SENATORS ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IF THEY ARE PRESENT AND I WOULD
ASK THE CONSULTANT TO CALL THE
ROLL AT THIS TIME SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH. WHICH SENATORS ARE
PARTICIPATING. SEGMENT HERE. LET
US. PAMPER HERE. WE NOTICE THAT
CENTERS EGGMAN AND PAN
PARTICIPATING TODAY. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO RECOGNIZE
IT USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO NEW
PLEASE SELECT A MUTE POINT YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. ARE EIGHTY
PERSONAL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU
WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STAGE NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO GO. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO EXTEND TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IS ALLOWED.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE REMOTE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER. TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ONCE WE MOVE
PUBLIC. WE BE WILL BE PRO BY MY-
TO ONE THEN JUROR. PROCESS ONE
TIME IN WE PATIENTLY FOR
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
WHAT YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LAN NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE A MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW
PARTY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING TH
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WILL BE RETAINING DECORUM. AS IS
NECESSARY AND ANYBODY WHO IS.
DESCRIPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED OR
HAVE YOUR CONNECTION MUTED. TO
BEGIN THE HEARING AT TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL HAVE REVIEWED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THIS COULD BE A BIG
AGENDA- TODAY DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS A LOT GOING ON AS WE
MIGHT GUESS- WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
HERE THE DEPARTMENT TO SPEND
SOME TIME DISCUSSING HIS
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN
IMPROVING OUR STATE'S PUBLIC
INTEREST FOR ALL OF US AND WE
WILL ALSO BE CONVENING. A PANEL
OF STAKEHOLDERSINCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICES PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
AND HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL.
JUSTICE ADVOCATES TO DISCUSS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND
WHERE WE MIGHT MAKE A DISH NO
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS. ONCE
DISCUSSED HAVE CONCLUDED WILL
ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO VERY
BRIEFLY. PRESENT ALL THEIR
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS AND
PROGRAM ESTIMATES AFTER WHICH I
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MAY ASK SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE ESTIMATES. AFTER
THAT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS- BEFORE WE BEGIN TO
EXPAND YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS- LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE PRESENTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
WANT TO WELCOME- THE DIRECTOR DR
THOMAS COUNTING ON. THEM AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR TO
GONE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
AND DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH SH
IT IS IT IS AN HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT ON THE STATE OF
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE I PROVIDE THIS
PRESENTATION BRANDON NUNEZ CHIEF
DEPUTY OF OPERATIONS WILL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. BRANDON THANK
YOU- AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- SO AT A HIGH LEVEL OUR
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET- ARE REVISED
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET IS
SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION WITH
THREE POINT THREE BILLION COMING
FROM GENERAL FUND. AND THEN OUR
PROPOSED TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET IS FIVE POINT SEVEN
BILLION WITH ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION COMING FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. THE REASON FOR THAT SLIGHT
DECLINE IN- FROM TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- AS YOU ALL. ARE AWARE THE
EARLY ACTION THAT WAS PROPOSED
LAST. WEEK AND PASSED INCLUDED
SOME OF OUR COVERED RELATED-
COSTS FOR SUPPORT THROUGH THIS
CURRENT YEAR. DOES DROP OFF INTO
THE BUDGET YEAR AND SOME OF
THOSE COSTS TO CONTINUE BUT AT A
LESSER AMOUNTS- SO I WON'T GET
INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL ABOUT SOME
OF THE COVERT RELATED COSTS FOR
THE FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
INCLUDED BECAUSE WE WILL BE
GETTING INSTALLED SINCE THE NEXT
TWO AGENDA ITEMS. BUT THERE'S A
COUPLE OTHER AREAS THAT I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT FOR US- THAT ARE
IMPORTANT IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET-
IN OUR CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. WE'VE BEEN MAKING A
LOT OF INVESTMENTS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS IN THE BUDGETS
RELATED TO ALZHEIMER'S RELATED
PROGRAMS. THIS BUDGET CONTINUES
THOSE INVESTMENTS WITH TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME RELATED
TO THE ALZHEIMER'S HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE. AND THEN IN THE
CENTER THERE'S ALSO. A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME. EIGHT
SETTLEMENT FUND. A PROBE. AND
THAT'S GOING TO GO SOME OTHER
AWARENESS. TARGETED TOWARDS
YOUTH- EDUCATION AWARENESS AND
BEND ALL RISK- EDUCATION AND
THERE'S ALSO FIVE MILLION FROM
THIS FUND. TO IMPROVE THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO COLLECT AND
ANALYZE DATA ON OPIOID. OVERDOSE
TRENDS- WE ALSO THIS YEAR IN OUR
BUDGET HAS SOME CLIMATE CHANGE
INVESTMENTS. THERE'S A ONE TIME
INCREASE OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM. AND
THAT'S GOING TO GO TO FIND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND TRIBES
TO DEVELOP REGIONAL CLIMATE. AND
HEALTH RESILIENCE PLANS. AND
THEN THERE'S ALSO TEN MILLION
GENERAL ONE TO INITIATE A
CLIMATE HEALTH SURVEILLANCE
PROGRAM. AND THIS IS GOING TO
HELP PROVIDE NEAR REAL TIME
NOTIFICATIONS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS. AND THE COMMUNITY ON
EMERGING OR INTENSIFIED CLIMATE
SENSITIVE DISEASES. AND THEN THE
FINAL AREA HIGHLIGHT IS RELATED
TO SOME OF OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
INVESTMENTS. YOU ALSO MAY RECALL
SOME INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
MAKING OVER THE YEARS ARE BLACK
AND HEALTH PROGRAM IN OUR HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS THIS BUDGET
CONTINUES AS INVESTMENTS WITH
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR. THOSE
BOTH OF THOSE PROGRAMS- AND THAT
INVESTMENT WILL HELP SERVE
APPROXIMATELY SIX THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL FAMILIES FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS ON TOP OF THE THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING- SERVED IN OUR OWN
VISITING PROGRAMS. AND ROUGHLY
SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS IN A BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM. AND THEN
FINALLY THERE'S TEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND INCLUDED TO EXPAND
EARLY LITERACY EFFORTS. BY
PROVIDING MULTILINGUAL BOOKS TO
YOUNG CHILDREN AND EARLY
LITERACY PROGRAMMING FOR
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
TODAY I KNOW THERE'S GONNA BE A
LOT OF CONVERSATION RELATED TO
OUR CALL OF THE COST IN FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT WANTED TO
ELEVATE SOME OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED BIG AGENDA
TODAY AND WE HAVE OUR WHOLE TEAM
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THESE ITEMS THAT I TALKED ABOUT
BUT- IN THE MEANTIME ALL PASS IT
BACK TO THE DOCTOR OR GOING TO
CONTINUE OUR PRESENTATION.
THANKS. THANK YOU BRANDON. THE
MISSION OF THE H. IS TOO VASTLY
AND WELL BEING CAL. THAT PEOPLES
AND CAN. HEALTH NOT JUST THE- OF
DISEASE OR INJURY HOW IS OF
COMPLETE FIRST MENTAL SOCIAL
WELL BEING. HEALTH MAKES EVERY
POP. AND I EIGHTY EIGHT THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE DEFINED
HEALTH IS WHAT. AS A TO
COLLECTIVELY TO ENSURE THE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH PEOPLE CAN
BE HEALTHY. WORK IN PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSOCIATION'S THAT THE
ROLE OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS TO
PROMOTE AND PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF PEOPLE AND THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY LIVE LEARN WORK AND
PLAY. IN SPITE OF THESE
DEFINITIONS PUBLIC HEALTH IS
LARGELY INVISIBLE MANY STILL DO
NOT UNDERSTAND PUBLIC HEATH. OR
CALL HAS FOUR PILLARS THAT THIS
. OUR POPULATION HEALTH SCIENCE
APPROACH THE FIRST PILLAR IS
ECOLOGICAL SOCIAL. THAT IS HOW
PEOPLE ARE WITH THEIR FAMILY AND
THEIR SOCIAL NETWORKS AND HOW
THEY INTERACT WITH ANY OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU FOR
EXAMPLE THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN CLIMATE CHANGE-
NUMBER TWO LIFE CORE. AN INTER.
PROCESS THESE FRANK ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND TOXIC
STRESS IMPACTING THE NEURAL
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN AND
IMPACTING LIFE. THEIR HEALTH FOR
LIFE. INTERGENIC THANK ALSO
INTER GENERAL INTERGENERATIONAL
TRANSMISSION OF THE SOCIAL AND
BIOLOGICAL EFFECTS OF ADVERSITY
COLOR NUMBER THREE EQUITY AT
HEALTHEQUITY THANK OF THE LOW
INCOME AND RURAL RURAL
COMMUNITIES. AND THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT WERE IMPACTED BY
CODE NINETEEN. ALSO RACIAL
ETHNIC HEALTH INEQUITIES THAT
PREDISPOSE PERSON SO HAVING
COVERED COMPLICATIONS COLOR
NUMBER FOUR IS PREVENTION
ESPECIALLY PRIMARY PREVENTION
THANKS FOR EXAMPLE. VACCINE
SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS THAT
COMFORT- AND UNITY SO THAT WE
PREVENT MANY CHILDHOOD VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASES. AND OF
COURSE MASS FIRST SOURCE CONTROL
AND RESPIRATORY PROTECTION
AGAINST COVERED. OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTION HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
REDUCING THE OVERALL DEATH RATE
FOR ALL GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER TODAY CALIFORNIA FACES
INCREASING PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES WHICH IMPACT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND AMPLIFY SOCIAL
INEQUITIES THESE CHALLENGES ARE
LIKELY TO INCREASE IN SCALE
SCOPE AND SEVERITY. OUR
POPULATION IS GROWING AS WELL AS
AG WE SEE THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON OUR ENVIRONMENT
INCLUDING DROUGHT WILDFIRES HEAT
WAVES AND CORE ERROR QUALITY.
ECONOMIC AND SOCIALIST PARTIES
INTENSIFY STRESS AND ANXIETY WE
ALSO OBSERVED ESCALATION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONCERNS
INCLUDING ISOLATION TRAUMA AND
ADDICTION. THE COVER DATING
DEREK IS AMONG VISIBLE EXAMPLE
OF ECOLOGICAL SOCIAL FORCES
IMPACTING HEALTH WITH PROFOUND
AND DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES ON
THE LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. BEGINNING AT TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED INCREASE IN ALL
FIVE DEATHS FOR ALL RACIAL OR
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE ALL
CAUSE MORTALITY IN CALIFORNIA
INCREASED. WHAT IS THE INCREASE
IN TERMS OF ACCESS THAT BY FIFTH
. POINT 9% AMONG LATINOS THAT
WAS THIRTY FOUR POINT 1% CHANGE
IN THEIR LIFE EXPECTANCY-
REDUCING THAT BY THREE POINT SIX
YEARS. OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC DEATH RATES HAVE
CONTINUED TO GO UP AND THE
DISPARITIES IN THE GROUPS ARE
WIDENING. A PANDEMIC REVEALED
AND WORSENED UNDERLINE
INEQUITIES EXIST EXISTING
INEQUITIES AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH CREATE
HIGHER RISK FOR POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES. WHICH WERE MADE EVEN
MORE VISIBLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SOCIAL ECONOMIC
FACTORS CONTRIBUTED TO GREATER
EXPOSURE AND HIGHER RATES OF
SEVERE OUTCOMES SUCH AS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS FROM
BECAUSE IN NINETEEN. EXAMPLES
INCLUDE LIVING IN CROWDED
HOUSING RELIANCE ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WORKING IN FRONT
LINE ESSENTIAL SERVICE SECTORS
HIGHER RATES OF COAL COAL
MORBIDITIES WORK FOR ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. THE INCREASE DOES
RATES DUE TO COVER NINETEEN WILL
LEAVE A LASTING IMPACT ON FUTURE
GENERATIONSAND THE POPULATION.
HEALTH LANDSCAPE IN CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EXPERIENCED A
LOSS OF AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBER SUCH AS A GRANDPARENT
PARENT SPOUSE SIBLING OR CHILD.
MANY CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCED
LOSS OF A PARENT OR CARE GIVER
WHO PROVIDED THE CHILD'S HOME
AND BASIC NEEDS INCLUDING LOVE
SECURITY AND DAILY CARE. EFFECTS
OF THE LOSSES INCLUDE CREATING
TRAUMA LONG LASTING HEALTH AND
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP MENTAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES AS WELL AS RELATED
PHYSICAL HEALTH RISK. LOSS OF A
FAMILY MEMBER CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
HM COVER NINETY- INITIALLY
COVERED NINE THERE NO OTHER
MARTEL TRENDS AND OTHER
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS. ASKING THE COURT TO
SEIZE COVER NINETEEN AT
ALZHEIMER DISEASE WHERE THE TOP
THREE LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH.
IF GIVING CARDS WHICH DECREASE
AND- FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY
STARTED GOING UP. ALZHEIMER'S
ALZHEIMER'S DEATHS AT THE SINGLE
LARGEST INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS FROM 1-920-192-2020
AND MORE THAN DOUBLED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. IF CURRENT TRENDS
CONTINUE IT IS ON TRACK TO
BECOME THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN CALIFORNIA. HEBER
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE GROWING
AREA OF PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN
PARTICULARLY AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
INCREASES WERE OBSERVED FOR DRUG
OVERDOSE ROAD INJURY HOMICIDE
AND ALCOHOL RELATED CONDITIONS.
PRIMARILY AMONG YOUNG ADULTS
THERE WAS A 50% INCREASE IN DRUG
OVERDOSE AT A 30% INCREASE IN
HOMICDE DEATHS DRUG OVERDOSE IS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF YEARS OF
LIFE LOST IN TWENTY TWENTY-
DISORDERS AND SCHIZOPHRENIA ARE
AMONG THE TOP CAUSE OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR YOUTH AND
MIDDLE AGE ADULTS. AND THERE ARE
OTHER CONTINUING DISPARITIES IN
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT I WON'T HAVE TIME TO GO
OVER TODAY. THERE ARE THERE ARE
ALSO MANY ADDITIONAL FACTORS
WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO INFLUENCING
POPULATION HEALTH SOCIAL ICE
ISOLATION AND DISCONNECTION. YOU
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FACE
SCHOOL CLOSURES IN CAPS AND
LEARNING AND THERE WAS AN
INCREASE IN ADULT INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE EXCESSIVE
ALCOHOL USE OPIOID USE DISORDER
ADULT ADULT DEPRESSION. WITH A
FOCUS ON EQUITY CDPH HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACHES TO SHAPE AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY CAN ADDRESS
THE FULL RANGE OF FACTORS THAT
INFLUENCE A PERSON'S OVERALL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. NEW AND
EXISTING POPULATION HEALTH
CONCERNS HAVE HEIGHTENED THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN A
MODERNIZED PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
THIS INVESTMENT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY BUILD
BACK BETTER BUT TO BUILD BACK
MORE EQUITABLY. SUNDAY MENTALLY
RE ARCHITECTING THE FOUNDATIONS
AND STRUCTURES THAT SUPPORT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS AND THE
HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ANYTHING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO.
BUT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. OKAY
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION I
KNOW THAT DELVE MORE DEEPLY INTO
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
PRESENTED DURING OUR HEARING
TODAY I DID HAVE A FEW. BROADER
QUESTIONS AS PARTY OVERVIEW SO
FIRST I WOULD MAKE NOTES- THAT
LEESON ARE RIGHT UP THAT
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE HAD A CHANCE TO
SEE. ON THE FUNDING FOR. THE
GENERAL FUND FOR DEPART PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH STARTS WITH THE
ACTUAL TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
COURSE GOING TO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE PROPOSED. HOW LOW
WILL THE GENERAL FUND. HAS BEEN
. UNTIL EARLY UNTIL TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTIES I GUESS WHEN-
THAT THE ONE CODE STARTED AND-
IF WE HAD ONLY VERY THIN LINE
THE BOTTOM WE ONLY DOUBLED ITS
LET'S SAY WHICH WE WOULDN'T
BARELY NOTICE ON THE GRASS. IN
THOSE PRIOR YEARS PERHAPS-
SOMETHING METALLIC AND EVEN
PERHAPS IN SOME OF THE SPENDING
THAT WE CAN DO NOW WOULD NOT BE
QUITE AS HIGH- SO I'D SO IT'S WE
ASSIST PEOPLE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT- WE'RE WE'RE COMING IN THE
FUTURE- AND I APPRECIATE IT
WON'T RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
AND WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT LATER
THE- GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT WHICH
IS PUT INTO THIS- THIS THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION- SO I'M GOING IN
SO HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE A-
TRULY AN ON GOING INVESTMENT. IN. PUBLIC HEALTH- SO I GUESS ONE
QUESTION I HAVE IS. WITH WITH
THE RIGHT IN BY NOW THAT MOST OF
THE MONEY THE PART ABOUT HOW
THEY'LL BE IN THE PAST COME FROM
FEDERAL FIVE. AND FUN WHICH TEND
BE RESTRICTED SO FORTH. IN
RESPONSE TO COAL BED. AND THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S MORE
OF BOTH FUNNY AND WORKFOR
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. AT
THIS PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC CAN
YOU SPEAK TO. THE WORK FORCE AT
CDPH SO- YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING FOR A LOT
MORE POSITIONS WE'RE GONNA BE
DISCUSSING ABOUT. BUT GIVEN THE
CURRENT WORK FORCE- HOW ARE WE
DOING IN TERMS OF VACANCIES. ARE
WE YES GIVEN THE CRISIS- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
DOING VERY IMPORTANT WORK IN
MANY OTHER FIELDS I THINK IT'S
JUST RELAYED BY THE DIRECTOR. IT
IS A LOT YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT'S
NOT THE ONLY THING OUT THERE-
AND WE AND USUALLY DURING
PANDEMICS ARE OTHER OUTBREAKS
AND SO FORTH OFTENTIMES YOU HAVE
TO PULL STAFF FROM ONE THING TO
ANOTHER IN ORDER TO. TAKE CARE
OF A CRISIS BUT THEN THAT MEANS
WORK SLOWED OR STOPPED. IN OTHER
AREAS. SO CAN YOU JUST THAT IS
PART OF THE OVERVIEW. I GIVE ME
A GENERAL IDEA ABOUT THE OVERALL
CD P. H. WORK FORCE IS IT ARE
THEY ABLE TO. DO THAT THE- DO
THE NON THING ARE SUPPOSED TO DO
. AS A AS OF COURSE. TO COVET.
HOW WE DOING IN TERMS OF BACON
AND HIRING AND TURNOVER. THE
OVERALL. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I'LL GIVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS THAT ASKS THAT STUDENTS
. TO FILL IN SOME OF THE DETAILS
. OF YOU'RE YOU'RE- CORRECT
CORRECT- YOU KNOW SINCE
EVERYBODY. FIRST YOU'RE PRETTY
MUCH EVERYBODY IN PUBLIC HEALTH
ALMOST EVERYBODY PUBLIC HEALTH.
HAS HAD SOME IMPACT SOME WORK
RELATED TO COME IN NINETEEN
DISTRICTS SINCE JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND IT DID TAKE
AWAY FROM OTHER OTHER AREAS WE
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE JUST WITH A
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS
THAT THAT HAVE DOES IT REALLY
HAVE TO HAVE SKYROCKETED. WE
KNOW THAT HIV TRANSMISSION
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN WE NOTE
TUBERCULOSIS CONTINUES TO BE
TRANSMITTED. THERE ARE A LOT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT HAVE
NOT RECEIVE THE ATTENTION. WE
BEEN. VERY VERY SAND- AND IT
PARKING REALIZE. IS THAT- IT HAS
GIVEN US A LOT BECAUSE SOME OF
THE FOR TO. SOME OF OUR SOME OF
SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE- I. T. BUT
THE WORK FOR IS MOST AND- AND
YOU KNOW WE WILL WE GET TO THE-
AND I DON'T WE'LL TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAT WOULD BE CAN DO
FOR FILLING THOSE GAPS ARE IN
IMPORTANT SH ME ASK THIS IS AN
ISSUE SHE'S. CLOSER TO THE
OPERATION DETAILS AND SHE CAN.
ARE SOME ARE MAKING SEE RIGHT
RIGHT NOW IS TIME TO ABOUT 8%
WHICH IS IF WE CAN WITH WE- RUN
AND- ABSOLUTELY THERE ARE SOME
TO RECRUIT CUSTOMER. LIKE
LIBERTY ENDS THAT WE CAN TO. DO
OUR BEST TO TRY TO FILL I THINK
ALSO BEEN ABLE TO USE SOME OF
THE ONE TIME DOLLARS AND THROUGH
A VARIETY OF. RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS BEEN ABLE TO HIRE ABOUT
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED NEW PEOPLE
AND LAST PROBABLY. MONTH BETTER
FOR COVERT RESPONSE THAT WE ARE
GRADUALLY RETURNING SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN REDIRECTED
BUT CLEARLY WE'RE STILL IN
RESPONSE AND STILL NEED TO KEEP
SOME OF THE FOLKS RE DIRECTED SO
WE ARE ABLE TO GET EVERYTHING
DONE. AT ALL I MEAN THERE ARE
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
WORKLOAD AND WE'LL BE
TRANSFERRING TO TRANSITION THAT
BACK BUT WE WILL I THINK AS WE
GET INTO THE WORK FORCE
DISCUSSION WITH THE NEW DOLLARS.
WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS CREATIVE
AS POSSIBLE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S WORKED THROUGH THE
CULVERT RESPONSES SETTING UP
TEAMS TO HELP US RECRUIT FOR NEW
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE. H. OUR
DEDICATED STAFF WE HAVE A
PROGRAM DEDICATED STAFF AND THEN
WE HAVE A TEAM OF PEOPLE WHO
JUST KNOW HOW TO GET ALL THE
DOCUMENTS AND THINGS PROCESSED
AND CAN HELP WITH RECRUITMENT
DOCUMENT DOCUMENTS CAN HELP WITH
ALL THE PAPERWORK THAT HAS TO GO
TO HR TO FILL POSITIONS AND SO.
THAT HAS BEEN A REALLY
SUCCESSFUL MODEL FOR US IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO. AND IT REALLY
EXPEDITE SOME OF THE HIRING AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BRING ON THE OPEN
POSITIONS BUT THEN WE WILL ALSO
USE A SIMILAR PROCESS AS WE GET. TO YOU BRING ON WORKFORCE AND
UNDER THESE NEW DOLLARS AND SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN.
REALLY GOOD GREAT AND THAT. THEY
BUILT ON THE RELAY. AND THE
SCALE THEY BILL IN THE CONGRESS
. WILL ALSO. AS WE AWAY FOR COAL
THAT RESPONSE INTO SOMEONE KEY
AREA WHERE WE PLAN TO REACH. SO
WE HOPING WE CAN MIX OF THOSE
PEOPLE. PERMANENT STATE
POSITIONS AND THEREBY GAIN FROM
ALL THAT KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE
THAT THEY BROUGHT TO THE TABLE.
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN
I GUESS THE OTHER. QUESTION
RELATED AGAIN OVERALL WORK FORCE
IS THAT- YEAH THAT POINTED OUT.
IN THE PAST AT LEAST MOST OF THE
MONEY FOR C. PEACHES COME
THROUGH. ESSENTIALLY GRANTS AND
THINGS ARE FAIRLY DIRECTED FUNDS
I MEAN IF WE SEE THE BOXES AS
FEDERAL FUNDS BUT A LOT OF IT IS
FOR VERY SPECIFIC THINGS- AND
THAT. SO I GUESS. THE QUESTION
IS THAT. THE WORK. THESE GRANTS
FOR. OTHER TYPES OF FUNDS THAT
YOU GET- AND HOPEFULLY AT THE
FUNDERS DO UNDERSTAND WITH CODE
THAT YOU HAD TO YOU KNOW THERE
THERE NEED TO BE SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN TIME IT'S- HOW
ARE YOU ABLE. HOW YOU DOING IN
TERMS OF KEEPING UP WITH THE
OTHER WORK HAS BEEN UNCOVERED
WORK. THAT WORKED AT CITY PAGES
CONNECTED TO DO. I THINK IT IT
VARIES BY CENTER IN OFFICE-
CERTAINLY INVENT FACTIONS
DISEASE GROUP IS MORE IMPACTED
BUT ALSO THE FUNDERS ARE MARTINI
AND IN TERMS OF USING THOSE
STAFF AND REDIRECTING THEM
BECAUSE THE SKILLS AND WHAT THEY
LEARNED. IN QUEBEC RESPONSE I
THINK HELPS THEM WITH THEIR DAY
TO DAY JOB AS WELL. I'M SO I
THINK IN OTHER AREAS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BACK FILL SOME OF
THE POSITIONS WE'VE- REDIRECT IT
WE'RE STARTING TO DO MORE OF
THAT RELEASE OF THE RE DIRECTED
STAFF. AND YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THE PROGRAMS
ARE JUST PICKING UP MORE WORK-
AND SO YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE A
LITTLE TIRED I. WILL GIVE YOU
THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE BOTH
CALLED IN RESPONSE TO NONVIOLENT
RESPONSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN REALLY
BUSY TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH THE
WORK BUT- THERE ARE SOME AREAS
AND WE DID SOME GAP ANALYSIS TO
LOOK AT. WHERE WE WANT TO PICK
UP SOME OF THAT WORK AND AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME NEW
INITIATIVES THIS YEAR WERE SOME
OF THE CENTERS ARE GOING TO. BE
TAKING ON NEW ROLES AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
BALANCING THAT AND THE KEY TO
THAT IS HIRING AND WE'VE GOT TO
DO A GOOD JOB OF USING THE
DOLLARS WE HAVE TO FILL
POSITIONS. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT- JUST MAKE NOTE THAT AGAIN
PRE COATED- WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
HEARINGS IN THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT PANDEMIC GUARD NOT TO
SPEND I CAN OPERATE
RESPONSIVENESS AND- FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE HAD PREVIOUS. OUTBREAKS OF
MEASLES AND SO FORTH. AND I'VE
ASKED C. PH ABOUT WELL HOW MUCH
THAT ACTUALLY COSTS THE STATE
THEY'RE LIKE WELL WE WERE SO
BUSY YOU KNOW TAKING CARE OF THE
OUTBREAK WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
TRACK HOW MUCH TIME WE'RE
SPENDING SO. I HOPE THAT WE GET
TO A STAFFING LEVEL WERE
ACTUALLY CAN'T BECAUSE BABSON'S
OF INFORMATION DOESN'T MEAN
DIDN'T HAPPEN. AND SO IT'S GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT YET WERE ABLE TO
TRACK. AND PLAN AND BUDGET FOR
THOSE IN THE FUTURE AND THEN
FINALLY I JUST SAY IS I DO
APPRECIATE IN THE PRESENTATION
STATED PUBLIC HEALTH THE FOUR
PILLARS. I HOPE WILL BE
CONTINUING TO REFERENCE THOSE
FOUR PILLARS AS WE TALK ABOUT
THE OTHER ITEMS WERE GOING AT
THROUGH THIS HEARING TODAY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND DOCTOR
BEHIND WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT SORT
OF A COST ANALYSIS ON SOME OF
THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BRINGING ON A HEALTH. ECONOMIST
TO HELP US WITH SOME OF THAT AND
ARE ALL. A CALL. IN PLACE. WILL
AT OF THOSE. BE WE DO WANT TO.
HAVE BETTER METRICS AND BETTER
COSTUME. SO THAT WE- REALLY.
TRACK THAT AND PROVIDE THAT IN.
THANK YOU VERY AND I DIED BORNE
EXPRESSED THANKS THE- IT'S LIKE
WE'VE BEEN ON. A JOURNEY-
THROUGH COVERT DR PAM POINTED
OUT YOU CAN YOU SEE ON THE ON
THE SCALE HOW IT JUST SHOOTS UP.
SO I GUESS IT HAD TO TAKE
ANOTHER HUNDRED YEARS FOR PEOPLE
TO APPRECIATE PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
THINGS THAT YOU DON'T THINK
ABOUT UNTIL IT BECOMES A REAL
CRISIS AND THEN WE REALIZED. THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAINTAINING OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM SO AGAIN I
REALLY WANT TO. THANK YOU ALL
AND AS YOU COME UP AND BEGIN TO
BREATHE A LITTLE BIT- REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK TO CONTINUE TO
DO FORWARD THINKING ABOUT- THE
NEEDS AND OUR FOUR PILLARS. ONE
QUESTION I WANT ANSWERED JUST
OVER A LITTLE BIT ASIDE IS
ANOTHER AREA PUBLIC HEALTH IS-
INSPECTING. OUR FOOD IN
RESTAURANTS AND SO- WALL ALSO
CURIOUS ABOUT THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CHANGES IN. FOOD FOOD DELIVERY
HOW YOU KNOW TRUCKS POPPING UP.
HAS THERE BEEN HOW HAS IT BEEN
TO TRACK ALL OF THE NEW.
BUSINESS MODELS. FOR FOOD AND
HAS THAT CREATED ANY EXTRA.
HEALTH ISSUES. THAT WE WERE
PREVIOUSLY AWARE OF. WE MIGHT
ASK MARANDA JUMP IN. IT'S A
REGARDING THE LOCAL FOOD AT
RESTAURANTS. THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
REGULATED BY THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. OF THE DEPARTMENT
OR WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULATING AND LICENSING
MANUFACTURERS THAT WE HAVEN'T
HEARD OF ANY- SPECIFIC INCREASES
IN COMPLAINTS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT. RELATED TO CRIME DURING
COLD IT SO I'M NOT AWARE. OF ANY
SPECIFIC INSURANCE. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR USING HIS INTEREST WHEN
WE THINK. OUR ENTIRE MODEL OF
HOW WE GO OUT AND EAT AND
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS CHANGES
IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
RAMIFICATIONS OR OR ANY LESSONS
LEARNED. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE OKAY LET'S MOVE ON THEN
TO ISSUE NUMBER. TWO OKAY I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GIVE US SOME
. YOU NEVER. IT I REMEMBER A FUN
TRADITION FOR THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE COVER NINETEEN
ENDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
SIZE THE NEED FOR ADEQUATE
INVESTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EXPOSED SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN THE
ABILITY O CDPH AND LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO RESPOND TO THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS RAPIDLY.
FOR DECADES THE LEVEL OF HEALTH
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH AT
THE NATIONAL STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
BELOW WHAT IS NEEDED FOR A TRULY
EQUITABLE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
THAT CAN KEEP CALIFORNIANS
HEALTHY AND SAFE. THE FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORK GROUP BROUGHT
TOGETHER LOCAL HEALTH EXECUTIVE
HEALTH OFFICERS ADMINISTRATORS
ADMINISTRATION LEADERSHIP TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND IDENTIFY CORE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN FOUNDATIONAL GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE INVESTMENTS CAPABLE OF
MEETING CURRENT AND FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS. SEE PAGE
REQUEST FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR
POSITIONS AND SHE CAN GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
TO MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM WITH THE GOAL OF
PROTECTING AND IMPROVING THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. OF
THESE RESOURCES- JUST OVER TO
TWO HUNDRED MILLION WITH SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AND NINETY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION WITH
SUPPORT STATEWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PRIORITY AT
CDPH. TO MODERNIZE THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSITION TO RESILIENCE SYSTEM
RATHER THAN ONE DEPENDENT ON
INTERMITTENT SHORT TERM FUNDING
OR VARIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS IN SIX FOUNDATIONAL
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE AREAS IDENTIFIED BY THE
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE.
THE FIRST ONE IS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RECRUITMENT EVER TO
EVER CHANGE THE CAPACITY AND
ABILITY TO RECRUIT RETAIN AND
DEVELOP A DIVERSE WORK FORCE.
THIRTY PAGES PLAN INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY POSITIONS AT
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION TO INCREASE
STAFFING CAPACITY AND TO ATTRACT
DEVELOP AND RETAIN A DIVERSITY
OF MULTI DISCIPLINARY PUBLIC.
HEALTH WORK FORCE THAT CAN. FUN
FACT OF THE TO THE TO NEXT UP
HEALTH CHECK. THIS IS GOING TO
BE A- ADDRESSING KEEPING GAPS
WE'RE GOING TO BE DEVELOPING FR
THE FIRST TIME WE'RE GONNA BE
BILL AND ALL. OF POLICY AND- SO
THAT WE CAN BE. DO SOME OF THE
WORK THAT DUCK PANDA WAS TALKING
ABOUT LOOK FORWARD AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN EXECUTE WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN PROTECTING AND
IMPROVING HEALTH. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A STRONG EMPHASIS ON
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT WERE
BECOMING A LEAN ORGANIZATION
FOCUSING ON ELIMINATING WASTE
AND IMPROVING ITS OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GOOD STEWARDS
OF. THE PUBLIC'S- RETIREMENT
FUNDING DEVELOPING A REGIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE SO WITH
THAT WE CAN COORDINATE ACROSS
THE STATE AND A BIG FOCUS ON
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. AND
EXPECT A AREA IS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE. THIS
IS THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES OF ALL KINDS FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS TO INFECTIOUS
DISEASE OUTBREAKS TO
BIOTERRORISM. CDPH IS PLANNING
INCLUDES SEVENTY SEVEN POSITIONS
AND TWENTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION FOR A SCALABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE STRUCTURE. THAT CAN
RAPIDLY IDENTIFY HAZARDS AND
DEPLOYED RESOURCES TO MITIGATE.
AND CONTAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS. IT INCLUDES KEY
INITIATIVE WE HAVE WHICH IS
DEVELOP A TWENTY FOUR SO IN
TOUCH. HOW HAVING A BILL TO BE
ABLE TO REACT TO FOUR STAR FIRST
LARGE HEALTH. WITH A POPULATION
OF CLOSE TO FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE- ALSO AN EMPHASIS ON.
EVERY REBUILDING OUR- PLANNING
TRAINING AND EXERCISE PROGRAM-
ALSO STRENGTHENING OUR REGIONAL-
RESOURCING MODEL WHERE WE HAVE
WORKED WELL AGAIN WORKING IN A
REGIONAL WAY AROUND AT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND THEN
THE LAST COMPONENT IN THAT AREA
IS HAVING A DEDICATED RECOVERY
UNIT WELL AFTER ANY DISASTER
WHETHER IT'S LOCAL OR OR CUTE
THERE'S ALWAYS RECOVERY THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL. THE THIRD AREA
IS AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
DATA SCIENCE AND INFORMATICS
MOST OF THAT MEAT IS GOING TO BE
FELT THROUGH MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS WITH A SEPARATE
BUDGET CHANGE BECAUSE ALL THERE
IS A SMALL AMOUNT THAT'S GOOD
WE'RE ASKING HERE FOR THAT BIRTH
DEFECTS. AND MONITORING PROGRAM
WHICH IS THREE POSITIONS AT FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS THE FOURTH AREA IS
PUBLIC EDUCATION ENGAGEMENT AND
BE HERE FOR A CHANGE AND THAT'S
THE ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE TO DIVERSE PUBLIC
HEALTH. PUBLIC AUDIENCES WITH
TIMELY SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THE SAYS. WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY HELP SHAPE THE NARRATIVE
AROUND PROTECTING AND PROMOTING
PROMOTING HEALTH AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT THE MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION THAT'S HAPPENING
HAS HAD A TREMENDOUS NEGATIVE
IMPACT AND SO WE HAVE TO.
COMMUNICATE ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND BUILD TRUST SO WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS PEOPLE WILL
TRUST US WHEN WE WHEN WE WHEN WE
ASK FOR PEOPLE TO REALLY
CONTRIBUTE I REALLY DON'T FROM A
LESSER INDIVIDUALLY
INDIVIDUALISM PERSPECTIVE. TO
MORE OF A COMMUNITY ORIENTATION
AND PROTECTING PROTECTING YOUR
COMMUNITY INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THIS WILL BE CREATING
A CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY- ALSO
GIVE ME A- IN. OUR TABLE CABLE.
TO INFORMATION NUMBER FIVE THIS
CAN PRK. EVERYTHING THE THINGS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORK ON HER-
BIG AND YOU'RE REALLY REQUIRES
US TO WORKING WITH WITH
PARTNERS- SEE PAGE PLANS TO
INCLUDE FIVE POSITIONS AND TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CHIEF HOLISTIC PARTNERSHIP
NETWORK IT IS ENGAGED TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS. AND THAT'S DEVELOPING A
MORE GONNA BE DEVELOPING A
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP STRATEGY
PLAN BENNETT AND ALSO HAVING
DEDICATED COMMUNITY. ENGAGEMENT
PERSONNEL. WELL THE LAST AREA IS
COMING. HOW IMPROVEMENT THE
ABILITY TO SCALE PUBLIC. FROM
HEALTH PROMOTION TO
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
STRATEGY THAT EMPHASIZES LIFE
COURSE PERSPECTIVE THOSE PILLARS
OF PUBLIC HEALTH BUT WHAT WE'LL
DO THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THIS SPECIFIC AREA IS THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE THROUGH KEY
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS
ESPECIALLY WITH WITH. THOSE THAT
PROVIDE- HEALTH CARE BECAUSE A
BIG PART OF BUT IMPORTANT PART
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
WHICH IS WHICH IS MORE THAN JUST
THE AGENCY WHICH IS JUST FOR US
IS THAT OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
IS WHERE WHEN PEOPLE DO GET ILL
THAT'S WHERE THEY GO AND THAT'S
FOR A LOT OF THE METRICS THAT WE
RELY ON. AND WE USE THOSE AS A
AS A WAY TO BE ABLE TO TRACK HOW
SUCCESSFUL WE ARE CALIFORNIA
PLANS INCLUDE TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS ARE SIX POINT OE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT STRATEGY THAT
EMPHASIZES THE COLORS TODAY I
MENTIONED. I'M LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT WAYS OF FINANCING-
COMMUNITY HEALTH AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL EDUCATED DEDICATED
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
TEAM AND ALSO DEVELOPING A NEW
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
AN IMPORTANT GAP AREA IN IN
PUBLIC HEALTH IS THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS MORE ON. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PREVENTION HOW CAN WE WORK TO
REALLY BUILD RESILIENCY AND
BUILD IT IN EARLY IN THE LIFE
COURSE BECAUSE ONCE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR A HEALTH PROBLEMS
ARE SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IT'S REALLY.
WITH THAT THEN AND THEN OF
COURSE WE HAVE THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE SPENDING PLAN THAT'S
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
GOING TO GO TO LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
FOR THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
EVERY HEALTH DEPARTMENT HAS
DIFFERENT NAMES WHAT IS CORE
CROSS ALL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
IT'S REALLY IT IS REALLY
SUPPORTING AND EXPANDING THEIR
WORK FIRST TO DEAL WITH ALL THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT SO 70% OF THE
FUNDS WILL GO TOWARDS SUPPORTING
PUBLIC HEALTH- WORKFORCE
EXPANSION. RECRUITMENT RETENTION
ETCETERA. AND THEN OF COURSE
REDUCING HEALTH HEALTH
DISPARITIES. WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
DISTRIBUTED IN A WAY THAT
EMPHASIZES- HEALTH INEQUITIES
BUT NOT JUST A LOT OF RACE AND
ETHNICITY ALSO. SOCIAL AND
GEOGRAPHIC INEQUITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND RULE AREAS HAVE BEEN ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
COVERAGE SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- PAY ATTENTION. TO EVERY
SINGLE AREA OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT EVERY EVERY INDIVIDUAL
CALLS FOR EVERY INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITY DESERVES A- THE BEST
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION. OF
COURSE FOCUSING ON DATA
COLLECTION AND MONITORING AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THE LAST. THING I WANT TO MENTION IS FOR
WE'RE WORKING- WITH DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH ACCESS CENTER. TO COME
UP WITH A COMMUNITY BENEFITS
STRATEGY OR PROPORTION OF
HOSPITAL COMMUNITY BENEFITS IS
DEDICATED TO GO TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. TO SUPPORT
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH TO REALLY
HELP CHANGE THIS BROOKE TO
REALLY GO UPSTREAM IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS GUIDED BY THE
COMMUNITY PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS THAT. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING TO REALLY
MAKE THAT TRANSFORMATION HAPPEN
IN THE WAY THAT MEETS THE LOCAL
NEEDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY W.
THANK YOU SENATOR ADMIN AND
DOCTOR PAN- WE THINK WE JUST
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS ON ON THIS
PROPOSAL WE THINK THE PLAN HAS A
NUMBER OF MERITS FOR EXAMPLE
INCREASING REAL TIME DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE- COORDINATING
REGIONAL EPIDEMIOLOGICAL AND
COMMUNICATIONS ACTIVITIES AND
IMPROVING STRATEGIC PLANNING
THROUGH THE NEW OFFICE OF POLICY
AND PLANNING. AND WE LIKE TO
RATE THE REASON IDENTIFY A FEW
ISSUES WHICH WE THINK IS
ADDRESSED COULD- POTENTIALLY
STRENGTHEN THE PLAN SO FIRST WE
KNOW THAT THE PLAN DOES NOT-
INCLUDES THREE- WHAT WE SEE AS
KEY OBJECTIVES SO. FIRST
ALTHOUGH IT HAS A MALL FACETED
APPROACH TO RECRUITMENT TRAINING
AND INTERNAL EDUCATION AND
ADVANCEMENT FOR THE WORK FORCE
IT DOESN'T CREATE A WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. SECOND WE KNOW THAT IT
DOESN'T- INCLUDE DISCUSSION ON
STRENGTHENING THE STATE WIDE LAB
NETWORK PUBLIC HEALTH PLAN THAT
WORKS SPECIFICALLY SO THERE IS
FUNDING AND- POSITIONS FOR THE
STATE LAB AND FOR STATE LAB
FIELD SERVICES BUT THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS OR PLANS FOR
ENSURING THAT THE TWENTY EIGHT
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH LABS. ARE
STAFFED AND SUSTAINED. THIRD WE
NOTE THAT- THE PLAN CURRENTLY
DOES NOT LAY OUT AN OVER ARCHING
I T. STRATEGY. SO THE
DEPARTMENTS- NOTED TO OUR OFFICE
THAT IT DOESN'T TEND TO HIRE A
CHIEF I. T. STRATEGIST AND
DEVELOPER- MORE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE IT STRATEGY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. BUT WHEN THIS
PLAN WILL BE AVAILABLE AND HOW
THAT FUTURE- I. T. VERSION WOULD
BE FUNDED IT'S NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR YET. NEXT WE NOTE THAT THE
PLAN WE THINK COULD HAVE
STRONGER OVERSIGHT OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS SO RIGHT
NOW AS WRITTEN THE PLAN DOES NOT
LAY OUT MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS OR
GOALS FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. WE DO KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOES INTEND TO-
COLLABORATE WITH THE LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS ON ON THESE ISSUES-
BUT WE THINK THAT- THIS IS AN
AREA THAT THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO- CONSIDER WEIGHING IN ON
. AND THEN- WE NOTE THAT THE
PLAN. HAS LOCAL LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PLANS WOULD BE TIED TO
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
COMMUNITY EXISTING COMMUNITY
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PLANS WE JUST
SENT OUT A COUPLE THINGS ABOUT
THIS APPROACH FIRST I'M NOT ALL
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
CURRENTLY HAVE I'M A COMMUNITY
HEALTH ASSESSMENT- COMMUNITY
HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PLAN I TURNER
STANDING THAT THEY WOULD BE
WORKING OVER THE NEXT YEAR OR
TWO JUST TO DEVELOP THESE AND-
WE'RE NOT CLEAR IF THAT'S REALLY
ENOUGH TIME TO DEVELOP SORT OF
HIGH QUALITY- HEALTH ASSESSMENTS
IMPROVEMENT PLANS. SECOND WE
KNOW THAT THESE PLANS CAN
SOMETIMES- THE COMMUNITY HEALTH-
IN IMPROVEMENT PLANS CAN
SOMETIMES ENCOMPASS SCHOOLS THAT
ARE SORT OF BEYOND THE PURVIEW
OF PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
SUCH AS STRENGTHENING THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE IT OR
INCREASING STABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. SO WE RAISE THIS JUST
TO SAY THAT TYING LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS DIRECTLY TO THESE ARE
COMMUNITY HEALTH ASSESSMENTS AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT
PLANS. MAY NOT BE THE BEST
SUBSTITUTE FOR HAVING SORT OF A
MORE DELIBERATE AND CONSISTENT
TYPE OF LOCAL PLAN A CALL ACROSS
LOCAL DEPARTMENTS- HAVING A
HAVING A MORE CONSISTENT TYPE OF
LOCAL PLAN WOULD ALSO MAKE THE
STATEWIDE EVALUATION EASIER. THE
JUST A FEW ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONCERN- FIRST WE
THINK- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER ASKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT SOME OF THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PLAN THAT WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED SO WORK FIRST
PAY BLIND PUBLIC HEALTH LAB
NETWORK ACROSS THE STATE AN OVER
ARCHING I STRATEGY. WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER REQUIRING MORE CDPH
MANAGEMENT OF THE LOCAL PLAN
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS OVERSIGHT
OF THE LOCAL- ON USE OF FUNDS-
AND- AS I NOTED BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER IDENTIFYING SOME OF THE
COMMON PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS IT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE- PRIORITISED
ACROSS THE STREET. ACROSS THE
STATE- THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER SOME
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- FOR EXAMPLE DANIEL
BATES OR AND OVER AT THE BENCH
LEE A FIVE YEAR OR TEN YEAR
REVIEW AND- IF IT WERE TO DO
THAT TYPE OF GROUP REVIEW WE
RECOMMEND- HAVING THAT CONDUCTED
BY AN OUTSIDE PARTY- FINALLY WE
NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO IMPLEMENT THE
SPENDING PLAN. THROUGH BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AND WE SUGGEST
DEVELOPING INSTEAD TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH THE PLAN'S
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY. THANK THE
DRUG ON CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT PIPELINE AND WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT WORK FORCE ACROSS ALL
ALL AREAS OF HEALTH. THIS NUMBER
COME UP YOU WANT TO START DO YOU
WANT ME TO START NO YEAH GO
AHEAD. SO I THINK THEY'RE NOT OF
THINGS WE ARE TRYING TO DO TO
TRY TO BUILD THE PIPELINE. ONE
YEAH WE HAVE SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM GOALS AS WE LOOK AT OUR
WORK FORCE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AN
AGING POPULATION AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO RECRUIT-
I'M MORE DIVERSE. WORK FORCE AND
SO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING IS. REALLY LOOKING AT I'M
TRYING TO DO A FIRST OFF A
PUBLIC HEALTH CAMPAIGN WHAT IS
PUBLIC HEALTH WHY DO YOU. WHY
SHOULD YOU COME TO WORK FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH HOW IS IT DISTINCT
FROM HEALTH CARE AND WE'RE GONNA
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL. HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO COME UP WITH
THAT TIME AND WE REALLY THINK
THAT THAT'LL BE A START TO TRAIN
TO ATTRACT NOT ONLY. PEOPLE FROM
THE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO MAYBE
STUDENTS AND OTHERS WE PUT IN
PLACE THIS YEAR WHAT WE'RE
CALLING OUR PATHWAYS PROGRAM
WHERE WE'VE TAKEN FORTY FIVE
PEOPLE FROM. VERY DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND PLACED THEM WE
HAVE A TRAINING PROGRAM WE
PLACED FORTY FIVE PEOPLE IN
ACROSS THE STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. ALL AND
BROUGHT THEM TOGETHER SO THEY
THEY GET SOME STATE EXPERTISE
AND TRAINING BUT THEY ALSO GOT
SOME LOCAL EXPERIENCE AND WE
THINK IT'S A WAY NOT ONLY TO
GROW THE PIPELINE. TO GET PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN THIS WORK TO GET
THEM EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
QUALIFY FOR SOME OF THE HEALTH-
POSITIONS BUT ALSO WE CAN PLACE
THEM IN SOME OF THE COUNTIES
THAT STRUGGLE TO. TO HIRE AND SO
THAT'S ONE WAY TO GROW THE
PATHWAY WE ARE WORKING AND HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH ON. OUR
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM AND THE
IMPACT IT WE'VE HIRED PROBABLY A
THIRD OF THE INTERNS THAT COME
TO OUR DEPARTMENT. ACROSS THE
CSU ON CAMPUSES. AND WE WANT TO
EXPAND THAT AND WE WANT TO DO
MORE WITH HIGH SCHOOLS AS WELL-
AND OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ALSO
WANT TO BECAUSE I CAN. SAY WHEN
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL I WOULDN'T
HE WOULDN'T HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT A
CAREER IN PUBLIC HEALTH. I
SCHOOL STUDENTS DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS
NECESSARILY MAYBE NOT WITH THE
PANDEMIC. THAT'S CHANGING A
LITTLE BIT BUT I THINK THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS WE NEED TO DO TO
TRY TO MAKE PUBLIC. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT A FIREMAN AS
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKER ANTS AND SO. HOW
DO WE START TO REALLY GROW THAT
HOW WE PARTNER MORE WITH THE-
INSTITUTE. AND WITH OUR COME
BASED OR- BECAUSE THEY
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY- THE
COMMUNITY. CAN BE HELP TO.
PUBLIC HEALTH FORWARD SHOULD BUT
pHAVE. THAT WE LOOK AT THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS WERE
LIVED EXPERIENCE CAN BE AS-
IMPORTANT. AND THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING AS SOME OF THE
ACADEMIC REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
MAY HAVE BEEN SO WE MAY NEED TO.
HAVE SOME NEW CLASSIFICATIONS
THAT HELP US TO BUILD THAT
PIPELINE AS WELL. AND SO TRYING
TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS ACROSS.
THE STATE TO TRY TO ADD TRACKED
MORE AND A BUILD A PIPELINE WITH
SCHOOLS WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND BY LOOKING
FURTHER INTO OUR WHAT WE LEARNED
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND PROBABLY
HAVE KNOWN. FOR SOME TIME AS WE
NEED TO ATTRACT PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT SKILLS THAT.
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH AT B.
WE NEED ALL OF THAT WE NEED OUR
SCIENTISTS. BUT WE ALSO NEED THE
STRATEGISTS AND WE NEED PEOPLE
WHO. BUILD STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS WE NEED
INFOGRAPHICS PEOPLE WE NEED TO.
HAVE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
POSITIONS THAT. FILL OUT OUR
WORK FORCE AND SO REALLY. KIND
OF LOOKING ACROSS THE DIFFERENT.
SECTOR OF SOCIETY LOOKING WALK
WHAT CAN WE ADD TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FOR. HOUSING HELPS
WITH THAT. I THINK. IT'S BEEN SO
LONG WE'VE JUST BEEN IN THE
TRENCHES. THERE HASN'T BEEN- THE
TIME OR ATTENTION TO KINDA LOOK
UP AND LOOK FORWARD. CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE LAB
NETWORK WE ALL HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THAT IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- AND THEN OFTENTIMES
COUNTIES WERE CONTRACTING WITH
LAB SAID. THAT WEREN'T QUITE
REPUTABLE ANALYSTS DID UP A
DISASTER WITH DATA. BEING ABLE
TO GET AROUND CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MORE ABOUT THE
LAB NETWORK. LOCALLY AND THE
INVESTMENT OUR OUR PLANS FOR
FUTURE INVESTMENT IN THAT. SO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT TIME LINE FOR
PUTTING THIS PLAN TOGETHER
DIDN'T ALLOW US ENOUGH TIME. BUT
WE REALLY ARE THINKING THROUGH
WHAT. NOT ONLY HOW MANY LABS DO
WE NEED ACROSS THE STATE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT WHAT SHOULD
THEY BE DOING. AND WHAT PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS AT WHAT LEVEL SHOULD
TAKE ON WHAT WORK BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE THE-
DUPLICATION. WE RECOGNIZE WE
NEED TO HAVE A STRONG LABORATORY
NETWORK WHERE. EVERY STATE EVERY
COUNTY HAS ACCESS TO THE TESTING
THAT THEY NEED AND SO WE WILL BE
COMING BACK TO THAT. IN TERMS
OF. YOU KNOW OUR LABS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ACROSS THE NETWORK TO
MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THINK THROUGH WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE. AND WE'RE PROBABLY SIX
MONTHS UNDER BRAND IF YOU HAVE
COMMENTS ON THIS BUT WE'RE
PROBABLY. SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
OUT AND MAKING SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY'RE- LOOKING
AT RECRUITMENT LOOKING AT
TRAINING- YOU KNOW IT'S- REALLY
HARD FOR US WHEN WE HEAR THAT
YOU KNOW SOMEBODY HAS ALL THE
EQUIPMENT AND THEY CAN'T FIND A
LAB DIRECTOR AND THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THEIR LAB OPEN
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A LAB
DIRECTOR- AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE TRAINING PROGRAMS
WE HAVE AGAIN. A PIPELINE TO
BRING PEOPLE AND TO YOU OUR
LABORATORY POSITIONS AND RELATED
TRAINING THEM AND SO WE PUT SOME
MONEY. ON IN OUR- MAN PLAN THAT
WOULDN'T. TRAINING FOR LAB AS-
AND I KNOW. THAT THE COALITION
ALSO HAS SOME. ON FURTHER
TRAINING. T. WE'RE- EXPAND ON
OUR LABORATORY NETWORK. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF TOMAS OR BRANDON
HAVE ANY MORE TO SAY ON THE LAB.
YEAH NOT NOTHING TRACK. OKAY AND SPEAKING OF THE LAB AND
LOCALS IT. AS AS YOU SERVE AS A
HUB AND I KNOW OUR MIGHT MIGHT
HELP DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN IN A
LOT OF CONTACT I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT. ABOUT COUNTIES
THAT ARE POLLUTING- SPECIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS AT A
HIGHER RATE AND IF THE PLAN AS
OF THE STATE AND THE DEPARTMENT
COULD HAS A PLAN OF WHAT WE DO
IF WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO SEND
MORE RESOURCES. TO THIRTY TWO
COUNTIES THAT ARE UNDERSERVED
WITH THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
HAVE HIGH DEGREES OF- OF DISEASE
AND NEED IN THEIR AREAS. I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE CAP CAPACITY
BUILDING THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
THESE DOLLARS WERE- ALLOW US TO
DO MORE- I'M WE WILL ALSO HELP
TO TRY TO RECRUIT. PEOPLE FOR AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND USE SOME
STRATEGIES LIKE THE PATHWAYS
PROGRAM WHERE WE CAN PLACE
PEOPLE BUT ALSO WORKING WITH
CONTRACTS AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC TO PLACE PEOPLE IN
SOME OF THESE HARD TO PLACE.
COUNTIES WHERE YEAH THEY HAVE
EVEN WHEN THEY HAVE THE DOLLARS
AND THEY HAVE THE POSITION THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO ATTRACT AND
SO WE MIGHT HAVE TO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT MODELS OF BRINGING
PEOPLE AND DOING SOME ROTATIONS
MAYBE BRING A MAN TO A STATE
POSITION BUT- HAVING THEM ROTATE
THROUGH- AND- I THINK WE HAVE
SOME MODELS FOR THAT CDC
CERTAINLY HAS SOME MODELS FOR
THAT. AND WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
THAT BECAUSE WE DO YOU KNOW WE
KNOW. THAT THERE ARE SOME AREAS
OF THE STATE THAT GO. AFP OUT.
TIME AND TIME TO IT. PEOPLE IN
THE SAME POSITION. THEY LOSE
PEOPLE THE OTHER COUNTIES THEY
LOSE PEOPLE TO OTHER POSITINS
SO- BUT THAT CAPACITY BUILDING
WE'RE DOING AT THE STATE. HAS
THAT IN MIND AS WELL SO THAT WE
CAN BE A BETTER RESOURCE ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'RE LOKING AT- IS
OUR REGIONAL. HEALTH OFFICE
WHERE WE WILL HAVE AN F. B. NFP
. IN JUST A COMMUNICATIONS
PERSON. YEAH I'M COORDINATING
POSITION AND THAT WILL BE A
RESOURCE TO YOU NOT ONLY. TO THE
REGION BUT ALSO TO SPECIFIC
COUNTIES THAT MAY NEED A LITTLE
MORE HELP WITH THAT WITH THEIR
F. B. DATA MAY NEED I'M A LITTLE
MORE HELP LOOKING BROADER AT AN
ISSUE AND SHARING THE RESOURCES
FROM OTHER COUNTIES AS WELL AS
SHARING SOME STATE RESOURCES SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE IDEA. THAT
THE REASONS CAN BE A RESOURCE
AND IF WE HAVE STAFF AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT CAN HELP MANAGE
THAT THAT WE CAN BUILD A BUILD
THAT OUT AND REALLY LOOK AT
THOSE AREAS OF CONCERN. THANK
YOU AND I GUESS I JUST LIKE TO
MAKE THE POINT I'M SURE YOU'VE
ALREADY THOUGHT OF THIS BUT BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE TO DEPLOY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. FOR STAFF
TO AN AREA IT SEEMS LIKE THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THAT THAT WE
ALSO JUST DEPLOY. EXTRA
COMMUNITY- EDUCATION TO COMBAT
MISINFORMATION THAT HAPPENS THAT
IF THAT IS A THAT IS A SIGN IF
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF DISINFORMATION IN AN
AREA SO WE'RE DEPLOYING JUST
MORE PEOPLE I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE MORE HOLISTIC AND HOW WE LOOK
AT GOING INTO TO HELP. INTERVENE. IN SITUATIONS TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC HEALTHY. I THINK. BUT THE
PATH. THAT THING YOU SO VERY
MUCH AND- FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE LA- FOR THEIR
REPORTS- THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS
BEEN AND ALSO THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN RAISING THESE ISSUES
FOR YEARS- EVEN PRE COATED. WITH
A SET OF MENTIONED- I'VE CHAIRED
TWO HEARINGS ONCE WHEN IWAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAIR OF SIMPLY
HEALTH AND THEN IN THE SENATE-
PRIOR TO COVE ID ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE I'VE KNOWN
I KNOW I'VE CHALLENGED MY- NOT
DIRECTOR GOING YOUR YOUR YOUR
PREDECESSORS TO ACTUALLY DEVELOP
A PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN. IN FACT I THINK A- RATE IT
WILL REINSTATE A PUBLIC HEALTH
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY HAS COVERED
WAS STARTING AND- THAT WAS ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I ASKED
DIRECTOR THEN- IT'S HAPPENED
PREVIOUSLY. IN A GUEST YOU KNOW
AGAIN I. APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION- BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- WHAT THE ALLEY--POINTED OUT- SHOULD CERTAINLY
HAVE NOT BEEN ANY SURPRISE. TO
ANYONE AT C. P. H. SO I THINK WE
ALL THE KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE A
WORKFORCE ISSUE NOW SOME OF THAT
OF COURSE IS OUR FAULT IN PUBLIC
POLICY BECAUSE IT WAS NOT IN
TERMS OF FUNDING- A SHARED A
FUNDING STREAM THAT WAS STABLE
WAS NOT NECESSARILY THAT MAKES
ALWAYS HARD FOR WORK FORCE
RIGHT. I MEAN IT'S GREAT YOU CAN
EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THEY DON'T KNOW WHETHER
YOU HAVE A JOB AND THEY'RE GOING
TO BE A STAY IN A JOB THAT IT'S
A LITTLE HARD TO RECRUIT RIGHT
SO. SO I DO WANT A KNOWLEDGE
THAT- SO THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE CAN DO THAT THIS IS
A COMMITMENT. FOR AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE A BILL THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE UNLESS PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THE WORKERS THERE. THE
WORK IS DEFINITELY THERE BUT
THAT THEY WOULD BE PAID THAT
THAT- THE JACKS POSITIONS TO DO
THAT WORK. THE LAND ISSUE HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR OVER A DECADE
AND- THAT I HAVE ANY KIND OF
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DON'T HAVE
AND I'M HEARING THE. RESPONSES
LIKE ALL WE NEED ANOTHER YEAR.
WE'VE KNOWN. THIS HAS BEEN A
PROPERTY IN FACT BUT THE ME JUST
LAY OUT. LAST YEAR. THE
LEGISLATOR SAID WE WANT A
COMMITMENT FOR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION THE ADMINISTRATION SAID
WELL WE'LL START IT NEXT YEAR
HAVE YOU HAD A YEAR'S WARNING IN
ADVANCE WE'RE COMING SINCE DOING
THIS- AND THEN OF COURSE BEEN
TALK ABOUT LAB IS AN ISSUE. EVEN
BEFORE THEN FOR A LONG TIME. SO
FENCING WITH BY THE WAY IN TERMS
OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AS
WELL. AND SO I GUESS- SO FIRST
OF COURSE I WANT TO. IT'S TEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF WHAT THE LA
BROUGHT UP IN THE NIGHT AND I
DON'T KNOW ILLEGAL MAYBE YOU'RE
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
PREVIOUS HEARINGS BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS THE THINGS WE TALK
ABOUT PIPELINE. WORKFORCE LAB
INFRASTRUCTURE I. T. AND THEN
ALSO- OVERSIGHT THE LOCAL
OVERSIGHT NOW THAT WE ARE
PUTTING SOME STATE FUNDS AND
HERE I THINK IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT. AND THAT WE CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT. BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT. NINE
REALIZE THAT RIGHT NOW THERE'S
NEVER A GOOD TIME BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A PANDEMIC SO
EVERYONE'S REALLY BUSY AT CDPH
DEALING WITH THIS PANDEMIC. BUT
I'M ALSO CONCERNED AS I'M
HEARING SOME OF THE ANSWERS IS
THAT- YOU KNOW I'LL JUST BE
BLUNT- SOMETIMES C. PH HAS A
REPUTATION OF TAKING ITS TIME
GETTING THINGS DONE- YEAH WE'VE
HAD REGULATIONS THAT- WE PASS
LAWS AND- I REMEMBER HAVING A
HEARING BECAUSE THERE'S A-
BECAUSE C. PH AFTER TEN YEARS
STILL HADN'T ISSUED REGULATIONS
AND WE FINALLY. SOMEONE OFFERED
A BILL TO TAKE CARE OF THE
DETAILS. AND SO FORTH SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO ME ABOUT. WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO SO. SO IS THERE A
WAY WE CAN DO THIS FASTER. YEAH
THESE ARE NEW PROBLEMS I MEAN WE
KNOWN THESE THINGS FOR ALL THE
TIME SO YEAH WE HAD AND WE EVEN
HAD A YEAR'S NOTICE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. THAT'S COMING. SO IS
THERE SOMETHING I CAN WE CAN WE
DO THIS FASTER PLEASE- I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU- YOU
KNOW AND I CAN'T CHANGE THAT IN
JANUARY IS MY FIRST YEAR. YES
AND I REALIZE YOU JUST CAME IN
JANUARY. AND SO I FOUND YOU BUT
NO BUT I BUT I'VE BEEN IN PUBLIC
HEALTH NOW. SAID IN IN. HEALTH
OFFICERS FROST IS NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AND I SPEND. MOST MY
TIME IN SAN FRANCISCO- BUT
ANYWAYS I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SORT OF. CONTRAST OF THE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH AND LOCAL
AND LOCAL AT LEAST LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH. I'M FROM THE BAY AREA.
AND I AND I MEAN IT'S ONE OF THE
FOR THINGS I. WHEN I CAME HERE
TO STAY HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
THAT. THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IT
IT'S A BARE BONES INFRASTRUCTURE
IT'S BARE BONES. AND WHEN YOU GO
BACK AND YOU BEGIN TO LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OF. THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IT BECAME A STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS SEPARATE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
TWENTY OH SIX MMHM YEAH AND IT
WHEN T WAS CREATED IF. IT
DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE NECESSARY
COMPONENTS. AND THE N. WORD
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
IS BEGINNING TO REAP BUILDING
SOME OF THOSE COMPONENTS. A LOT
OF THOSE COMPONENTS ARE ARE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE OPERATIONAL. FOR
EXAMPLE- NOT HAVING A DEDICATED
ROBUST OFFICE OF POLICY AND
PLANNING. YOU NEED A TEAM OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE STORED DO INDEED
VANCE PLANNING STRATEGIZING.
FIGURING OUT WHERE WHERE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE WE'RE WE'RE GETTING
NOT JUST TO DO A REPORT BUT HOW
DO YOU MAKE HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT
DEPORT. REPORT COMBINED WITH
EVIDENCE AND THEN TWO AND THEN
TO WORK WITH PARTNERS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. SO THERE THERE IS A
LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THAT
HAS BEEN MISSING. AND FOR ME
THAT'S THE REASON WHY I CAME
FROM LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH THE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH. BECAUSE I
ANTICIPATED IT JUST WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE SOME OF THIS
MONEY AND FIX SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. I AGREE WITH YOU WE DO
THINGS WE DO THINGS- NOT FAST
ENOUGH- AND I'M REALLY COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT SO THAT'S ACTUALLY
ONE OF THE REASONS. WHY IT WERE
AT AS AN ORGANIZATION. OR HAVING
A STRONG. THE FOCUS ON BECAUSE A
LEADER. TO ME SURE THAT WE DO
THING FAST. AND BETTER FOR CUT.
THE ULTIMATE BECAUSE- WHICH IS
EVERY CAL. BUT ALL THE BUILD THE
LEAD. AS WELL THEY WERE
ACCOUNTABLE TO YOU AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T WE
DELIVER. OUTCOMES UT WE DO IT
IN A WAY THAT SEE EFFICIENT. AND
THEY WERE GOOD STEWARDS OF THE
PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WHAT I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S TENDS
TO HAPPEN IS THAT- YOU KNOW. WE
NEED TO DO THINGS RIGHT- IS
THAT- PEOPLE WANT TO THIS REALLY
THOROUGH YOU KNOW ANALYSIS AND
WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE YOU
DATA AT CETERA. AND THEN WE SAID
ONE TOTALLY GATHER ALL THAT
TOGETHER WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
RIGHT AND THEN IT'S GONNA TAKE
US TWO OR THREE YEARS TOGETHER
ALL THAT GREAT IN FACT ACTUALLY
PUBLIC HEALTH DID DO. SOME MANY
YEARS AGO. THEY DID THIS BIG
THING WHERE EVERY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT CETERA AND THEN THEY
CAME OUT WITH A REPORT IT SAID
ON THE SHELF AND THE BY THE TIME
WE GOT BACK TO IT IT'S LIKE WELL
IT'S KINDA OLD NOW IT'S NOT
REALLY RELEVANT. AND LIKE
NOTHING HAPPENED. SO I DON'T SEE
THAT HAPPEN- I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO THE LOCAL OVERSIGHT
WHEN THEY HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
LOCALS- IN THE PANEL COMING UP.
IT REALLY IS TO BE SURE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A STATEWIDE.
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM SO AND THAT
OF COURSE WE HAVE C. PH AT STATE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE OF COURSE
ALL THE OTHER PIECES AS WELL. WE
WANNA BE SURE THAT IT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE PROPERTY IN
SILENCE SO FOR EXAMPLE AND THEN
NO YOU BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON THIS
R. R. IS THAT- SO. YOU KNOW WE
KNOW DISEASES DON'T STOP AT
POLITICAL BOUNDARIES RIGHT SO
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
OFTEN DEFINED BY POLITICAL
BOUNDARIES BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
A COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
CITY HELP APART WHATEVER RIGHT
SO. HOW DO WE GET AND THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WORK I KNOW YOU CAME TO
THE BAY AREA THERE WAS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE BAY
AREA HEALTH OFFICERS HOW WE DO
MORE OF THAT BUT THEN ALSO HOW
CAN THE STATE. ALSO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. AND ALSO
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT AND CAN I
GET IT YOU GOT BARE BONES SO HOW
CAN WE BUILD THAT IN WITH THIS
INVESTMENT. AND THEN. THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY TO SO THAT THE
STATE MY MANY IS. THE ONLY
COURSE PORTING. YEAH THEY GO TO
A LOCAL SINCE. TO LOW ACTIVITY
BUT ALL. THAT THE- ALSO IN. FOR
THEM BE WORKING TOGETHER SO
WORKING WITH. BY THAT'S THE
LAVISH. A PRIME EXAMPLE WHERE.
BASICALLY H. K. WAS A ON THERE-
OWN FIGURE. HOW TO DO THEIR LAB.
RIGHT AND THEN. IF DECIDE TO. A
LOT AND THE WAY WHAT KIND OF
IT'S A WORKFORCE. I APPRECIATE.
OUT IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THEY
CAN SUPPORT ALLOWED TO CONFINE
THE LAB DIRECTOR RATES. SO WE
HAVE TO BUILD THAT WORK FORCE
OUT TOO BUT- WE SHOULD HAVE A-
SO. SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY SHOULD
BE CONSENSUS IMAC THINKING ABOUT
OKAY SO WHICH LANDS DO WE NEED
BOTH STATE LAB. AND LOCAL LABS
RIGHT DO WE YEAH DO WE NEED TO
CONVINCE THE COUNTY TO OPEN ONE
UP. DO WE HAVE TO IS THAT SO.
BUT THESE ARE BEING DONE
SYSTEMATICALLY IS KIND OF DONE
BY. SO I CAN'T EVEN MAKE A
DECISION AND THEN ALL THE OTHER
COUNTIES AROUND WOULD HAVE TO
JUST THAT RIGHT WHETHER DATE IS.
MAY DECIDE TO CLOSE THE LAB SO-
SO WE NEED MUCH MORE. SO WE
THINK WE DO NEED TO HAVE A-
DIRECTION TOWARD. THIS
COLLABORATION TO BUILD A PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM. AND OF COURSE I
MEAN IDEALLY NATIONALLY AS WELL
BUT- CERTAINLY SOME TOWARDS THE
GOVERNMENT. A CALIFORNIA BIG
STATE. HOW DO WE BUILD OUT SOON
WITH THE IT INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING MUCH
MORE ABOUT THAT. AND THE NEXT
ITEM. BECAUSE THIS PARTY ONLY A
LITTLE PIECE OF IT HERE. RIGHT
WE NEED A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH IT SYSTEM THAT INTERFACES
ACTION WITH ALL THE OTHER
HEALTH. IT SYSTEMS AS WELL RIGHT
BECAUSE IT WOULD CAUSE RIGHT NOW
UNTIL THAT WE'RE HEARING STORIES
ABOUT. LITERALLY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. GETTING RESULTS
FAXED OVER THEM. FACT THESE
FAXES ARE ACTUALLY IN HELL CARE
ALSO WE DO BILLING AND SELF I
MEAN THAT THAT AND THEN SOME HAS
TO TAKE A PIECE OF SENATE EASIER
TO KNOW WHAT TRY IF DOES AND
THEN TAKE IT BACK TO THESE OF
PAPER THEN RE ENTER ELECTRO INTO
THE THIS IS RIGHT UP A LOT OF
WAYS TO TIME AND F. AND PROBABLY
VERY TELL FIRST WHO YOU WANT I
CAN PUT HEALTH DOESN'T TO BE.
PICKING UP A FAX AND THEN AND
DATA AND THAT'S REAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OKAY BUT WE'RE USING
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSONNEL TO DO
THAT RIGHT THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
A GREAT ADVERTISEMENT FOR DOING
PUBLIC HEALTH- THE OTHER THING I
ALSO JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON
BRIEFLY UNFORTUNATELY IS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WORKFORCE AT
LEAST WITH THIS PANDEMIC. SAFETY
WE'VE HAD LOCAL PUBLIC. OFFICE
BASICALLY GET DEATH THREATS
PUBLIC. PEOPLE HAVE BEEN.
BRITAIN AND BULLIED- AND- YOU
KNOW THAT'S AGAIN GONNA BE AN
ISSUE FOR WORK FORCE- RETENTION
AND SO FORTH AND- AND SO A
REALIZES THAT PERHAPS A BIGGER
CONVERSATION THAN JUST CD PH BUT
CERTAINLY SEE IF EACH OTHER ROLE
IN. CONVERSATION WITH THE
MINISTRATION MORE BROADLY BUT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY FOLKS AND SO
FORTH- BOTH THE SAFETY PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS HAND ALSO
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
RIGHT FOLLOWING THE LAW LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO ENFORCE THE
LAW. SO IN THE LAW AND PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
OUR RIGHT I MEAN I THINK HE I
THINK WAS REALLY BEFORE RIGHT SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF VERY.
BRAVE PUBLIC SAFETY- FIRST
RESPONDERS OUT THERE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS PUBLIC SAFETY HE DIED
OF A DISEASE YOU'RE JUST AS YOU
DIED OF A BULLET. AND WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE PUBLIC HEALTH IS THAT.
SO SO ANYWAY I KNOW YOU ANY
COMMENTS BUT WE JUST SAID BUT
AGAIN I. GO I APPRECIATE YOU
RECOGNIZING THESE ISSUES WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP PUSHING ON YOU. ON
THIS AS WELL- BUT WE LIKE TO SEE
MORE DETAILS BY TIME WE ACTUALLY
PASSED A BUDGET SO RELEASES THE
FIRST CUT BUT ALSO IT'S NOT
RECOGNIZED IT THESE ARE NO THESE
ARE NOT NEW ISSUES WE'VE KNOWN
ABOUT THIS FOR A LONG TIME SO.
WHEN I HEAR YOU NEED MORE YEARS
TO FIGURE IT OUT. LITTLE
FRUSTRATED SO NOW. YEAH THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. ALL YOUR SUPPORT YOUR
SUPPORT AND- EVERYTHING THAT YOU
SAY IS VALID- WEEK WE RECOGNIZE
IT. AND WORK FOR COMMITTED TO.
COMMITTED TO DELIVER RESULTS
INTO BEING ACCOUNTABLE AND
WORKING WITH YOU IN PARTNERSHIP
TO TRY. TO BECOME A BETTER A
BETTER PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM ONE
OF ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED IS THAT. DAY I FEEL
THAT I'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE TO
BEING IN SITUATIONS WHERE.
LOCALLY AND THAT'S A STATE WITH
A LEGISLATOR TO REALLY HAVE. THE
SUPPORT OF ELECTED OFFICIALS IT
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
WORLD AND SO. I'M I'M REALLY
INSPIRED AND HOPEFUL AND
CONFIDENT. THAT ITH YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT WE WILL WE'LL
BE ABLE TO YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
SEE. MEASURABLE IMPROVEMENTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEDIA. AND ON
THAT LOCAL OVERSIGHT WE WILL BE
PROVIDING MORE DETAILS ON THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
JOHN THE CHIP IS NOT THE END ALL
FOR EVERYTHING AND THAT THEY ARE
MY OFTEN BIGGER. WE ARE
CONNECTING TO THE STRATEGIC
PLANS WE MET THIS WEEK WITH. OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS TO TALK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN. REALLY LOOK AT SOME
STATEWIDE METRICS AND WE ARE
SETTING UP A TEAM OF PEOPLE THAT
WILL BE. RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING RESPONDS AND GETTING
THE FUNDS OUT THE DOOR BUT ALSO.
LOOKING AT HOW THEY ARE GETTING
SPAN TO WHAT THEY'RE BEING SPENT
ON AND THEN HOW WE SET UP
METRICS SO THAT WE CAN TRACK AND
EVALUATE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE HAVING. YOU ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE WITH THESE DOLLARS SO
MORE. TO COME ON THAT AND WE
WILL. WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE ALL
OF THAT IN PLACE. JULY FOR. OKAY
THAK YOU I DO SAY IT IT'S SET
UP. YOU MY FAVE PART. TELL ME
WHAT YOU. THANK YOU. WE THANK DR
PRATT FOR HIS LEADERSHIP OVER
THE YEARS. HE HAS BEEN THE- THE
POKER IN THE PRIOR ON THIS END
AND NOW HE- HE HAS CERTAINLY
PROVED HIMSELF TO BE RIGHT AND
SO WE WANT TO GO FORWARD AND-
I'M NOT JUST BEING RIGHT OR
WRONG BUT JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THE PUBLIC SAY SAFE AND- AGAIN.
WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THE PANDEMIC BY
CUSTOMER BASE BY SURPRISE BUT-
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO BUILD UP
OUR SYSTEM OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM. THEM OUR OUR PANEL
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE MICHELLE
GIBBONS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. GONNA HAVE MATT
PLEASE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ADVOCATE FOR SJ U. CALIFORNIA.
KAREN SAVAGE SWING SWING IN
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK OR C. FAN AND MATTHEW
MARCIN SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT. OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
ALL OUR GUESTS OUR PANELIST. I
WILL PROVIDE A LIST OF QUESTIONS
TO HELP GUIDE THEM IN THEIR-
PRESENTATIONS TO US AND WE WOULD
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS MACHEL GIVENS WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WANT TO THANK THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE. LEADER LAST
LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR AND
PRIORITIZING FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING FOR
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AND BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
BEGIN TO REBUILD OUR DECIMATED
WORKFORCE OUR MEMBERS WE UTILIZE
THIS FUNDING TO RETAIN STAFF
HIRED DURING THE- DURING THE
PANDEMIC WITH FEDERAL ONE TIME
CODE NINETEEN FUNDS. AS WELL AS
ADDING NEW STAFF AND EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF THEIR DEPARTMENT. IN
REGARDS TO HOW THE STATE CAN
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING OUR SMALL RURAL
JURISDICTIONS SEVERAL STRATEGIES
COME TO MIND MANY THAT SEEM TO
ALIGN WITH WORDS WHAT DOCTOR ARE
GOT HIS START AS STATED EARLIER-
STRATEGIC PLANNING. PROVIDING
CLEAR GUIDANCE ON STATEWIDE
PRIORITIES AND ACTIONABLE TOOLS
THAT CAN SUPPORT LOCAL
APPROACHES. ALSO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON VARIOUS FUNDING
STREAMS IN GRANTS IN AN EFFORT
TO BREAK DOWN THE SILOS AND
FURTHER STATEWIDE PRIORITIES
HELP TO REBUILD OUR WORKFORCE BY
INCREASING TRAINING PROGRAMS IN
PROVIDING STATEWIDE TRAININGS ON
VARIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH TOPICS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS DONE WITH
CONTACT TRACING- TRAININGS THAT
WERE PROVIDED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. COURTNEY COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS THROUGH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO ACHIEVE
STATEWIDE GOALS AND AVOID
DUPLICATION AND DESPERATE
EFFORTS. PROVIDE REAL TIME
MODELING AND DATA ON PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES AND FOR SMALL
RURAL JURISDICTIONS PROVIDE DATA
THAT IS JURISDICTION SPECIFIC
AND DOES NOT WANT THEM IN WITH
OTHER SMALLER JURISDICTIONS
GIVEN THEIR UNIQUE COMMUNITIES.
ACCESS THAT INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY LANDSCAPE IN STATE
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
LEAD EFFORTS TO MODERNIZE PUBLIC
HEALTH IT SYSTEMS. AND THEN
CONTINUED- DETAILED EVALUATION
OF THE STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING LAB CAPACITY AND
WORKFORCE PIPELINE TO BUILD A
ROAD MAP FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE PREPARED TO
ADDRESS PRESENT AND FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS. LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE AND
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
CHALLENGES MANY EXISTED. PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC BUT IT ONLY BEEN
A- BY BURNING. ARREST A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL IN A COME. WITH SECTOR
. LOCAL HOW TO YOUR ANNOUNCE TO
THEIR- NETWORKS THE HOST. WHEN
OPERA. ARE AVAILABLE AND OFTEN
IMPLEMENT GROW YOUR OWN
STRATEGIES WHERE THEY HIRE
SOMEONE TO HELP THEM ATTAIN THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION. DESPITE HIS BEST
EFFORTS A MORE ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IS
NEEDED. THIS IS WHY OUR
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION
IS ALSO SEEKING ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR A VARIETY OF STRATEGIES
INCLUDING RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION STIPENDS. ELIMINATION
OF COST BARRIERS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE CERTIFICATIONS AND
VARIOUS TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD SUPPORT A MUCH NEEDED
WORKFORCE PIPELINE INCLUDE THE
EXPANSION OF THE PATHWAYS
PROGRAM THE MISSPELLING
MENTIONED EARLIER. AND THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S NO. CURRENT FUNDING TO EXPAND THAT
TODAY. THESE CRITICAL TRAIN
INVEST WOULD ALLOW NEW ANY. HOME
HEALTH STAFF TIME TO PURSUE
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION AND ON THE
JOB SKILLS IN ESSENTIAL AREAS OF
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE PREVENTION
AND CONTROL. EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS MICROBIOLOGY
EPIDEMIOLOGY AMONG OTHERS.
THROUGH THESE INVESTMENTS WE
ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES TO THOSE
FROM DIVERSE AND
UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS.
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY DIRECTORS AND
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CERTIFIED
MICROBIOLOGIST IN TRAINED
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT I'D BE HAPPY TO
GO INTO DETAIL ON OUR COALITION
BUDGET REQUEST. AND I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT NUMBER IS GIVEN WE
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION-
WE'LL HEAR FROM METAL IS NOW. IT
LEADS LADY HOW IS IT. EARNINGS
LUCE LUCE OKAY CLOSE UP NO
PROBLEM- MY NAME IS JAY ON
BEHALF OF S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST ONE AT
STAKE THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PRIORITIZING
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. WE DO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY%
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING FOR
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS A COMMITTEE IS
WIDELY AWARE AND WE'VE JUST
HEARD A COUPLE PRESENTATIONS ON
IT PUBLIC HEALTH IS A CORE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTION OF LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS REALLY HAVE BEEN
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC IN AFTER YEARS OF
UNDERFUNDING- AND SHORTAGES TIME
IS NOW TO INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND RETAIN
STOP AND HAVE BEEN TRAINED OUT
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS WELL AS
ADDING ADDITIONAL STAFF TO MEET
THE LONG STANDING STAFFING
SHORTAGES. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE BEEN RAVAGED MICHAEL THAT
NINETEEN OUT MORE DEVASTATING
LEVELS AND WHATEVER OCCURRED HOW
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BEEN
SUFFICIENTLY STAFFED AND
RESOURCE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC-
WITH THIS FUNDING WE BELIEVE
THAT I WILL BE BETTER PREPARED
TO ADDRESS AND RESPOND TO KOBE
NINETEEN AS IT CONTINUES TO RUN.
THROUGH THE ENDEMIC IN FUTURE
HEALTH EMERGENCIES PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE TRULY TEAM
ENVIRONMENTS WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTIGATORS ANALYSTS EDUCATORS
HAVE BEEN EPIDEMIOLOGIST LAB
SCIENTISTS AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS IMPORTANTLY THERE ARE
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS IN
EVERYDAY COMMUNICABLE DISEASES-
OUTSIDE IN SEPARATE FROM COVE IN
NINETEEN AND- UNFORTUNATELY THE
PANDEMIC IS OVERSHADOWED MUCH OF
THIS WORK DUE TO THE LIMITED
CAPACITY SINCE STOPPING AT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. CALIFORNIA
CANNOT WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS HITS
INSTEAD WE MUST INVEST REBUILD
OUR CORE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. AND INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. THIS
IS WHY WE'RE DOING WITH OUR- AND
COLLEGE CAN'T WAIT. TO SEE ONE
TIME. FOR A VARIETY OF STRIDE TO
PRIME THE WORK FORCE. AND
RECRUIT UPSKILL AND RETAIN
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH WORK
WORKERS AND DIVERSIFY THE
WORKFORCE. AS WE FOUND DURING
THE PANDEMIC HAVING PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS THAT COME FROM
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE
HOW TO BUILD PUBLIC TRUST. AND
THIS ADDITIONAL WORK FORCE
FUNDING IS VITAL TO CONTINUE
DIVERSIFYING THE WORKFORCE-
THESE CRITICAL TRAINING
INVESTMENTS WE SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFF TO PURSUE
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION ON THE JOB
SKILLS AND ESSENTIAL. FUNCTIONS
ALTHOUGH MANY OF THE SKILLS ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WORKERS HAVE
BEEN DOING DURING THE PANDEMIC
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKERS TO.
BROADEN THEIR SKILL SET TO
ADDRESS THE MANY CHALLENGES
FACING PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. GIVING STOCK GIVEN
STOP SHORTAGES AND LIMITED
FUNDING IT PREVIOUSLY- THE
BACKFILL FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE- HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO PURSUE
ADDITIONAL SKILLS AND CAREER
ADVANCEMENT. AND UPSKILL- AND
ARE ABLE TO DO SO WITHOUT AT THE
DENTURE WITHOUT BEING TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MISSION YOU'RE REALLY GIVING
THAT TIME AWAY AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT LEAVING THEIR
COWORKERS. I'M WITHOUT ENOUGH
RESOURCES AND HELP. WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN SECURING
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING AND WE SUPPORT THAT
DECISION A WORKFORCE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT US SUPPORT REBUILDING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. WORKFORCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE CONSTANT BEAT THAT WE ALL
TALK ABOUT HIS WORK FORCE AND I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO GET WAY
MORE CREATIVE IN HOW WE THINK
ABOUT. DEVELOPING THAT LATTER
AND NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM KAREN
SAVAGE SWAG. FROM C. FAN. I
THINK IT'S A MUCH I'M SURE MANY
YOU FOR HAVE ME DANCER. IT'S
FROM THE HELP WE CANNOT HELP YOU
WORKERS CAN. AND I WANT TO START
OUT TO BY THINKING DEPARTMENT
ALLEGES. AND ALL OF OUR LOCAL
HEALTH LEADERS MY WORKERS FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS WORK DURING A
PANDEMIC. OFTEN AT GREAT
PERSONAL COST WE OWE A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE TO THE PUBLICSERVANTS. STOOD STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF INCREASING
INVESTMENT IN CORE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDING THE
WORK FORCE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS DATA AND
COMMUNICATIONS PLANS PROPOSED BY
THE DEPARTMENT WHICH ARE
CRUMBLING PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS OST
DETRIMENTAL TO HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. COULD HAVE A LITTLE
ABILITY TO INDIVIDUALLY MITIGATE
THE STATE'S FAILURE TO PLAN FOR
A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND
WE MUST CORRECT. WE ALSO THAT
STRONG EQUITY PUBLIC HEALTH IF.
MUST MULTI. AND MULTI SECTORAL.
PUBLIC HEALTH DOES NOT START AND
END AT THE DOORS OF GOVERNMENT
AND NEITHER DOES RACIAL JUSTICE.
IN FACT IN ORDER TO BUILD AND
SUSTAIN HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WE
MUST HAVE SHARED OWNERSHIP SHARE
LEADERSHIP AND SHARED
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CHANGE.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR
THOSE WHOSE MISSION IT IS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF A STARKLY
EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES. MUST BE
PART OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. WELL THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SPENDING PLAN CONTAINS MANY
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. IT FALL
SHORT IN QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP. THIS SECTION
CONTAINS NO SPECIFIC INVESTMENTS
INSTEAD MERELY PROPOSES TO
CREATE ANOTHER PLAN ALONG WITH A
FEW ADDED STAFF POSITIONS. IN
OUR VIEW THAT FAILS TO MEET THE
MOMENT AND SHORT KNOWLEDGE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE THAT
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS THAT
PLAYED IN BRINGING US TO A TIME
WHEN WE CAN EMBRACE. THE
SECRETARY PUT IT YESTERDAY A
SLOW GLIDE TO NORMAL. WE BELIEVE
THAT AN INVESTMENT IN THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FINE
CAN BUILD ITS MAJOR GAP IN THE
STATE'S PLAN. HEALTHEQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND WOULD GIVE
THE STATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DIRECTLY SUPPORT THE CRITICAL
WORK OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. TO RIGOROUSLY
EVALUATE WHAT WORKS USING. BEST
PRACTICES AND COMMUNITY DEFINED
. COMMUNITY BASED ON. LIKE THREE
CARD ROLE IN INDIAN PUBLIC
HEALTH GOAL FOR DC DISPARITY AND
FROM RCIAL JUSTICE. IT MAY BE
INVISIBLE BUSINESS THEY BRIDGES
THEY CAN TO TRANSFORM. TO ALIGN
COMMUNITY PRIORITIES. MAKING THE
END AS A VISIBLE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ARISEN OUT OF
UNMET NEED OFTEN IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MADE
INVISIBLE BY OUR SYSTEMS AND
PRACTICES. IT IS THEIR SIZE OR
LACK OF POLITICAL POWER. FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE PANDEMIC
PACIFIC ISLANDERS EXPERIENCED
THE HIGHEST DEATH RATES OF ANY
RACIAL GROUP IT DUE TO THE SMALL
SIZE OF THE POPULATION AND ITS
DISPERSED NATURE TRUCK
CALIFORNIA LITTLE WAS READY TO
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY. IN RESPONSE I GOT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS MOBILIZED TO
BUILD A STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADVOCATED FOR THEIR NEEDS
ARE AND WHAT STATE AND COUNTY
EFFORTS STILL ATTENDED TESTING
VACCINATION AND PP DISTRIBUTION.
PROVIDED CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND PROVIDED
HOPE DURING A PERIOD. OF
ISOLATION FEAR. SECOND I'M
BUILDING COMMUNITY BASE ART. ARE
IN TO HAVE A FIND ANY WORLD
INTERNET BETWEEN THE STRUCTURE
OF COPPER AND- OF COMMUNITY. FOR
EXAMPLE I DOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES
WERE PARTICULARLY DEVASTATED BY
THE IMPACT BUT ALSO PARTICULARLY
ISOLATED. FROM THE RESOURCES OF
GOVERNMENT. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE STARTED ITS GAP ACTING AS
TRUSTED MESSENGERS. FINALLY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M IN A
MEETING TO TRANSFORM SYSTEMS TO
ALIGN WITH COMMUNITY PRIORITIES.
AFTER THE LAST TWO YEARS I THINK
IT IS CLEAR TO ALL OF US TO
VALUE EQUITY THAT WE CANNOT GO
BACK TO WORK WE CAN GET BACK TO
NORMAL. INSTEAD WE MUST INNOVATE
AND TRANSFORM TO ELIMINATE
RACIAL AND OTHER INEQUITIES.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HOLD SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE INSURE
CAR BECAUSE A PATIENT IN THE
MOCK CHRISSY AND DEVELOP NEW AND
CREATIVE IDEAS TO SOLVE
SEEMINGLY INTRACTABLE SOCIETAL
PROBLEMS. IT IS THIS ROLE THAT
WE WANT TO SUPPORT TO THE RACIAL
JUSTICE INNOVATION COMPONENT OF
THE FINES. WE MUST BE WILLING TO
INVEST IN NEW IDEAS AND
EXPERIMENTS AND IN COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES IN ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY TACKLE THE
GENERATIONAL IMPACTS OF SYSTEMIC
RACISM. BY KILLING THESE THREE
CRITICAL ROLES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS COMPLEMENT AND
EXTEND THE REACH OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS. AND WE URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER TARGETED INVESTMENTS
IN COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS AN INSTRUMENTAL COMPONENT OF
PUBLIC. HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW GO TO OUR FINAL PRISON TO
TODAY. WITH A MATTHEW MARCIN
FROM SENIOR VICE. OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME'S MATTHEW MONSON SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT FOR PROGRAMS AND
POLICY WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE. FOUNDED IN CALIFORNIA
NOW WORKING ACROSS THE GLOBE YOU
TRIED DESIGNS AND IMPLEMENTS
PROGRAMS THAT ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY AND HELP BUILD AND
STRENGTHEN PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING THE
DEDICATED AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. IT
IS NECESSARY AND LONG OVERDUE
AND DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH. OUR
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
MOST RECENTLY IN THE PANDEMIC
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT EVERYONE
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY FROM STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WE WORK BEST WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER AND WHEN WE ARE FULLY
RESOURCE THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE
SHOWN THAT CBO'S ARE A CRITICAL
PART OF THE LONG TERM PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. NOT JUST
A TEMPORARY SOLUTION DURING A
CRISIS WE'LL ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT IS WHY PH I IS PROUD TO
JOIN MISSY PAN AND OVER TWO
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. IN CALLING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL STATE INVESTMENT OF A
<c.red>UNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN</c>
ONGOING FUNDING TO ESTABLISH THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND. PROVIDING CBO'S FUNDING TO
CBO'S CLINICS AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEVELOP
COMMUNITY LED SOLUTIONS THAT
ADDRESS RACIAL JUSTICE AND THE.
STRUCTURAL AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. I WANT
TO THANK LEGISLATURE. AND
PARTICULARLY THIS. FOR PROVIDING
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE FUND IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. BECAUSE IT
IS EXPOSED TO NUMEROUS LONG
STANDING AND DEEP FRACTURES IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM AND IT
HIGHLIGHTED CONVEYS OF THE
DISPARITIES AMONG COMMUNITIES.
THE DEDICATED RESOURCES PROVIDED
THROUGH THE FUND WILL TACKLE
THESE CHALLENGES HEAD ON. THE
GROUND FUNDS WILL BUILD POWER IN
CBO'S SO THEY CAN IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE MOST PRESSING HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND RACIAL INJUSTICE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES CAUSED BY
THE STRUCTURAL AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. FROM
HOUSING DRINKING WATER FOOD
SYSTEMS THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT TO
POLICING AND PUBLIC SAFETY TO
PARTICIPATION IN LOCAL DECISION
MAKING. THE WAY WE DO THAT IS BY
FUNDING COMMUNITIES DIRECTLY AND
TRUSTING THEIR EXPERTISE. CBO'S
HAVE A DEEP AND UNIQUE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROOT CAUSES
OF HEALTH INEQUITIES AND RACIAL
INJUSTICE NECK COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY ARE BEST SUITED TO TAILOR
EFFECTIVE. CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY CENTERED
SOLUTIONS TO LOCAL CONCERNS.
THEY'RE ALREADY A KEY COMPONENT
OF OUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE ONE THAT LOOKS. AND
SPEAKS THE LANGUAGE OF THE
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES. THEY'RE
ALSO A VALUABLE SOURCE FOR THE
PIPELINE INTO GOVERNMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT WAS NOTED
EARLIER TODAY. CEOS NEED TO BE
VALUED AS EXPERTS ENTRUSTED AND
EMPOWERED WITH THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE CHANGE. ALONG WITH THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORT TO MAKE THEM A SUCCESS.
WHEN WE STEP BACK AND LET THEM
LEAD COMMUNITIES DO BETTER. AND
WE HAVE BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES.
I WANT TO BRIEFLY SPEAK TO THE
QUESTIONS RAISED IN TODAY'S
AGENDA REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- THAT
WOULD REQUIRE A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE
20% OF COMMUNITY BENEFIT FUNDS.
SPECIFICALLY AT HOW COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVED
FUNDING. LIKE MANY STAKEHOLDERS
WE WERE SURPRISED TO LEARN OF
THE PROPOSAL. P. H. I. DOES HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
COMMUNITY BENEFIT AND DR KEVIN
BARNETT A PH I. PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR IS ONE OF THE
NATION'S FOREMOST COMMUNITY
BENEFIT POLICY EXPERTS. GIVEN A
ROUGH ESTIMATE OF QUALIFIED
SPENDING OF APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
TO EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. APPLICATION OF THIS
REQUIREMENT COULD DOUBLE CURRENT
HOSPITAL EXPENDITURES FOCUSING
ON THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. FLOWING IN COMMUNITIES.
THIS PROPOSAL MERITS CLOSE
ANALYSIS AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS AND CBO'S TO
CONSIDER THE OPPORTUNITIES BUT
CHALLENGES OBSTACLES AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. WE HAVE
PREPARED A POLICY BRIEF WE ARE
RELEASING TODAY SUMMARIZES THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS PROPOSED
CHANGE IT INCLUDES A SHORT
OVERVIEW OF RELEVANT COMMUNITY
BENEFIT HISTORY AND ALSO AT THE
ADDRESS IS WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. BUT
PLEASED TO PROVIDE A COPY TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO OFFER ANY
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS YOU
CONSIDER THE PROPOSAL.
IMPORTANTLY WHILE MANY COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS IN AREAS SERVED BY
NON PROFIT HOSPITALS DO YOU
CURRENTLY RECEIVE FUNDING
THROUGH COMMUNITY BENEFIT. IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ACCESS THE
FUNDS WOULD BE PRIORITIZED IF
THIS PROPOSAL WERE IMPLEMENTED.
IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR WHO WOULD
DECIDE WHAT ISSUES WOULD BE
ADDRESSED OR HOW TO ADDRESS THEM
. THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES NO
SPECIFIC PROVISION THAT WOULD
ALIGN THOSE FUNDS EXPLICITLY
WITH THE GOAL OF ADVANCING
HEALTH EQUITY PROMOTING RACIAL
JUSTICE ALL OTHER STATEWIDE
PRIORITIES. CBO'S ARE THE
VANGUARD OF RACIAL JUSTICE
ACTION STEPPING OUT QUICKLY AND
COURAGEOUSLY WELL OUR SYSTEMS
AND INSTITUTIONS LIKE BEHIND.
WHAT THIS KIND OF FUNDING HELP
OR HINDER THEM IN TAKING BOLD
DECISIVE ACTION TO ADDRESS
RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUES THAT MAY
NOT BE POLITICS OR POPULAR.
IMPORTANTLY MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN ARE NOT SAVED BY A
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS. AND WOULD
NOT LIKELY BE ABLE TO ACCESS
FUNDS AT ALL. FINALLY THE
COMPLEX LEGAL AND REGULATORY
FRAMEWORKS GUIDING COMMUNITY
BENEFIT WOULD MEAN THE FUNDS
WOULDN'T SHIFT AS A RESULT OF
THIS CHANGE FOR CONSIDERABLE
TIME. IF NOT YEARS. COMMUNITIES
NEED ACTION NOW IT IS NOT AN
EITHER OR BUT OF BOTH AND
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD BY
ESTABLISHING THE HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND. WE COME
TO COMMUNITIES FOR THEIR
EXPERTISE WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM
TO SOLVE. ALL TOO OFTEN WHEN
SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES HAVE ONCE
AGAIN FAILED THEM. WE NOW NEED
TO COME TO THEM WHEN THERE WAS
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL. GIVEN THE
CHANCE CBO'S WILL RISE AND MEET
THE MOMENT WE NEED TO TRUST IN
THEM BUILDER POWER PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE RESOURCES AND LIFT UP
THE VOICES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY P. I
AND OUR COALITION IN SUPPORTING
THE HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE AS THE
BUDGET PROCESS MOVES FORWARD TO
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF THE
FUND. AS AN INTEGRATED COMPONENT
ALONGSIDE AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. IN
THE FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. AND TO
THE ADMINISTRATION ITSELF LIKE
EVERYBODY AS IT. I THINK AS
WE'VE ALL SAID MORE TELL US WHAT
WE WHAT YOU NEED. AND HOW YOU
INTEND TO SPEND IT BECAUSE WE
ALL RECOGNIZE. THESE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT NEED TO OCCUR
AND THE FUNDING THAT NEEDS TO GO
OUT- AND I WOULD CONCUR WITH-
OUR LAST PANELIST WHEN I. WHEN I
READ THIS AGENDA ITEM I THOUGHT
WELL THIS IS PAUL SCHEER ISN'T
THAT MEMBERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
PASS POLICY ON FOR YEARS AND-
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT SEEMS TO BE
RIGHT HERE SO. I'M SURE WE'LL
HAVE MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT.
AND WE THINK THE PANELIST FOR
THEIR INPUT CLICK TO PRINT. I
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE PANEL'S
PRESENTATION- WHO I GUESS IS THE
QUESTION FOR- ACTUALLY FIRST OF
ALL- QUESTION FOR- WHAT KIND OF
BUSINESS NOW. CDPH BUT ALSO FOR-
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION
SO- TO HELP THE- HELP DEPARTMENT
SEND THE SEIU. SO YOU'LL JUST
ACTUALLY JUST LAST SUMMER- CC
DID A LARGE STUDY. AND THEY
FOUND THAT OVER HALF OF PEOPLE
WORKING IN PUBLIC HEALTH-
TACTICS BERRIEN SYMPTOMS AT
LEAST ONE SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION. AND THAT PTSD T. WAS
ACTUALLY 10220% HIGHER IN PUBLIC-HEALTH WORKERS THAN THEY WERE
FOR FRONTLINE HEALTH WORKERS THE
ONES ON THE FRONT LINES IN THE
E. R. IN THE ICY USE. WATCHING
PEOPLE DIE- SO WHEN HE COMES SO
AGAIN REALLY AND WE TALK ABOUT
PIPELINE AND SO FORTH- IN TERMS
OF THE PROPOSALS THEY'RE BEING
PUT FORTH- AND AGAIN I FEEL IN
TERMS OF STABILIZING THE
WORKFORCE BEYOND THE STUFF THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED AND I
KNOW THAT- VIA CALIFORNIA WE
COALITION HAS AN ADDITIONAL-
WORK FOR STABILIZATION PROPOSALS
CAN YOU SPEAK TO AND I KNOW HE
DIDN'T DELVE INTO THE DETAILS
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF SUPPORTING OUR EXISTING
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS GIVEN YOU
KNOW WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO THEM. AND BEING SURE
THAT- WE CAN BT- SO COULD YOU
SUPPORT THEM AND HAVE THEM
CONTINUE TO DO THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF IT WE LOSE WE CAN
BUILD THE PIPELINE BUT WE'RE
GONNA LOSE MORE PEOPLE OR BRING
IN WE'RE GONNA BE FALLING BEHIND
- THANK. CAN I MAKE A- PROMISE
STUDENTS FROM THE CITY A- THANK
YOU HIS PERSPECTIVE AND THANK
YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
UP THIS TOPIC. YEAH THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. THAT I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES AND EVERYTHING THAT
YOU MENTIONED IS THAT ACTUALLY
TRUE THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORK
FORCE HAS BEEN TRAUMATIZED. SHE
AND A GOOD PROPORTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMES FROM
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY- COVERED COVERED
NINETEEN. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE DOING HERE AT CPA M. WHAT
WE YOU KNOW AND OUR OUR PLAN IS
TO WORK WITH LOCAL TO REALLY.
MAKE THIS TRUE FOR ALL OF ALL
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IS THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON BECOMING A TRAUMA
REFORM INFORMED AND TRAUMA
RESPONSE ORGANIZATION. AND
BRINGING IN TRAINING TO REALLY.
MAKE EVERYBODY AWARE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRAUMA HOW HOW IT
HOW IT AFFECTS US INDIVIDUALLY
AND IN IN THE WORK SETTING. AND
PART OF THE PART THE IMPORTANT
MESSAGE IS. WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR HEALING AND TRAUMA. WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO DO OUR
HEALING. OURSELVES YOU CAN'T BE
. HEALTH OR- IF YOU'RE NOT A
HEALING ORGANIZATION AND SO WE
ARE GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE TAKE. THE
LATEST ON WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT-
TRAUMA AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
MAKING A PART OF. THE WORKFORCE
EXPERIENCE SO THAT'S THAT'S FROM
UP FROM UP FROM A MENTAL HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH PERSPECTIVE OR
BRINGING IN SOME. CONSULTANTS
THAT WORK AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
WHICH HELPS INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES WHAT IS YOUR
TOPIC AND THEY HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH THE
ISSUE OF. OF CODING AND ITS
IMPACT ON HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HEALTH CARE INSTITUTIONS.
AND THE OTHER THE NEXT THE NEXT-
SO TO OTHER COMPONENTS ONE IS
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
REORGANIZE HOW WE DO OPERATIONS.
SO THAT WE CAN GIVE PEOPLE MORE
BALANCE GIVE PEOPLE TIME GIVE
PEOPLE TIME OFF IT IS BECOMING
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT AND HOW WE
DO THE ESSENCE CAN MAIL SYSTEM
AND DISASTER RESPONSE. AND
BECOMING AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE SO PEOPLE CAN ROTATE
OFF AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TIME TO REST AND TO CATCH
UP INTO K. AND TO CATCH THEIR
BREATH. AND THEN THE LAST
COMPONENT IS REALLY- IT'S GOING
TO BE MOVING FORWARD WITH LOCAL
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE WORKING WITH THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IT'S NOT JUST
HELP PUBLIC HEALTH HAS BEEN.
IMPACTED A LOT OF THESE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED SO IT'S GOING
TO TAKE A LONGER TERM
PARTNERSHIPS- OKAY AND SO YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
IN THAT AREA I WOULD GO AHEAD
AND ANSWER BECAUSE I'M SURE.
THERE'S OTHERS DON'T WANT TO
COMMENT AS WELL. YES THANK YOU
PAN THAT CAR. I JUST JUMP ON
BEHALF THE COLOR AGAINST GIVEN
TO GEAC. AND WE CAN'T UNDER. THE
IMPACT THAT SOME OF THE- DURING
THE PANDEMIC HAD ON OUR OUR
LOCAL HEALTH LEADERS AND
WORKFORCE. AT JUST TO GIVE YOU A
ROUGH NUMBER. SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC WE'VE LOST OVER
SIXTY A LOCAL HEALTH LEADERS A
LOT DEPARTMENT LEADERS THAT
INCLUDES HEATH OFFICERS AGENCY
DIRECTORS PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTORS- THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
LOSS OF KNOWLEDGE SKILL. THOSE
ARE THE MENTORS THAT HELP WITH
SUCCESSION PLANNING AS WELL SO
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT AND DEEP
LOSS IN LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT IT ALSO HAS THE IMPACT OF
DETERRING. FOLKS FROM WANTING TO
COME INTO GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ALSO DETERS THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO. WERE IN THE
PIPELINE AND KIND OF WORKING
THEIR WAY UP AND HOPING TO BE
THE FUTURE LEADERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF NOW SEEN A WHOLE
DISK DIFFERENT SIDE. OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND NOT QUITE SURE THAT
THEY WANT TO EVEN MOVE INTO
THOSE RANKS SO IT IS.
DETRIMENTAL AND IT HAS HAD A
HUGE IMPACT IN I WILL SAY JUST
KNOWING THAT I'VE HAD CLOSE
TOUCH WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
IN WITH THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTORS. THAT THEY GIVE THEIR
LIVES TO THIS WORK YOU KNOW THEY
DO THIS IT ADDED THE PURE
MISSION OF PUBLIC HEALTH- AND
THERE IS THERE IS. FOR THEM I
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
MOMENT WHERE. THEY WILL NEED TO
UNPACK THE TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED THROUGHOUT THIS THIS
PANDEMIC- AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY'VE HAD THE TIME TO SLOW
DOWN AND DO THAT QUITE YET. WITH
THAT SAID THOUGH I DO WANT TO
KIND OF REFOCUS THIS BACK ON
WHAT IS THAT MEAN FOR OUR WORK
FORCE. AGAIN THE FLKS THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO SIT DOWN MENTOR
AND TRAIN OUR NOW DEPARTED IN
SO. YOU KNOW OUR CALIFORNIA
COALITION IS PUT TOGETHER A
PACKAGE OF IDEAS THAT WILL HELP
WITH RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
YOU HAVE- OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT
CAN OFFER SIGN ON BONUSES-
LONGEVITY BONUSES CAN OFFER. A
LOAN REPAYMENT WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE TOOLS AT OUR AT OUR
FINGERTIPS AND PUBLIC HEALTH SO
WE'VE BEEN ASKING. FOR A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION TO HELP WITH
RAT RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STATEMENTS THAT CAN. AND TO
REALLY HELP BUILD THE SKILL SET
SO THAT. WORKER UP SKILL
TRAINING REALLY IS FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT NOW THAT MIGHT NEED
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION SO ALLOWING
THEM THE TIME AND EDUCATION TO
PURSUE THAT. SO THAT THEY CAN
ADVANCE THEIR SKILLS. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH HEALTH PATHWAYS TRAINING
CORPS IS GREAT. AS IS FINALLY
MENTIONED THERE'S- IT CALLED FOR
A FORTY FIVE I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THIS AND I'M SORRY FOR TAKING
THE TIME I SPOKE WITH THE COHORT
AND ONE INDIVIDUAL SAID. HEY I
KNOW I'M A OLDER FACE INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT I JUST ANT
YOU TO KNOW I'M LOVING WHAT I'M
DOING WHICH IS LIKE HEART
STRINGS FOR US. THERE WERE OVER
NINE HUNDRED APPLICANTS FOR THAT
PROGRAM AND SO WE'RE ASKING FOR
TWENTY FOUR MILLION. TO EXPAND
THE PROGRAM TWO HUNDRED TRAINEES
PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS BUT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT EXPANDING
THE PROGRAM TO ALLOW. IN
INTERNSHIPS WITH CSU'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN UC'S TO TRY TO HELP
WITH THAT HI BRIAN IT SHOULD BE
SAID THAT LESS THAN ONE IN FIVE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GRADUATES FROM
SCHOOLS OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ENTERING THE
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. THAT IS A HUGE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINE
CHALLENGE SO THESE NEW
INNOVATIVE WAYS AND INVESTING IN
THESE PROGRAMS ARE NECESSARY WE
HAVE OTHER PROGRAMS FOR
MICROBIOLOGISTS LAB DIRECTORS
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. THESE ARE
TRAININGS THERE ACTUALLY ARE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE GREAT OUTCOMES I
WAS LOOKING AT SOMEONE THAT CAL
EIS TRAINING YESTERDAY FOR
EXAMPLE 78% OF THOSE GRADUATES
THAT HAVE DONE THAT HOW EIS
FELLOWSHIP THE EPIDEMIOLOGY
FELLOWSHIP. ACTUALLY STATING
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
STATE THE SCENE IN CALIFORNIA
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE'RE LOOKING TO HELP
OFFSET THE CHALLENGES THAT WERE
HAVING BY A DEPARTING. A
WORKFORCE AND LEADERSHIP BY
INVESTING MORE INTO THAT THE
TOOLS. FOR RECRUITMENT IN
RITUALS FOR TRAINING. I MIGHT
ADD TO THE COMMENTS I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING SEEMS. THIS IS
MATTHEW PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
I WANTED TO ECHO WHAT WE WERE
THE FIRST ORGANIZATION. ELIAN
COVERED WITH- AND SUPPORT WE'RE
PROVIDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST THE CONTACT
TRACING CASE INVESTIGATION. WITH
THE FIRST TO PROVIDE. A STUNT
TEAMS WITH. A COMPREHENSIVE
MENTAL FIRST AID AND TRAUMA ROOM
FULL OF SUPPORT BOTH FOR THEIR
OWN WORK FORCE AS WELL AS FOR
THE COMMUNITIES THEY WERE
SERVING A WE WERE HIRING PEOPLE
FROM THE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
THOSE ARE IMPACTED BY COAL BUT-
I'M ALSO REALLY PLEASED TO
SHARE- THAT- WITH THRILLED TO BE
PARTNERING. WITH THE SCHOOLS AND
PROGRAMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
LAUNCH. A NEW CALIFORNIA
ACADEMIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
PROGRAM. THAT WILL BE BUILDING A
PATHWAY TO DIVERSE PUBLIC HEALTH
GRADUATES AND FACULTY. IN LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THESE WE HAVE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ACROSS. ACROSS
THE STATE WILL BE PARTICIPATING
IN THIS INITIATIVE I'M PONDERING
WITH JACK AND OTHERS IN THE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
REALLY EXCITING. BUT I WILL KNOW
IT IS FUNDED BY THAT'S WHERE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SECURE THE RESOURCES TO
LAUNCH THAT PROGRAM. IN THIS IN
IN THIS FIRST PHASE. AND MANAGED
FROM A U. N. REMARKS. ON THIS I
WAS JUST A LINE- MY COMMENT
SWITH MY COLLEAGUE THE ACCOUNTS
CAN'T WAKE CHANGE SHARE THE RE
IMPORT AND PIANO KNOW YOUR WAY
OF THIS MENTOR. IN A WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE AND LOSING
STAFF REALLY AT A LOCAL LEVELS
YOU KNOW IT'S THAT SORT OF BRAIN
DRAIN BUT ALSO THE PEOPLE WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO
THAT- WILL HELP YOU KNOW HELP
YOU GET THROUGH CRISIS HELP YOU
GET THROUGH. THE CARE AND SO
JUST THAT THAT FURTHER DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE NEED TO REALLY BOTH
PRIME THE PIPELINE BUT THEN ALSO
ENSURE THAT THIS FUNDING- THAT
DIGITAL FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PRPOSAL COMES IN SO
THAT YOU CAN- YOU KNOW HOW DID
YOU SPELL STOP IT ETAIN STAFF
AS WELL- SO WE HAVE THAT
MENTORSHIP WHICH ISN'T REALLY
PROVEN MODEL AND- THAT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SPACE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER COMMENTS ON MAKER AND THAT
THERE'S BEEN- APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY. ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
FOR. CAN BE BETTER FINE- YEAH I
DO THEY SHARED CONCERNS I IT'S A
BIT PROBLEMATIC. THIS IS POINTED
OUT. THREE PEOPLE WITH IT'S NOT
THE COMPANY LAND. FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE WEATHER SERVICE AREAS ALL
THE HOSPITALS AND WHAT TYPE AND
THE LEVELS CAN BE BENEFITS THE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE- BECAUSE- BUT
MY GUESS. ALTHOUGH AGAIN I
ALWAYS APPRECIATE DATA. IS THAT
HOSPITALS IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES PROBABLY ALREADY-
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES- THEY TEND
TO HAVE THE- MORE MEDIC TELL US-
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE WE PAY A
FEW RESOURCES AND THEREFORE BE
MIGHT DO. A PROPORTIONAL S.
COMMUNITIES OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE A LOCAL HOSPITAL
WITH THE ABOUT LOVE A RURAL
COMMUNITIES. SO THEN YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE GONNA SAY 25% WELL HOW'S
THAT DISTRIBUTED ACROSS OUR
STATE RIGHT WHERE WHERE THERE'S
A SIDE FROM THE OTHER MECHANICAL
ILLEGAL ISSUES AND SO FORTH
ABOUT. HOW YOU KNOW HOW WE CAN
DIRECT THE MONEY ETCETERA. JUST
EEN TO DISTURB YOU KNOW WHERE
THE FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY SITTING
RIGHT NOW ALREADY DISTRIBUTED IN
A WAY SINCE YOU'RE DEPENDING ON
HOSPITALS- IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY REFLECTS THE NEED- AS
WELL AND- AND SO. I THINK THAT'S
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING AND-
NOT SURE THAT'S REALLY THE MIGHT
BREAK MECHANISM BUT- CERTAINLY
WOULD APPRECIATE IF THAT'S TO
CONTINUE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
THATMUCH MORE IN DEPTH ANALYSIS
OF HOW DO YOU SURE. WE MEET
THOSE COLORS THAT WERE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE IN TERMS OF EQUITY
AND SO FORTH AND HOW THOSE
RESOURCES DISTRIBUTED- BEFORE
WE'D ENTERED YEAH SEARCH
ENTERTAIN- ADOPTING THAT
GUESS ONE LAST QUESTION IS THAT.
IN TERMS OF COMMUNITY OUT REACH
AND WE TALKED YOU KNOW EVERY P.
C. C. TEN AND C. H. I TALK ABOUT
THE COMING OUT RIGHT. NOW WE
DEVELOPED A MODEL FOR THE
CENSUS. I MEAN IT WAS A SORT OF
BIG CAMPAIGN WE NEED TO GET
PEOPLE THOUGHT SENSES ND SO
FORTH AND I KNOW SOME OF THE
FOLKS I BELIEVE WHO WORKED ON
THAT ARE EACH ARE NOW WORKING
WITH CPS THAT C. P. H. ON SOME
OF THE OUTRAGE. THAT WAS THAT
WAS THAT POTENTIALLY- THE MODEL
THAT THEY HOPE WILL THE LESSONS
WE LEARNED FROM THAT WAS IT IT
DID THREE IT IS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD LEARN FROM THAT AND TERMS
OF OUR APPROACH FOR. AN ONGOING
EFFORT TO STAY IN PUBLIC HEALTH-
TO BUILD THOSE- COMMUTER
RELATIONSHIPS AND- AND
MESSAGING. YEAH LET ME ASK
ASSISTANCE IN LA TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN WORKING
ON A VACCINE AREA WHERE THAT.
SPEND IT. IN A PART APART. OF
OUR VACCINE AFTER. YEAH I'M
SORRY THINK WE WERE A LOT A LOT
THROUGH THAT THOSE PART WITH
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED CD ACROSS
THE STATE THAT THERE ARE A
CRITICAL PART IN OUR BACK
STRATEGY IN TERMS NOT ONLY
BRINGING THE RESOURCE TO COME BY
DR THE DEMAND AND HELP TO ANSWER
ADDRESS. THAT THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL- WE DEFINITELY SEE THE
PARTNERS SO CBO A CRITICAL TO
IMPROVING HEALTH I THINK YOU ARE
ON WORK ON THE COMMUNITY BENEFIT
IS CERTAINLY CERTAINLY A
PARTIALLY AN ANSWER I THINK THAT
IT DOES BRING SOME RESOURCES IT
WON'T BRING IT EVERYWHERE IN THE
STATE BECAUSE AS YOU SAY THIS
WON'T REACH EVERY CORNER OF THE
STATE IN TERMS OF WHERE THE
HOSPITALS ARE LOCATED. THERE ARE
SOME TECHNICAL CHALLENGES WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE WE'RE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH THAT WORD
DRESSING SOME OF THE ISSUES
BROUGHT UP BY NOT ONLY THE
HOSPITALS BUT BY SOME OF THE
CBO'S IN TERMS OF HOW WE MIGHT
MAKE THIS WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INVESTMENTS AND WE'VE WE'VE
DONE SOME MASTER MASTER H. GUY
OF WHAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT COULD
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE ABOUT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS SPENT ON
COMMUNICATING ON. THE BENEFIT
NOW OF THAT ABOUT FOUR BILLION
OF IT IS ON UNCOMPENSATED CARE
SO WE WOULDN'T BE TOUCHING THAT
MONEY BUT 25% OF THE REST OF THE
MONEY IS STILL A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT THERE ARE
SOME CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF THE
REACH OF THAT WHAT THIS MONEY
GETS SPENT ON SO WE'RE TRYING TO
CLARIFY AND COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT WOULD HELP US TO
REALLY DRIVE COLLECTIVE IMPACT
AND- FOCUS ON EQUITY AND SOME OF
THE ISSUES WHERE WE DO WANT TO
SEE THESE INVESTMENTS GO. AND
YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK IT WILL
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO GET
THESE IN PLACE AND TO MOVE THE
DIAL BETWEEN WHERE THEY'RE
INVESTED NOW AND HOW WE GET
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THAT I
THINK WE'RE ALSO DRIVING TOWARDS
TRANSPARENCY IN THE REPORTING
AND HOW THIS INFORMATION GETS
REPORT IT- SOME MORE WORK TO
COME WILL BE SHARING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- AS WE
FLUSH IT OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE AND- COMMUNITY OUT OF
IT. YOUR COMMUNITY BASED.
ORGANIZATIONS IN IMPROVING
PUBLIC I'LL- ACROSS THE STATE
AND I THINK P. H. I. AMAZING
AND- OF. CONTACT RACER AND WORK
WITH OUR LAW JURIST. AND SHOWING
. THE WAY THAT WE CAN WORK
DIFFERENTLY AND THEN IN OUR
VACCINE STRATEGIES. THAT WORK
ACROSS COMMUNICATIONS AND THEN
WITH OUR CBO'S TO REALLY PUT
RESOURCES PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREAS WHERE. WE WERE NOT SEEING
THE MOST IMPACT ON THE LEAST
RESOURCES SO THAT WE SAW. THAT
TESTING WHERE WE PLACED OUR
TESTING SITES WHERE WE PLACED
OUR VACCINE CLINICS AND MOBILE
RESOURCE SAYS. AND THEN
PARTNERING THAT SO NOT ONLY
WOULD WE CREATE THE EVENT. BUT
WE WOULD HAVE C. B. I WAS ON THE
GROUND THAT COULD. PROVIDE
TRANSLATION SERVICES GET PEOPLE
TO COME TO THOSE EVENTS. AND THE
ANSWER AND ADDRESS EDUCATION
QUESTIONS- THAT REALLY HELP TO
GET US. WHERE WE NEEDED TO BE
AND SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
SO. MORE TO COME ON THIS. IF I
MAKE ON THIS QUESTION ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THAT REGION THAT TYPE
OF. COMMUNITY BASED CAMPAIGNS
THINK WE DO SEE THAT. AS A
REALLY EFFECTIVE MODEL AND ONE
THAT THE STATE DID YOU REPLICATE
WHEN IT CAME TO DOING OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION. AROUND HOPING
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE WERE
ROLLING OUT SCENES IN TRYING TO
PARTICULARLY TARGET. COMMUNITIES
WITH THE HIGHEST NEED BUT I
THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
DESCRIBING FOR MANY YEARS WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHICH IS THAT WE
DON'T INVEST UNTIL WE HAVE A
REALLY SPECIFIC NEED AND CRISIS
AND SO WE DON'T BUILD THAT LONG
TERM CAPACITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY. THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT ON
SOME OF THESE IMPACTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. EXCELLENT POINT
THANK YOU. A IS THAT AT THE IS
NOT TO A DRIVER. YOU COMMENTS
COMMUNITY. FROM THE- REPORT
WE'RE RELEASING TODAY THE BRIEF.
BEGINS TO ADDRESS EXACTLY THOSE
ISSUES BUT BUT MORE DISCUSSION
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH THE
HOSPITALS- AND ALSO WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
PARTICULAR AROUND FOR EXAMPLE
THE IRS APPROVED CATEGORIES FOR
COMMUNITY BENEFIT. AND THEN HAT
ACTION CAN BE TAKEN TO THE STATE
OR THE LOCAL LEVEL AND TO
SUPPORT SOME OF THAT. INCREASE
SPENDING UPSTREAM AND-
STRUCTURAL AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SO WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL. THAT'S A LOOK AT
THAT MORE CLOSELY THANK YOU AND
WE SET THE RECORD I'LL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU. AND SO MUCH FOR. HERE
WE HEAR YOU'RE WORKING ON THE
AND YOU HEAR WERE LITTLE
SKEPTICAL SO- OKAY WE THANK OUR
PANEL VERY MUCH- AND JUST JUST
BRIDGES ONE NOTE AS I AS WE'VE
ALL NOTED TO WORK FORCE IS AN
ISSUE AND WE'RE LOSING A LOT OF
THE SENIORS- THOSE MIGHT BE SOME
FOLKS THAT WE CAN GO BACK AROUND
TO ALSO AFTER THEY HAVE A LITTLE
BREAK AND SEE IF THEY WANT TO
COME BACK IN FOR SUPERVISION.
MENTORSHIP SOME OF THOSE MAYBE
NON NIKON CONTACT AREAS OF
WORKING BUT THAT'S UP TO A HUGE
RESOURCE THAT IS STILL OUT THERE
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
INVITED BACK A PERHAPS MORE AT A
SUPERVISOR LEVEL OR- FOR
PROVIDING INPUT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE. NUMBER THREE. GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS JAMES WHITE
AND I'M AN ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. FIND SOME BRIEF
PROGRAMMATIC CONTEXT FOR THE
PROPOSAL AND THEN I'LL HAND OFF
TO THE RIGHT GERMAN SHELL WITH
OUR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES DIVISION. SO PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC S. T. E. PH HAD
INFECTIOUS DISEASE- INFORMATION
SYSTEMS THAT WERE SUFFICIENT FOR
ROUTINE ACTIVITIES BUT THEY WERE
LIMITED IN FUNCTIONALITY. DUE TO
LIMITED RESOURCES AND THE
SYSTEMS WERE NOT SUFFICIENT FOR
THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE. THE
DISEASE REPORTING SYSTEM WAS
QUICKLY OVERWHELMED BY THE
VOLUME OF DATA BEING REPORTED ON
ALL POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE
COMMENT NINETEEN TESTS. WE WENT
FROM AN AVERAGE OF FEWER THAN
TEN THOUSAND INCOMING MESSAGES
PER DAY TO MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY.
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE HAD UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER DAY. IN RESPONSE WE
SET UP A NEW SYSTEM FOR
RECEIVING LABORATORY DATA. AND
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF MEASURES
TO BE ABLE TO RECEIVE ANALYZE
AND REPORT LARGE VOLUMES OF DATA
QUICKLY AND CONSISTENTLY. WE DID
NOT HAVE FLEXIBLE TOOLS TO
SUPPORT CASE INVESTIGATION AND
CONTACT TRACING. WE SET UP A NEW
STATEWIDE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
THESE ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS TO
MOVE DATA BETWEEN SYSTEMS. WE
COULD NOT SEND AUTOMATED
COMMUNICATIONS TO PERSONS
INFECTED WITH ARE EXPOSED TO
COVER NINETEEN. IMPLEMENTING
TOOLS TO SEND AUTOMATED MESSAGES
HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY IN TIMES IN CASE
COUNTS HAVE BEEN VERY HIGH. WE
ALSO NEEDED NEW TOOLS TO SUPPORT
CODE NINETEEN VACCINATION
EFFORTS THAT WERE NOT NEEDED
BEFORE THE ENDEMIC SO WE
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL NEW TOOLS
INCLUDING A TOOL FOR PEOPLE TO
DETERMINE THEIR VACCINE
ELIGIBILITY FIND A VACCINATION
SITE AND SCHEDULE AN APPOINTMENT
- TOOLS TO SUPPORT ORDERING AN
INVENTORY MANAGEMENT FOR VACCINE
PROVIDERS. NEW TOOLS TO SUPPORT
VACCINE ALLOCATIONS IN ORDER
MANAGEMENT FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. IN A SYSTEM FOR THE
PUBLIC TO OBTAIN VACCINE
VERIFICATION. AND FINALLY. WE
ENHANCED THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY. TO MANAGE THE GREATLY
INCREASED DATA VOLUME AND
COMMUNICATE WITH HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS. DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
NUMBER OF DOSES RECORDED HAS
DOUBLED. THE NUMBER OF QUERIES
TO THE SYSTEM FOR VACCINE
RECORDS HAS INCREASED FIVE FOLD.
SO WE HAVE ENHANCED OUR SYSTEMS
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
INCREASED DATA VOLUME. JOHN OVER
TO YOU KNOW THANK YOU JAMES. SO
CHENEY PH HAS LEVERAGE FEDERAL
STATE FUNDING AND BEST EGG HOW
TO INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
DATA SYSTEMS CREATED AND
MODIFIED DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE
ADOPTED OUR CURRENT TECHNOLOGY
TO WORK WITH NEW MODERN
ARCHITECTURES PROVIDING SHE
COMPONENTS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
RESPOND OVER NINETEEN. AND THE
URGENT NEED FOR ENHANCED DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS. ITS
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE ALSO
ESSENTIAL FOR CD PH AND LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO
EFFECTIVELY TRACK GATHER AT
TRACKING GATHER DATA ON CODE
NINETEEN AND OTHER INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. PERFORM CONTACT
TRACING TO MINIMIZE DISEASE
SPREAD. OFFICIALLY ADMINISTER
LIFE SAVING VACCINES RAPIDLY
PERFORM COVER NINETEEN TEST AND
DEPLOY PERSONNEL IN AREAS OF
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
DIVISION AND THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES REQUEST A
HUNDRED THIRTY POSITIONS. FORTY
FOR A FOR I. T. AND SEVENTY FIVE
PER PROGRAM AND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE POINT TWO MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED FORTY POSITIONS AND A
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX POINT ONE
MILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
FORTY POSITIONS AND SIXTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. THESE POSITIONS ARE
FUNDING FOR QUESTIONS ARE NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN AND OPERATE THE
CRITICAL TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURES AND SYSTEMS
SUPPORT. NECESSARY PANDEMIC
SERVICES STATEWIDE. FAIR FOR AND
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES ON A
LARGE SCALE DISASTERS. AND BUILD
CDPH OPERATIONAL AND TECHNOLOGY
RESILIENCY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DOES NOT. HELLO HEY THIS IS
SONYA PADDOCK AGAIN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
AS WE NOTED IN THE PREVIOUS
ISSUE WE DO THINK IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR CD CAGE HAVE AN
OVER ARCHING IT STRATEGY FOR ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS AND C. H.
DID INDICATE TO OUR OFFICE THAT
IT WILL BE DEVELOPING SUCH A
STRATEGY UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE NEW- CHIEF IT STRATEGIST THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO NOTED TO OUR
OFFICE THAT IT'S IN THE PROCESS
OF CONDUCTING A HOLISTIC
ASSESSMENT OF THE DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
ECOSYSTEM SPECIFICALLY. IN THE
MEANTIME WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE PATICULAR SYSTEMS ARE
CRITICAL FOR KOBE NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SURVEILLANCE OVERALL AND
WE THINK IT SEEMS REASONABLE. TO
BRING SOME OF THE MANAGEMENT
OPERATIONS OF THE SYSTEM'S IN
HOUSE SO THAT CDPH HAS GREATER-
VISIBILITY INTO EACH F THE
SYSTEMS AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE.
CHANGES AS NEEDED SO- WE ARE NOT
RAISING ANY PARTICULAR- ISSUES
WITH THIS REQUEST WE RECOGNIZE
IT'S A IT'S A LARGE
DOCUMENTATION FOR MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS OF THESE IT
SYSTEMS BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY PLAY AT A VERY CRITICAL
ROLE AT THE MOMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN SPEAK TO THE LACK
OF THE OVER ARCHING GOAL AND
THEN- HOW HOW THIS FITS IN WITH
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE ABOUT. WORK FORCE
AND BRING IN ALL THESE PEOPLE ON
HOW DOES IT HOW DOES IT FIT INTO
THE OVER ARCHING IT GOAL AND HOW
HOW DO WE INTEGRATE THEIR
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION INTO THIS. COMPONENT
AS WELL. AND I CAN SPEAK TO THE
OVER ARCHING IG GOAL SO- AS YOU
MENTIONED WE ARE DOING A
MULTIPLE ASSESSMENTS RIGHT NOW
OF OUR ECOSYSTEM AND OUR SYSTEMS
TO DETERMINE WHERE WE NEED TO
PLACE EMPHASIS ON THAT OVER
ARCHING STRATEGY IT'S A
FOUNDATIONAL WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE- WE SEE FUTURE STRATEGY
BEING CREATED. YOU KNOW- AS WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU CAN IDENTIFY
WHAT SYSTEMS APPLICATIONS AND
SERVICES NEED TO BE MAINTAINED
CONSOLIDATED OUR OUR RE FACTORS. AND AS WE BRING THOSE THINGS
IN HOUSE DO WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT OR SINCE
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH SUCH A
WORK FORCE ISSUE RIGHT NOW. DOES
IT IT DOES THIS IS THAT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
BRING ALL OF THESE COMPONENTS
TOGETHER. YES SO OUR PLAN IS TO
BRING THEM IN HOUSE AND GAIN THE
SKILLS AND STRATEGIES. OUR
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE AND
CAPABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN AND SUPPORT THEM. WE'RE
GOING TO LEVERAGE OUR
CONTRACTORS. GOING FORWARD. TO
BE ABLE O WORK WITH STATE
STAFF. TO DO THAT KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER- WE C. I. A. A. ROLE ON
STRATEGY OR WORK FORCE- COMING
OVER THE NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
PLUS. TO BE ABLE TO TRY AND
BRING THOSE THINGS IN HOUSE AND
THEN GAIN THAT'S US SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE AND CAPABILITIES TO
MAINTAIN AND SUPPORT THEM. I'M
AS FAMILIAR A FEEL I'M SORRY. GO
AHEAD FINISH COMPLETE I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY IT IT'S GOING TO BE A
LONG TERMSTRATEGY THAT WOULD BE
A ONE TO THREE YEAR STRATEGY TO.
BRING THOSE IN HOUSE OR LOOK AT.
JUST A STAIN ABILITY TO EVEN SEE
IF THEIR BIBLE TO BRING IT OUT.
I MISS FAILURE YOU'RE GONNA BE
YOU'RE GONNA WORK ALL ALL OF
YOUR- YOU WORK FIRST DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGY. INTO THIS COMPONENT AS
WELL. ABSOLUTELY. THIRTY PM.
THANK YOU AND- EVERY TIME WE
TALK ABOUT IT INVOLVES A LOT OF
MONEY SO I DO HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS- AND- SO FIRST OF ALL
JUST TO CLARIFY SO APPRECIATE
YOU SAID YOU CAN BRING THE
THINGS IN HOUSE- WHAT I SEE HERE
IS YOU'RE ASKING FOR ANY OF THE
FUNDING ESSENTIALLY A HUNDRED
FORTY POSITIONS ON ON GOING
BASIS BECAUSE YOUR FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS AND THIRTY FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION AND THEN A HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX IN THE SIXTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION THERE AFTER SO. IS
THE SIXTY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ESSENTIALLY TO PAY FOR
THE HUNDRED FORTY POSITIONS. I'M
SORRY YES I BELIEVE SO. OKAY SO
THE REMAINING OF THE MONEY SO
OBVIOUSLY THE FIRST US OF A TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE POINT TWO SO
THE SO WHAT'S THE REST OF THE
MONEY FOR IS IT. TO SO THAT IS
TO. MAINTAIN THE LICENSING- D.
STRUCTURES THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE APPLICATIONS THAT WE
START UP CURRENTLY. THERE ARE
SOME RESIDUAL COSTS AROUND THOSE
AND ONGOING COSTS THAT WE NEED
TO MAINTAIN. OKAY SO THOSE
LICENSING COSTS WOULD GO AWAY
AFTER THIS THIS FIRST YEAR OURS
IT AT THE COST OF PURCHASING AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
LIKE SO THAT YOU KNOW. THAT THAT
. LET'S PLACES YOU DON'T GO AWAY
SO YEAH I KNOW THIS WOULD GO
AWAY AND I CAN GET YOU MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT- IN MORE
DETAIL IF YOU'D LIKE OKAY FINE
SO IT'S I DO YEAH. I GUESS WHY
WHY UNDERSTANDS HIM WHO'S GOING
FOR TWO AND- TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE AND IT GOES DOWN TO SIXTY
ONE POINT EIGHT. WHAT'S GOING
FOR WHAT SO SOME OF IT'S OUR
POSITIONS SOME OF ITS FOR
WHATEVER AND- WHY IT IS
TEMPORARY VERSES YOU KNOW. THAT
NIGHT I'M GOING SO. THEN I GUESS
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE AND
BEGIN THIS IS. THIS THIS IS MY-
FORTUNATELY- EXPERIENCE WITH IT
PROJECTS IS THAT. SO FOR THESE
SYSTEMS AND I. YOU KNOW I HEAR A
LOT OF THE OLD MAINTENANCE AND
SO FORTH- AND IN FACT- ENFORCE
WE HAVE TOLENTINO THE TECHNOLOGY
FOLKS HERE. BUT R. D. AND I KNOW
WE STILL THESE UP PRETTY QUICKLY
FOR THE FOR THE PANDEMIC. BUT ON
A MORE ON GOING BASIS RD. FOR
EXAMPLE ALREADY BUILT AS A
MODULAR SYSTEM SO IT'S HARDLY
MADE SO IT DECIDE FROM THE
MAINTENANCE PART LIKE KEEP IT
RUNNING. WE ALL KNOW WE NEED TO
KEEP SYSTEMS UPGRADED RIGHT SO
THEY'RE GOING TO INTERFACE WITH
OTHER SYSTEMS. THERE'S OTHER YOU
KNOW WHETHER IN HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM OR OTHER PLACES AND THOSE
SYSTEMS WILL UPGRADE RATE THAT
OPERATING SYSTEMS UPGRADE YET
WINDOWS GET THIS FROM TEN TO
ELEVEN. BACK IOS GOES FROM I
ONLY GO TO HIGH SIERRA TO YOU
KNOW LET THIRD OR WHATEVER YOU
KNOW IF I GOT WRONG. YOU KNOW
THE MAC AT HOME. SO SO WE SO WE
NOT ONLY NEED MAINTENANCE WE
ALSO NEED TO BE SURE THAT WE
DESIGNED THE SYSTEM IN A WAY
THAT. IT'S MODULAR AND CAN
UPGRADE SO THAT WE'RE ALWAYS
WITH DOING MY CALL BIG BANG
RIGHT LANDS WE- REVIVED BIG
SYSTEM WE GET. SOMEONE AND THEN
WE PUT IT THERE AND IT SITS
THERE AND THEN EACH YEAR IT GETS
OLDER AND OLDER OLDER THAN TEN
YEARS LATER WE HAVE A SITUATION.
WHERE OUR SYSTEM IS REALLY OLD
AND IT'S NOT KEEPING UP I MEAN.
YOU KNOW WITH. WITH EDT DMV YOU
KNOW SO. SO I WANT TO BE SURE TO
IT AS WORK. PENDING FUNDING IN.
AND WE'RE ABOUT. WERE NOT JUST
TALKING ME IN A WE'RE TALKING.
ON GOING. UPGRADING BECAUSE IT'S
NOT KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM
CONSTANT IN- A MONITOR. TO IT
SUITS CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THESE ARE NOT JUST. ALONE THEY
HAVE TO INTERFACE THE REST OF
THE WORLD RIGHT SO I HOPE THE-
THE- LIKE THE BROTHERS OF AXING
REGISTRY OR TO NOTIFIER WHATEVER
ELSE RATES OF WHAT USED TO BE ON
TRACK FAX TECHNOLOGY USED TO BE.
A STATE OF THE ART. IT'S NOT
ANYMORE RIGHT SO YOU DON'T BE
STUCK WITH A SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T. INVOLVE WITH THE THINGS
AROUND IT EVEN IF IT WORKS
REALLY WELL. IT'S NOT GONNA WORK
WELL BECAUSE YOU CAN'T INTERACT
WITH OTHER SYSTEMS AROUND
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T THAT KIND.
COULD HAVE NVOLVED. IN THEIR
OWN WAY SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT. EAH I KNOW AND I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU SO UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAD TO STAND THESE THINGS UP
VERY QUICKLY AND RAPIDLY SO WE
DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO THE
STRATEGY ARCHITECTURE AROUND
THOSE. TO BUILD THEM THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND MODULAR WAY- THAT
IS- THE FUTURE STRATEGIES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT SO WE'RE GOING
TO. WE'RE DOING ASSESSMENTS
RIGHT NOW ON THE APP FOR
SUSTAINABILITY. LOOKING AT HOW
WHAT SYSTEMS CAN BE RATIONALIZED
COMBINED. WITH SYSTEMS NEED
BETTER ARCHITECTURE TO BE MORE
MODULAR. AND HOW WE TRANSITION
OR TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE CLOUD.
AND ALL THE FEATURES OF THAT
GOING FORWARD BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND THAT'S- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MAIN. PRIORITIES
AS WE SEEK A PHOTO SO WHAT'S THE
TIME SO AND I UNDERSTAND THE
PREVIOUS YOUR PREVIOUS ANSWER
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE YOU
KNOW THERE IS THIS THAT WE CAN
GET THAT CHIEF IT OFFICER. GOING
TO DO THIS THING WHAT'S THE
TIMELINE FOR THAT. SO YOU KNOW.
WE WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING IS
ASSESSED. TO UNDER. THE AND OF
F. AND WHAT WE- HAVE- BEFORE
WHICH DETERMINE THE- STRATEGY.
HOW LONG IS. IT TAKE IT JUST
DEPENDS ON HOW BIG. YOU KNOW I
GOTTA GET A SEQUENCE OF EVENTS
HAVE TO HAPPEN BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A TIME LINE FOR THE
SEQUENCE OF EVENTS SO HOW LONG
DID IT TAKE TO DO THAT FIRST
PART AND THEN YOU CAN BRING AN
I. T. PERSON AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO SO. I MEAN WE TALKING
IN. FULL WELL WE HAVE AN IT
STRATEGY IN TWO YEARS THREE
YEARS. WHAT'S THAT THAT WHAT
WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT- WE
SHOULD HAVE- THAT TV TO BE READY
TO PRESENT. ITS STRATEGY TO US
AND FRANKLY THE REST OF THE
WORLD. IS TOO OKAY- THIS IS THIS
IS THIS IS THE PATH THIS IS THE
PATH THAT WE'VE GOING THROUGH
EXTENDED SUCCESS MENTOR CENTER-
SO WHAT WHAT IS THAT TIME LINE.
I WILL ANTICIPATE IT WOULD TAKE
THREE YEARS WE WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE MORE AND ADD JOBS. ALREADY
JEWS OR STRATEGY UNDERSTAND OUR
ECOSYSTEMS AND THEN DEVELOPED-
THAT STRATEGY AND THEN IMPLEMENT
GOING FORWARD AND THEN JUST TO
GET HER DEATH. SO IT'S NOT A ONE
TIME STRATEGY. CAN IMPLEMENT IT
AND THIS STOP LIKE YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THAT LEADS TO BIG BANG AT
LEAST R. K. SYSTEMS AND OUTDATED
SYSTEMS. WE WANT TO CONTINUALLY
DO STRATEGY AND CONTINUE
REFRESHER SYSTEMS GOING FORWARD.
YOU NEED GIVE ME A TIMELINE FOR
ITS STRATEGY FOR AT LEAST
INITIALLY DOING STRATEGY SO IT.
I WOULD I WOULD SAY AT LEAST ONE
TO TWO YEARS BEFORE I CAN DO
THAT DEPENDING YOU KNOW AND-
DON'T QUOTE ME ON IT BUT THAT.
THAT'S NORMALLY ABOUT GENERALLY
WHAT WE'RE THINKING AND AS TIME.
SO IT'S ONLY JUST BECAUSE THIS
AND MENTALLY I WON'T BE HERE
NEXT YEAR- SO I'M GONNA LOOK AT.
CENTER ADMIN AND SOMEONE ELSE
WILL PERHAPS HERE TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND SO FORTH AND ALSO
TO LOOK AT ELIAHU IT'S NOT ON
THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW. AND SO I
THINK. ANYTIME WE DO A LARGE IT
STRATEGY. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. WITH AN UPDATE. THAT
HAS OF COURSE THE AGENCY THAT'S
DOING IT AND THE PART OF
TECHNOLOGY AND TALK ABOUT WHERE. YOU KNOW HOW THAT'S COMING
TOGETHER. AS AFTER ALL YOU KNOW
WE- THAT THE THINGS ARE EX.
STATE AND SO FORTH AND- WHAT I
PREFERRED TO THAT THAN THE
HEARING THAT HAVE TO HAPPEN WHEN
WE USED TO GO INTO AGENCY HAS TO
COME UP AND TELL US HOW. HOW TO
DETER SYSTEM IS AND WHY THERE'S
A FAILURE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
DON'T THEY CAN'T MAKE IT HAPPEN.
AND THAT THAT UNLIMITED DATA
DATA SYSTEMS. SO SO I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW UP- MAYBE
ELLIE- CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT
KIND OF MONITORING YOU'LL BE
DOING OF THESE I THIS I. T.
EFFORT- TO BE SURE THAT- WE ARE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURES WILL
INFORM TO I MEAN I GET. NOW AND
I APPRECIATE NOW THE AGILE AND
ALL THIS OTHER STUFF. BUT I.
THINK IT'S AGAIN IMPORTANT WE
MONITOR THIS. SO THAT SAYS THANK
YOU FOR ASKING DR PAN- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THIS AND WE ALSO HAVE. ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND IS.
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY LOOKS AT IT
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND MONITORS ALL OF
THE- VARIOUS PROJECTS GOING
THROUGH THE- DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND THE- PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE. PROCESS- BUT
YEAH YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE TO
GIVE THAT SOME SPECIFIC THOUGHT
AS TO JUST SORT OF HOW WE
INTERACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
MONITOR THIS GOING FORWARD BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THAT'S
ON OUR RADAR THAT WILL BE
CONTINUING TO ASK ABOUT OKAY SO
THE OTHER THING I WOULD JUST
MAKE NOTES HAND AGAIN WOULD
DEPRECIATE YOUR YOUR INSIGHTS
FROM THE LA- IS THAT SO THE
REASON I STARTED OFF POINTING
OUT THAT WE'RE GOING FOR TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
ESSENTIALLY DOWN TO SIXTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IS THAT.
THAT'S A BUDGET TO MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT SYSTEMS THAT'S NOT A
BUDGET TO SAY WE'RE UPGRADING
THE SYSTEMS THAT'S NOT INVITED
SAYING HOW WE'RE CONSOLIDATING
IT CETERA SO IN OTHER WORDS I'M
GONNA SAY THAT THERE IS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THAT WORD THEY WERE GONNA
DO A MULTIPLE YEAR OUT YOU KNOW
THAT OUT YEARS WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING THAT ON THE I. T.
SIDE FOR CD PH THERE'S GOING TO
BE AN ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURE FOR
NEW SYSTEMS AFTER A
CONSOLIDATION SO FAR THIS IS THE
MINIMUM THIS IS THAT MAINTENANCE
NOW GET THE CURRENT LICENSES
WIND THAT DOWN WE'LL BRING IT IN
HOUSE THIS IS THE FIFTH WE NEED
TO RUN IT TO KEEP IT GOING. SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT A PIN ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT DAN IS WE'RE LOOKING AT
BUDGETS FOR C. PH IN THE OUT
YEARS THAT'S ONE OF THE COME
BACK THEY WILL ACTUALLY TOLD YOU
NOW YOU DON'T WE ONLY NEED A
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX POINT ONE
MILLION YES YOU NEED A HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX POINT ONE MILLION TO
MAINTAIN YOUR CURRENT SYSTEM BUT
WHAT IS THE BUDGET ASK FOR THE
NEW SYSTEMS THE UPGRADE THAT
CETERA THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING SO THAT THE SYSTEM STAY UP
TO DATE. AND SO I DO WANNA BE
SURE WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THAT
AND REMEMBERING THAT SO EVEN
THOUGH IT MAY NOT BE PART OF
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET REQUEST THE
TRUE IT BUDGET FOR C. C. PH IS
NOT WHAT'S BEING BEFORE US IT'S
LARGER THAN. THIS IS AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT. YEAH I CAN CAN
RESPOND THAT YEAH THIS IS TRUE
JUST. TWO MINUTES OPERATE. AND
SO. SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE STOOD UP DURING
THE CALL THE CRISIS OKAY. SO IT
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SAY SEE
THOUGH IS IN ADDITION TO THIS.
ALL RIGHT. AT LEAST YOU RE TOLD
ME. THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
AND WE ONLY HAVE THAT AND THEN
WE HAVE THAT. TINY LITTLE PIECE
IN THE LAST ITEM WHICH IS ONLY
ABOUT THE BIRTH DEFECT DATABASE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A BUDGET
ALLOCATION. FOR WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO THAT I. T. PLANNING- RATE-
AND I DON'T KNOW YOUR CHIEF DATA
OFFICERS ARRAYED BUILT INTO THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION OR NOT BUT
I. MEAN WHAT YOU NEED IN ORDER
TO DO THE RIGHT IT PATH SO GREAT
YOU GAVE US A BUDGET FOR
MAINTAINING THE EXISTING SYSTEM
YET THE STAND UP DURING THE
PANDEMIC WILL STILL NEED A PIECE
OF ENDEMIC STILL WITH US. IT'S
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY- HOPEFULLY
WE CAN WIND IT THE OTHER GLIDE
PATH THAT THE GOVERNOR TALKED
ABOUT BUT- ALSO THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE A SOME PLANNING FUND SO
THAT. AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
COME BACK AND TELL US OKAY NOW
THAT WE PLANNED FOR I. T. THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED IN
ORDER TO. MOVE FORWARD AND BE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUALLY HAVE
UPDATE SYSTEMS. THAT MAKE SENSE
. YES VERY MUCH SO AND IN JUST
SUCH YOU KNOW WE- WILL
DEFINITELY WORK WITH OUR
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES. IN CONTROL
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW.
GIVE THEM REGULAR UPDATES ON
THIS AND FOLLOW THE- PROJECT
LIFECYCLE FOR CALIFORNIA. OKAY
BUT I I'D LIKE TO SEE A PROPOSAL
FOR D. V. I. MAINTENANCE. FOR
YOUR PLAN OKAY. WE NEED YOUR
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS FOR THAT
FINANCE IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
IN LINE WITH WHAT. I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS. BUT IS
THAT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT-
THAT- I MEAN WHAT WE HEARD FROM
C. T. H. IS THAT THEY ALSO NEED
TO. KNOW SO WE NEED TO GET THE
SUN RIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
PANTS AND ALL THE TALK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN TAKE BACK
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO BETTER EVALUATE.
TO YOUR POINT COSTS FOR UPGRADES
AND OR NEW SYSTEMS- WE WOULD
JUST REITERATE THAT THE EXISTING
BUDGET REQUEST IS TO MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE THE SYSTEMS THAT
WERE SET UP DURING KOBE TO- SO
THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT. THE BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE DEPARTMENT'S IT
COSTS OKAY THANK YOU SO I THINK
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND JUST
MAINTAIN EXISTING SYSTEMS MAR
TWENTY. TWENTY FOUR OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I WOULD SAY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
WELL AS TO THE LA- IT AS WE'VE
SEEN TO THE PANDEMIC IT'S NOT
WAS NOT JUST THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM THAT WE
STRUGGLED WITH ALL OF OUR STAFF
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH EDT- DMV
AND ANYBODY ELSE WHO HAS AN
INITIAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO OPERATE AS SOME
KIND OF I. T. DEVICE. THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH ON THE
BACK END. SO BOTH FOR THE LA-
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOR THE LA- I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S- TWO METRICS YOU CAN YOU
CAN WORK ON TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
THESE THESE. PROJECTS ASTHEY'RE
GOING FORWARD AND MAKING SURE
THAT UPDATES AND OR-
IMPROVEMENTS ARE BEING MADE TO
BE ABLE TO. TO RESPOND TO GOING
FORWARD AND NOT JUST LOOKING
BACK- OKAY WITH THAT LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. VIRGIN
SHE RESPONSE AND BORDER RESPONSE
OPERATIONS. THIRTY DR- YES I
THINK- I'M IS THIS OKAY BRANDON
IS THIS ONE ON THE ON THE ON THE
CUT CUT CUT YEAH COMPANY MERCY
RESPONSE SORRY OKAY- YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M GONNA MAKE
SOME OVERLAP I'M GONNA MAKE SOME
. HELLO COMMENTS HANDED TO
BRANDON. SO FOR THE COMMON
RESPONSE. YOU KNOW I'VE ALREADY
COVERED A LOT IN TERMS OF IMPACT
OF COVERT RESPONSE IN A WORD NOW
APPROACHING OVER EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND DEATHS THAT WE'VE HAD
ATTRIBUTED TO COME OVER AND WE
KNOW THE FACT THAT THE COMPANY
HAS A MUCH BIGGER RESPONSE
BEYOND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THAT HAVE DIED I HE
MENTIONED ALSO THAT EARLIER
ACCESS TO ASK. I DON'T THINK I
WANT TO MENTION IS THAT. WITH
CULTIVATED THERE REALLY HAS
THERE REALLY HAS BEEN A- SHIFT.
IN OUR MINDSET OF UNDERSTANDING
HOW THIS PANDEMIC IS PLAYING
OUT. I THINK WE'VE LEARNED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS AND ALL OF US CAN GO
BACK AND THINK ABOUT EVEN IN
JUNE FIFTEENTH. YOU KNOW WHEN WE
LIFTED. THE RESTRICTIONS- AND
THE BLUEPRINTS TO BLUEPRINT FOR
A BETTER ECONOMY WENT AWAY. YOU
KNOW THERE WERE SOME OPTIMISM
THAT YOU NEVER HEARD OF MUTINY
WAS GOING TO TAKE PLACE WE HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE VACCINATED. AND
THEN OF COURSE- THINGS CHANGE
WITH WITH DELTA. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
WITH DELTA THIS WAS TRUE ALSO
FOR THE ALPHA VARIANT. IS THAT.
THERE ARE NOT ONLY MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE BUT THEY. WERE
ALSO MORE VIRULENT. AND- ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH THIS
VIRUS MOVING FORWARD IS THAT
BECAUSE MOST TRANSMISSION
HAPPENS BEFORE PEOPLE DEVELOP
SYMPTOMS. EITHER THEY'RE A
SYMPTOMATIC DON'T DEVELOP ANY
SYMPTOMS THAT TRANSMIT. OR THEIR
PRE SYMPTOMATIC AND CAN TRANSMIT
BEFORE THEY DEVELOP SYMPTOMS. IT
TURNS OUT FROM AN EVOLUTIONARY.
BIOLOGY PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
COULD HAVE A BEARING ON THE
FUTURE LIKE WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
THAT ARE MORE VIRULENT IN OTHER
WORDS THE COST BECAUSE MORE
DISEASE. AND. AND CAN BE MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE. THERE IS A
NATIONAL THINKING THAT DELTA WE
WOULD NOT SEE IF WE WOULD NOT
SEE THINGS MORE TRANSMISSIBLE
THAN DELTA AND THEN OVER
THANKSGIVING WE LEARNED ABOUT A
LOW CRIME. SO OVERCROWDED REALLY
MADE US HAVE A REALLY BIG SHOULD
SHIFT IN OUR IN OUR IN OUR IN
OUR THINKING IS THAT BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE TRANSMISSION
HAPPENING GLOBALLY WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE NEW VARIANTS. WE CANNOT
PREDICT WITH CERTAINTY WHERE
WHETHER THAT BUT COMBINATION
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE IN TERMS OF
TRANSFER DEFINITELY PROBABLY
MORE TRANSMISSIBLE AND MAYBE
EVEN MORE VIRULENT. AND SO WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
READING US SO THAT WE CAN ADAPT
TO RESPOND TO WHATEVER WHATEVER
COMES AND YOU KNOW THIS IDEA OF
US LEARNING AND LEARNING TO LIVE
WITH THE VIRUS AND YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR. THE GOVERNOR COVERED
THE CORE COMPONENTS- EAT
YESTERDAY WHEN THEY CALLED
CALIFORNIA SMARTER EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. A PLAN
FOR THE NEXT PHASE OF
CALIFORNIA'S COVERT RESPONSE
HAVE A COVERS THE CORE AREAS
THAT ARE IN IN THE IN THE BUDGET
THAT- THE BRAIN IS GONNA IS
GONNA SUMMARIZE IN TERMS OF
VACCINATIONS. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT ESPECIALLY
GALE ABILITY OF. MASKING MAKING
SURE THAT. GOOD MASTER OF TO
HAVE A CALL. YOUR IDEA OF SIR.
IMPROVING OUR OUR OUR- WAYS
WATER SURVEIL. IMPROVING US.
SYSTEMS HO GENOME SEQUENCING OUR
READINESS OR ABILITY TO RESPOND
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS. BY TESTING SCHOOLS AND
THEN WHAT WE CALL THAT TESTING
TO TREATMENT VALUE STREAM.
MAKING SURE THAT AS- AS A
TREATMENTS BECOME MORE AVAILABLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WERE ABLE TO
GET IT TO EVERYBODY THAT THAT
THAT NEEDS IT AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE SO THEY COULD THEY
COULD HAVE. A CLINICAL BENEFIT
AND WE ALREADY KNOW FROM. WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN WITH COME
WITH THAT THE STRUCTURAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES MAKES THAT A
CHALLENGE SO ALL THE ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT AREAS
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE. TO BE
READY WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
VACCINATE FOLKS. AND WE HAVE TO
BE PREPARED FOR ANY NEW VARIANTS
AND STRENGTH IN. THAT WITH THE
ADVANCES WE'VE MADE BUT ALSO GET
BETTER AT THEM. I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TURN IT OVER TO BRAND
HE'S GONNA HE'S GONNA COVER THE
SPECIFICS AND THEN WE CAN ANSWER. QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AGAIN BRANDON YOUR
WITH THE- SO AS YOU'RE AWARE
LAST WEEK THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE WAS PASSED. THAT
INCLUDED ONE POINT SIX BILLION
FOR KOBE RELATED RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES- THE ASSUMPTIONS
ORIGINALLY IN THE TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT-
ASSUME RESPONSE COSTS THROUGH
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND SO GIVEN THE STATE STILL IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS RESPONSE
ECHOED IT PARTICULARLY AS-
DOCTOR GONE MENTIONED THE-
PURCHASE OF VARIANTS
PARTICULARLY ON THE CRIME- THE
EARLY ACTION WAS MEANT TO
SUPPORT THOSE WERE. OUR RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES THROUGH JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO THIS ISSUE
THAT'S NOW BEFORE YOU CONTINUES
THE SUPPORT FOR THE SAME COVERED
RESPONSE NOW THROUGH THE- THE
MIDDLE OF THE COMING BUDGET YEAR
SO IT SENDS IT TO DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- SO THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE MILLION
THAT'S INCLUDED IN THIS ITEM IS
FOR US TO FURTHER DOSE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. AND JUST TO KIND OF
PROVIDE YOU KIND OF A BY THE
NUMBERS FOR SOME OF THE BUCKETS-
FOUR IN THE AREA VACCINATIONS AS
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO POINT
THREE MILLION THERE. THAT'S
GOING TO SUPPORT OUR VACCINE AND
BOOSTER OUTREACH EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE CAMPAIGNS.
PROVIDES GONNA END AND
MINISTRATION MANAGEMENT SERVICES
FOR VACCINE SITES AND STRIKE
TEAMS AND THEN SUPPORTS A NUMBER
OF OUR MOBILE UNITS THAT GO
ACROSS THE COUNTIES AND LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO PROVIDE
POP UP CLINICS. THERE'S A BIT
ORIGINAL OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE THERE'S THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO MILLION THAT'S
INCLUDED FOR TESTING. THAT'S
GOING TO GO TO PROVIDE SPECIMEN
COLLECTION SERVICES THROUGH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT MODALITIES
INCLUDING DRIVE THRU SITES
MOBILE- AND SOME OF THOSE
TRAVELING TEAMS I MENTIONED AND
THEN SITE EXPANSION TO INCREASE-
FOR EXISTING SIZE SIX- EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF LANES. HOURS AND
DAYS OF OPERATIONS AT CETERA-
AND THEN OF COURSE IT ALSO GOES
TO SUPPORT- DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
OUT OF THE LAND SEA LAB BRANCH-
IN THE AREA OF CONTACT. TRACING
IS ROUGHLY EIGHTEEN MILLION
THAT'S IN COLLUDED THERE MUCH OF
WHICH IS TO- WE'RE START TO IN
THE CURRY YEAR WITH. A ACTION
THAT WAS TAKEN BY. IT'S TO
ESTABLISH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESERVE CORPS AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESERVE COURSE GOING TO
ASSIST US WITH RESPONSE TO A
NUMBER OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
EMERGENCIES CONTACT TRACING CASE
INVESTIGATION EFFORTS RELATED TO
COVE IT OF COURSE AS WELL- AND
THE RESERVE COURSE GOING TO
CONSIST OF STATE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE GOING TO VOLUNTEER FOR THE
PROGRAM- OF COURSE WITH THEIR
AGENCY'S APPROVAL TO. TO DO SO
AND TO PARTICIPATE- IN THE AREA
OF MEDICAL SURGE STABBING
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR MILLION THAT'S BEING
INCLUDED TO- AGAIN THROUGH
DECEMBER DEPLOYED REGISTERED
NURSES NURSE ASSISTANTS CLINICAL
TAX- AND OTHER KIND OF HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS TO BOTH
RESPOND TO ANY MEDICAL SURGEON
NEEDS. AS WELL IN HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AS WELL AS TO HELP ON
THE VACCINE ADMINISTRATION SIDE
. AND THEN FINALLY TO ROUND OUT
THIS REQUEST THEIR SEVENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S INCLUDED
FOR- OUR BORDER ACTIVITIES- WORK
CURRENTLY WORKING THIS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH FEDERAL LOCAL
AND NONPROFIT PARTNERS- WE'RE
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND SERVICES
TO NEW ARRIVING MIGRANTS AT THE
BORDER AND IMPERIAL SAN DIEGO
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES IN THIS
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE TESTING AND
TEMPORARY SHELTER AND VACCINES-
SO THAT'S KIND OF A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW AND THEN OF COURSE
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS
OF OUR VRIOUS- TASK FORCE HERE
AS WELL TO BE ABLE TO- TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANKS
THANK YOU RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I'LL
TAKE THAT AS A NO LMAO. NOTHING
IN THIS WITH A DIFFERENT. JUST
TO CLARIFY BECAUSE WE DETECTED
EARLY ACTIONS- SUBSAMPLE THE
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION FOR
CONTACT TRACING HIS THAT
ACTUALLY THROUGH THE END OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THE EARLY ACTION WAS FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SO. JUST WANNA
CLARIFY. THAT IS SO IS THAT
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO JUST FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO YEARS BECAUSE WE
PASSED AS PART OF THE ACTION AND
THEN IT STOPS OR IS THAT. BAND
NOW AUTHORIZED ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE END OF THE TWENTY. I
GUESS JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO
THIS AFFECTS THE SCHOOL YEAR.
YEAH DEPUTIES FOR THIS ACTION IN
TOTAL INCLUDING THE CONTACT
TRACING. BASICALLY TAKES THE
EARLY ACTION THAT BASICALLY GAVE
US FUNDING TO JAN AND NOW THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION. WILL TAKE US THROUGH
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
OKAY SO HOLD ON I JUST I CLARIFY
SO. JUNE OF WHICH YEAR. SO THE
TALKING WITH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO THE EARLY ACTION GOES TILL
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO OR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO OKAY
SO THAT'S COMING UP IN JUNE.
OKAY AND THEN YOU SAID THE SEVEN
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY POINT EIGHT
ACTUALLY ONLY TAKES US UP TO
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE ESTIMATES RIGHT NOW TAKE US
THROUGH DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THAT'S WHAT THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE OKAY SO
IT'S NOT REALLY TO TWENTY TWENTY
SO IT'S- BASICALLY MID FISCAL
YEAR THAT STOPS. OUT FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR CORRECT PRICES ONLY
FOR HALF THE BUDGET YEAR AND SO
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE WILL
HAPPEN IS. AFTER DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTH AND JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WE SAW THE HALF OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR LEFT TO GO.
RIGHT AND WE WOULD YOU KNOW KIND
OF BE ASSESSING WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE RESPONSE AT THAT TIME
YOU'D BE ABLE TO UPDATE THESE
ESTIMATES IT MAY REVISIONS IF
THERE WAS A NEED BEYOND DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I THINK WE
LOOK TO DO UPDATES AND-
REVISIONS. OKAY SO BASICALLY MAY
REVISION MAY SEE SOME CHANGES
BUT THAT THAT WOULD INCLUDE.
THEN THE REMAINDER OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. YES NETWORK WOULD. AT THAT
THE S. PROCESS. THERE RIGHT YES
YEAH I NEEDED IT COULD BE THAT
SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR TO SEE
THE LOWER ARE KNOWN TO MAN BUT I
JUST WANT OKAY. SO I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THOUGH IS THERE'S NO AT
LEAST I DON'T SEE ANY MONEY FOR
CONTACT TRACING PAST. JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IS THAT IS THAT. IS THAT THE
INTENTION OR ARE YOU JUST SAYING
HE AND MAY YIELD GIVE US AN
UPDATE AND MAYBE INCLUDE. MONEY
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. I THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME
I'LL I'LL PASS IT OFF TO SOME OF
THE I THINK WE HAVE SOME OF OUR
FOLKS FROM THE CONTACT TRACING
TEAM. HERE OUR **** AND THEY GOT
A RESPONSE FAR AS HOW THE- BEST
PHASING OUT OF CONTACT TRACING
IS GOING AND THEN MOVING. INTO
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING PUBLIC HEALTH RESERVE
CORPS BUT I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WOULD BE SOONER IF. THERE'S
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CONTACT
TRACING TEAM THAT COULD HELP. I
THINK WE WOULD RE EVALUATE IT
MAY REVISE BUT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S CONTINUING MONEY FOR
CONTACT TRACING. THE CAST. THOSE
ARE BASICALLY CONTACT TRACING
WILL THEN BE AND IF YOU LIMIT
THE STATE FUNDING FOR CONTACT
TRACING THE AND- WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE CONTACT TRACING
THEN. IS IT THAT WE JUST DUMP IT
ON TO THE LOCALS THEN AND SAYING
WE'RE NOT FUNDING ANYMORE I
MEAN. ARE WE SAYING AND AS- SOON
TO GEICO STOPPED ALL TWENTY FOUR
OF. YOU WAITING WHAT WE WILL
NEED AS WERE CHANGING SHIFTING
POLICIES AROUND CONTACT RACING
SO WHAT I WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
SOMETHING IN MAY REVISE. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- OKAY. AND THEN- THE
OTHER ISSUE I GUESS. YEAH WE
HAVE HERE A HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION FOR SCHOOL
TESTING ACTIVITIES ETCETERA. IS
THERE SOME IT'S I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SOME FEDERAL MONEY THAT
ENDS AT JUNE THIRTIETH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THAT. THAT I
KNOW WHEN THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE I DID ASK BUT I DON'T
THINK I'VE GOTTEN BACK LIKE. HOW
HOW MUCH OF THAT MONEY HAVE WE
ACTUALLY SPENT. AND SO I WON'T
BE SURE THAT WE'RE BUDGETING FOR
WHAT PEOPLE NEED. SO THIS IS-
BUT I WASN'T THAT. NO ONE IS
ABLE TO TELL ME WAS THAT FUND
OVER SUBSCRIBED UNDER
SUBSCRIBED. SO IT IN ORDER TO
INFORM WHAT WE GONNA BUDGET
MOVING FORWARD IF YOU GET TO
KNOW WHAT WE SPENT. IN THE PAST.
TO KNOW WHETHER THAT'S IN LINE
SO- IS THERE A MORE INFORMATION
ON- WHAT SCHOOLS NEED FOR THEIR
TETING AND ACTIVITIES AND SO
FORTH OR MAYBE IT'S NOT THIS
ISN'T. A PART OF THE BUDGET I
MEAN YOU'RE THIS IS A C. PH
BUDGETS- MAYBE. ANOTHER PART BUT
I JUST WANNA CLARIFY. THAT WERE
ARE WE PROVIDING SUFFICIENT
SUPPORT. AND FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS. THIRD CONTINUE THEIR
TEST THAT. THERE ACTIVITIES TO.
MASS AT OUR SO I GUESS THIS IS
MY SPECIFIC AROUND TESTING
SPECIMENS. TO CATS UPSET ON
CHRISTMAS OF THE MONEY YOU SAY
FOR SCHOOL IS OUR TEST. RIGHT
CORRECT AND- AND I UNDERSTAND IS
CURRENTLY FEDERAL FUNDING BUT IT
ENDS IN JUNE THIRTIETH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HI KATHY
JACOBSEN- GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
CAMP. YEAH WE'VE ENCUMBERED
ALMOST ALL OF THE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDS. THAT WORK. OFFERED
THROUGH YOU'LL SEE HER SCHOOL'S
TESTING. AS WELL AS- IN ADDITION
TO THAT. BOB PURCHASING. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN OVER THE
COUNTER CHANNELS. THAT WE
PURCHASED OVER THE LAST. FIVE OR
SIX WEEKS. RIGHT WHICH WILL
PREDOMINANTLY BE USED TO
SUPPORT. SCHOOLS. AND TEACHERS
FOR TESTING. OKAY I'LL ALL RIGHT
EXACTLY I ASKED HIM BECAUSE THIS
AGAIN BUT YOU CAN ON ASK ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY IS IN SPENT THE
AND NOW USING THAT INFORMATION
TO ESTIMATE WHAT OUR NEEDS WILL
BE IN THE FUTURE. AND IT AND SO
THAT SO THAT WAS REALLY THE
THRUST MY QUESTION IS SO HOW
MUCH ARE WE SPENT. IN THE PAST.
AFTER YEARS OF LOSSES THAT IS
THAT THE UNDER FIFTY EIGHT POINT
SIX MILLION REFLECTIVE OF THE
RATE AT WHICH WE SPENT WE'VE HAD
TO SPEND MONEY. TO DATE FOR
TESTING FOR SCHOOLS IS INOTES IS
IT SUFFICIENT- AND I MEAN I'M
GUESSING THAT YOU PROPOSED IT.
IN SOME FORM OF SUFFICIENCY IT
IS BUT HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THAT NUMBER. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
I CAN SPEAK SPECIFIC TO THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
BUT I CAN TELL YOU WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF. ESTIMATING WHAT OUR
FORESEE THEM BEING MOVING
FORWARD. BUT SPECIFICALLY TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED OR FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION I DON'T KNOW BRANDON IF
YOU WANNA. SPEAKER THAT'S. YEAH
THIS IS BRENDA SIGMUND APARTMENT
AND TO YOUR POINT WE DID TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THINGS LIKE THE
FEDERAL GRANT RESOURCES THAT
LIKE YOU SAID EXPIRED KIND OF AT
THE END OF JUNE OR COMING TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF JUNE AND
HOW WE'RE USING THOSE TO SUPPORT
SCHOOLS AND THEN LOOK TO THE
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT ANYTHING
THAT WASN'T YOU IT WASN'T GONNA
BE AVAILABLE THROUGH THAT
PARTICULAR BRANCH AS WELL SO DID
THE GENERAL FUND IS MEANT TO
KIND OF. CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR
THINGS THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
BRAIN OKAY BUT WE DID GET CLOSE
OKAY WELL I JUST WANNA BE SURE
OUR SCHOOLS DON'T HIT A CLIFF AT
THE JUNE WHEN THE GEAR UP AGAIN
FOR THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR AND
FIND THEMSELVES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
SUPPORT FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
PROTECT STUDENTS AT SCHOOL.
EARLY- DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT
ON THAT. NOT AT THIS TIME DOCTOR
AGAIN OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO I JUST
I DO I'M SURE YOU KNOW WE WILL-
BUT SO I'M SURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR SCHOOLS IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR SCHOOLS
OPENED SO I WILL BE SURE THE
SCHOOLS HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO
KEEP THEMSELVES OPEN AND- HE'LL
CERTAINLY THEY GET FUNDING FROM
THE STATE FOR EDUCATION. THIS IS
PUBLIC HEALTH STUFF SO- TO
CERTAIN DEGREE I THINK THAT NOT
ALL IT SHOULD BE COMING OUT OF
THEIR EDUCATION FUNDS WHO SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH SUPPORT AND- BE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SUPPORT NECESSARY FOR THE
SCHOOLS STAY OPEN. SO SO ALL
RIGHT WELL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WHEN IT COMES IN A REVISED BUT
ALSO I'M HOPING BECAUSE I KNOW
MAY REVISE AND WE KNOW WE DO
THIS EVERY YEAR SO I KNOW WHAT
THE DANCES THERE'S A LOT OF
STUFF COMING AT US SO- PLEASE
TRY NOT TO WAIT TO THE LAST
MINUTE. AND THEN- WONDER WHY WE
ASK QUESTIONS AND SLOW THINGS
DOWN OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- LET'S JUST SO SHOULD
WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO THE- THE
MORE STANDARD. BUDGET CHANGE
ISSUES- MOST A LOT OF THEM-
RESPONDING TO THE MEMBER'S BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED SO WE HAVE
THIRTY ITEMS LEFT- I'M GONNA I'M
GONNA SEE IF THE DEPARTMENT
WANTS TO PRESENT AND THEN SEE IF
THE LA- FEELS OKAY ABOUT WAITING
TILL THE END OR IF THERE'S- A
HALFWAY SPOT DO YOU THINK WOULD
LIKE TO STOP FOR SOME. INPUT OR
MAYBE WE'LL JUST GROUP FOR A
WHILE. AND T. O. GROSS- WE ARE
WE'RE GOING TO LA OR DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING THAT- LIKE A MADAM
CHAIR YOU ASKING FOR OUR INPUT
ON THAT YEAH YOUR INPUT ON WHAT
YOU WANT TO RUN THROUGH
EVERYTHING OR IS THERE A NATURAL
STOPPING POINT YOU SEE FOR YOUR
ANALYSIS OF MEDICARE IF YOU
DON'T MIND ME ASKING DO YOU WANT
JUST LIT UP WHICH ITEMS YOU PLAN
TO COMMENT ON THAT. HOW'S THAT.
YEAH HAVE SOME COMMON WHEN WE
GET INTO THE CLIMATE CHANGE
RELATED ITEMS WHICH ARE ISSUES
NINE AND TEN- AND- SO WHEN WE
WHEN WE TAKE FIVE TO TEN AND
THEN WE'LL STOP AND THEN WITH
THEM WILL MAKE A NEW PLAN HAS
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU FOR ASKING
YEAH YES SAID THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAIN FEAR HERE THAT HISTORIC
PERSPECTIVE. OKAY DEPARTMENT
LET'S START THEN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S GOING TO BE A ROBERT
THOMAS THOMAS. HELLO I'M ROBERT
THOMAS ON THE BRANCH CHIEF OF
LAB FIELD SERVICES KNOWN WIDELY
AS A LOT FAST. HELLO FAST WITHIN
CDPH OVERSEAS CLINICAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS AND PERSONNEL
ISSUE BANKS IN BIOLOGICS
PRODUCTION THROUGH FREE
SUPPORTED PROGRAMS. CALABASAS IS
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED ONLINE
ELECTRONIC LICENSING FOR
LABORATORY PERSONNEL AND
CLINICAL PUBLIC HEALTH LABS
HOWEVER IT HAS NOT DONE SO
PARTITION BANK IN BIOLOGICS
PROGRAM. SO WHAT IS BEING
REQUESTED IN THIS VCP IS
INCREASED SPENDING AUTHORITY TO
COMPLETE THE THIRD AND FINAL
PHASE OF A LARGER PROJECT. TO
TRANSITION ELLEVEST FROM A PAPER
BASED LICENSE APPLICATION
PROCESS TO AN ONLINE SYSTEM FOR
TISSUE BANK AND BIOLOGICS
PRODUCTION UNIT. WHICH OVERSEES
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS-
PERSONALITIES. THE COMPLETION OF
THIS PROJECT WILL CLEAR UP
FINDINGS RECOMMENDING THAT
TALLAHASSEE ENHANCE ITS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY DATA.
SYSTEMS THANK. THE RESULT WILL
BE THAT ENHANCE OF OUR ELECTRON
SYSTEM WILL AND THE FISH FOR APP
. AND ELLEVEST IN PROCESSING
APPLICATIONS FREEING PROGRAM
STAFF TO INCREASE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
ESPECIALLY INSPECTION AND
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE CONDITIONS OF
PERSONALITIES. AT THESE
FACILITIES COLLECT PROCESS STORE
AND DISTRIBUTE DISTRIBUTE
KITCHEN BLOOD BANK PRODUCTS FROM
LIVING AND DECEASED DONORS FOR
HUMAN TRANSPLANTATION AND
IMPLANTATION. STEM CELLS WOULD
BE AN EXAMPLE OF SUCH. IMPROVED
DATA COLLECTION WILL SUPPORT
PROGRAM PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT%
AS WELL AS COLLABORATION WITH
OTHER PROGRAMS ON ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES SO ONE IN CONCLUSION
HOW WILL THE SPENDING AUTHORITY
BE USE SO FOR FIRST YEAR THREE
POINT SIX MILLION TOTAL. TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR I. D.
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR
STAFF WERE ASKING FOR XIX
POSITIONS SHAGGY HERE ONE POINT
ONE MILLION FOR IT COST. EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND AGAIN FOR STAFF
AND SO THE OE POINT NINE
MILLION WOULD BE ONGOING GOING
FORWARD SH. SH THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX- THE LAST EPIDEMIC WE HAD
THE- A DOUBT PROGRAM AIDS. DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS INACCURATE
AND I AM THE CHIEF OF THE FISCAL
FORECASTING EVALUATION AND
MONITORING SECTION THAT OVERSEES
THE ESTIMATION. AND UNLESS THERE
IS ANOTHER PREFERENCE ALL
QUICKLY SURE THE GENERAL FUND
SUMMARY AND THE- REFINING
UTILIZATION PROJECTIONS AND THE
THREE ASSUMPTIONS WITH
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT NOTED IN THE
AGENDA. I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK ON
OTHER ASSUMPTIONS IF WANTED.
PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO PLAYS IS VERY
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S LAMINATION TO
GETTING TO ZERO PLAN TO IMPROVE
HIV SURVEILLANCE PREVENT NEW
INFECTIONS AND CARE FOR THOSE
LIVING WITH HIV. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR HIV
SURVEILLANCE EFFORTS. AND TWENTY
THREE POINT NINE MILLION
PROPOSAL YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND NINETEEN
POINT SIX MILLION FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
THE HIV PREVENTION PROGRAM.
FUNDING FOR THE AIDS DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS COMES FROM A
COMBINATION OF FEDERAL GRANTS
AND SPECIAL FUNDS. SPECIFICALLY
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND
CONTAINING THE FEDERAL HEALTH
RESOURCES AND SERVICE
ADMINISTRATION GRANT DOLLARS.
AND THE ETAPE REBATE FUND
SPECIAL FUN THREE THIRTY EIGHTY
WHICH CONTAINS OUR
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURER
REBATES. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET ESTIMATE
CONTAINS REVISED PROJECTIONS FOR
THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR COSTS
BOTH ARE EXPECTED TO BE LOWER
THAN PREVIOUSLY PROJECTED. FOR
THE CURRENT YEAR COST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDED
EIGHT UP LOCAL ASSISTANCE OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION. REVISED
CURRENT YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. THE MILLION A
DECREASE OF ABOUT ELEVEN POINT
7% WHEN COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. ACT OVERALL
COSTS RESPECTIVELY LOWER THAN
PREVIOUSLY PROJECTED IS THE
MAJOR FACTOR. IS MEDICATION
COSTS FOR THE UNINSURED CLIENTS
WHICH IS DRIVEN MAINLY BY
OVERALL CLIENT VOLUME WHICH IS
IMPACTED BY ATTRITION. AND THE
CLIENT MIX ARE SHIFTING CLIENTS
FROM UNRESTRICTED PRIVATE OR
MEDICARE COVERAGE- WHICH HAVE A
SHARE OF COST. SO WE'VE GOT
MAINLY A VOLUME AND MIX- DRIVER
THE MEDICATION PRICES HAVE
STAYED AROUND WHERE WE THOUGHT
THAT THEY WOULD BE. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE ESTIMATE
ALSO CLICK CONTAINS REVISED
ESTIMATES FOR THE CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR REVENUE WHICH IS EXPECTED
TO BE LOWER THAN PREVIOUSLY
PROJECTED. ALTHOUGH WE EXPECT AN
INCREASE- BY TWO POINT 7% TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS WE ALSO EXPECT A DROP OF
ABOUT SIXTY MILLION. FIFTEEN
POINT 7% AND A NET REBATE FUNDS
. THIS IS DRIVEN BY REDUCTIONS
IN THE OVERALL CLIENT VOLUME AND
CHANGES TO THE CLIENT NEXT I
DESCRIBED PREVIOUSLY. WITH YOUR
CLIENTS OR IF YOUR CLAIMS IN
WESTERN REBATE. AND ALTHOUGH
ATTRITION IS A MAJOR DRIVER ALSO
WITH EACH CLIENT BECOMES INSURED
BUT IT'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE LESS
FAVORABLE RETURNS- ARE DEPENDING
ON WHICH MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
TAKING. SO THE REDUCED CLIENT
VOLUME AND THE SHIPS IN THE ASIA
CLIENT MIX ARE EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET YEAR. SO
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR THE PROPOSED
EIGHT LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
IS FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY POINT SIX
MILLION. I DROP OF SIXTY EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION OR 14% WHEN
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. WE EXPECT A
DECREASE OF THREE POINT ONE
MILLION- 3% IN THE EXPECTED
FEDERAL FUNDS AND A SIXTY FIVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION SEVENTEEN
POINT 2% DROP IN PROJECTED ADA
REBATE FUNDS. THE SUMMER HIS
SUMMARY OF THESE FUNDING SOURCES
CAN BE SEEN ON THE TABLE ONE OF
THE- TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE EIGHT OUT NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE. I WANT TO BE MINDFUL
OF TIME- SO I WANTED TO STOP
YOUR GROUP FOR PRESENTING ON THE
THREE MEDICARE SPECIFIC TEACHER
POST CALL SOMETIMES AND ONE.
ASSUMPTION THAT WOULD EXPAND THE
PROVISION OF HIV MEDICATION
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE CONTAINED IN
CALIFORNIA JAILS. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE OVERALL.
COST. OKAY SO NEWLY INTRODUCED
TO THE CYCLE DO STAKEHOLDER
INTEREST INSURING PARITY BETWEEN
THE MEDICARE COVERS GROUPS. WE
HAVE A PAYMENT OF MEDICARE PART
D. PREMIUMS PLUS EXPANSION THIS
IS THE FUTURE THIS CALL IS SHE
WALL CDPH OPPOSITES CONDUCTS
THIS DISCOVERY TO REFINE THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT AND THEN
ALSO TO CONFIRM AN
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE AND ONCE
WE HAVE THE SCOPE AND THE
PROPOSED SCHEDULE BURNED UP. WE
CAN ESTIMATE HE NEEDED
RESOURCES. BUT FOR BACKGROUND.
RIGHT NOW ALL THE OFFICE SPACE
PAYS THE PREMIUMS AN OUTPATIENT
MEDICAL OUT OF POCKET COSTS. FOR
OUR CLIENTS TO HAVE PRIVATE
INSURANCE AND MEDICARE PART D.
AND WHEN IT ENDED UP CLIENT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE THEY HAVE
TO ENROLL IN MEDICARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE THE PAYER OF
LAST RESORT. IF THEY ENROLL IN
MEDICARE PART D. THEY CAN GET
HELP WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL OR
MEDIGAP PLAN PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
BUT IN CONTRAST A CLIENT WHO
ENROLLS IN MEDICARE PART SEE.
THEY CAN GET NO PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE AND THEY CAN NOT GET
NO MEDICAL OUT OF POCKET COST
ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE AIDS DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
WHICH CREATES A LACK OF PARITY.
IN EIGHT US MEDICARE SERVICE
DELIVERY. MEDICARE PART C. ALSO
KNOWN AS MEDICARE ADVANTAGE IS
THE BUNDLED INSURANCE PLAN OF
COURSE THAT INCLUDES THE
HOSPITAL BENEFITS FOR MEDICARE
PART A- MEDICAL CARE PART B. AND
THE PRESCRIPTIONS. MEDICARE PART
D. SO D. R. FEDERAL FUNDERS
POLICY HELPS US TO CLOSE THAT
GAP UNDER THAT POLICY GRANT
RECIPIENTS CAN NOW USE THE FUNDS
TO PAY THE PREMIUMS AND COST
SHARING WHEN THE MEDICARE PART
C. PLAN INCLUDES PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COVERAGE. SO END UP IS
PROPOSING TO USE THE REBATE
FUNDS TO ESTABLISH THE MEDICARE
PART C. PREMIUM PAYMENT PROGRAM
AND PAY FOR MEDICARE PART B.
PREMIUMS FOR THOSE ELIGIBLE
EIGHT OUT CLIENTS. THERE IS NO
KNOWN PHYSICAL IMPACT AT THIS
TIME- BUT WE ARE FIRMING UP THE
SCOPE AND THE SCHEDULE AND THEN
ONCE WE DO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
AN ESTIMATE OF THE COST. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO. THE NEXT
MEDICARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SO THIS NEXT SECTION IS A
COROLLARY TO THE LAST ASSUMPTION
DUE TO STAKEHOLDER INTERESTS AND
ALSO TO ENSURE PARITY BETWEEN
THE MEDICARE COVERAGE GROUPS-
IT'S ALSO A TEACHER AT SCHOOL
WHILE WE CONDUCT OUR DISCOVERY
ONCE WE HAVE THE SCOPE AND THE
SCHEDULE PERMED UP WE CAN
ESTIMATE THE RESOURCES NEEDS SO
THIS IS- BSICALLY INVEST IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE PREMIUMS ARE
THE CLIENTS WHO ARE IN OUR-
MEDICARE PREMIUM PAYMENT PROGRAM
WE ALSO WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. COVERAGE FOR THE
MEDICAL OUT OF POCKET COSTS AS
WELL. SO RIGHT NOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT- ESTABLISHING
EQUITABLE BENEFITS FOR INSTANCE
TRANSISTORS AND PROGRAMS AND
THEN ALSO TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
FOR AN APPLIANCE AS THE AGE AND
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE.
AND THE FISCAL IMPACT IS UNKNOWN
AT THIS TIME BUT WE WILL KNOW
MORE ONCE WERE ABLE TO THE
SCOPING AND THE- SCHEDULE
CLARIFICATION. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT ASSUMPTION
BEFORE I MOVE ON TO THE MEDICARE
COVERAGE OF EXTRA AND INNOVATIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL PLANS NOW PLEASE
MOVE ON. OKAY ALSO NEWLY
INTRODUCED THE CYCLE AND A
COROLLARY TO THE LAST
ASSUMPTION- WE ARE LOOKING AT.
I'M LOOKING AT COVERING THESE
SUPPLEMENTAL PLANS A SPECIFIC
KIND OF SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN THERE
ARE A LOT OF OPTIONS FOR THE
MEDIGAP PLANS- AND THEIR VARYING
LEVELS OF COVERAGE FOR MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL PLANS A THROUGH AND
WITH F. AND G. BEING THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE. OBVIOUS MOST
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS ALSO OFFER
EXTRA INNOVATIVE BENEFITS TO
COVER SERVICES OUTSIDE OF THE
BASE MEDICAL COVERAGE EXAMPLES
OF THESE EXTRA BENEFITS INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE SILVER SNEAKERS GYM
MEMBERSHIPS NURSE CONSULTATIONS-
HEARINGS. AIDS VISION EXAMS AND
ALL OF OUR MODELS THAT LOOK AT
HER IN A POPULATION SHOW THAT
ARE IN THE POPULATION IS AGING
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE INSURED
AND DUE TO VARIOUS ADVANCEMENTS
IN CARE TREATMENT- THEY'RE
LIVING LONGER AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR HEALTH
NEEDS ARE MET. OVER THE COURSE
OF THEIR LIFE- SOME OF THESE
EXTRA BENEFITS ARE RELATED TO
THINGS LIKE- THEIR SOCIAL NEEDS
REDUCING SOCIAL ISOLATION AND SO
WHAT WE SEE WITH OUR AGING
POPULATION AS AS PEOPLE GROW
OLDER THEY TEND TO SPEND MORE
MORE TIME ALONE. AND WITH THE
STIGMA THAT COMES WITH AN HIV
DIAGNOSIS THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY AN
APPLE. FOR OUR CLIENTS SO WHAT
WE ARE LOOKING TO DO IS- WE HAVE
OUR BEEN PAID. THE MEDIC. RB
SUPPLEMENTAL MEDICAL PLAN
PREMIUMS- WE WANT TO EXTEND THIS
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN COVER
THESE EXTRA AN INNOVATIVE
BENEFITS UP AND WE ARE LOOKING
TO USE THE REBATE FUNDS TO PAY
FOR THIS. THE GOAL IS TO IMPROVE
THE OVERALL HEALTH OF FOLKS
LIVING WITH HIV MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE FULL RANGE OF
CHOICES TO INSURE THAT THEY CAN
STAY HEALTHY BECAUSE HEALTH IS
MUCH MORE THAN JUST THEIR- THEIR
BASIC NEEDS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT SOCIAL HELL. AND THAT THEY
HAVE A WAY TO MEET ALL OF THEIR
NEEDS AS THEY AGE- AND SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOCKED INTO ANY ONE
PARTICULAR PLAN JUST BECAUSE
THEY NEED HELP FROM US. SO THE
PHYSICAL IMPACT RIGHT NOW IS
STILL UNKNOWN BUT WE ARE FIRMING
UP LIKE I SAID THE SCOPE AND THE
SCHEDULE AND WE'LL HAVE A FIRMER
ESTIMATE OF THE RESOURCE NEEDS.
COMING ONCE WE HAVE DONE. WERE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON OKAY ON
THOSE THREE MEDICARE RELATED
ASSUMPTIONS ARE EXTENSIONS OF
OKAY. SO THE LAST ASSUMPTION IS
NEWLY IMPLEMENTED IN IT WAS
RELATED TO THE PROVISION OF CARE
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE TANGLED UP IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM OF.
BEFORE TWENTY EIGHTEEN EIGHT
I'VE HAD ABOUT THIRTY SIX LOCAL
COUNTY JAILS THAT PARTICIPATED
IN THE END UP PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
WHO QUALIFY BEFORE THEY WERE
RELEASED THE PROGRAM WAS ENDED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO
ELIMINATION FINDING. RECENTLY
OUR FEDERAL GRANT FUNDERS
UPDATED THEIR POLICIES THAT
ALLOW THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DETAINED IN
THE COUNTY JAIL BUT AREN'T YET
CONVICTED OF A CRIME AND ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE FEDERAL OR STATE
HEALTH BENEFITS WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED. SO AFTER LEARNING
ABOUT THAT POLICY CHANGE OR
ACCOUNT OR TO COUNTY ASKED US IF
IT UP COULD PROVIDE SERVICES AT
THE COUNTY JAIL AND THAT WOULD
EXPAND THE OUTREACH TO A
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
POPULATION. AND THEN ALSO ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR ANY OF
OUR OWN EIGHT UP PLANS FOR
NAVIGATING THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
SO ONCE RESPONSE TO THE REQUEST
AND STAKEHOLDER TO MANAGE- A
LOST A SMALL PILOT PROGRAM WITH
THEIR COUNTY JAIL. IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND WE'VE BEEN MONITORING
THE PILOT PROGRAM- REGULARLY AND
CONSIDERING EXPANDING THAT
PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE. TWO
OTHERS WHO ARE INTERESTED AND
THOSE OTHER COUNTIES THAT ARE
INTERESTED OUR LOS ANGELES
MORAN. RIVERSIDE SAN FRANCISCO
ALLEN'S OF THIS PHOTO AND SINCE
YOU. AND OF COURSE IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND AFTER CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THE IMPACT TO
THE THAT REBATE POND. IN THE
SHORT AND THE LONG TERM- IS
REQUESTING THAT THE EIGHT AT GL
PILOT PROGRAM THAT'S IN ORANGE
COUNTY BE EXTENDED TO THE OTHER
INTERESTED COUNTY JAILS. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. WE WOULD MEET
WHEN THE INTERESTED COUNTY JAILS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THEY OPERATE
HOW THEY DO THEIR TESTING. WE
WOULD DETERMINE. IF THIS IS A
SUITABLE OPERA GRAHAM FOR THEM
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE NORMAL ENROLLMENT SITE
APPLICATION AND TURN CONTRACTS
WITH US. HE ADDED TO OUR
PHARMACY BENEFITS MANAGERS
PHARMACY NETWORK AND COMPLETE
THE NUMERAL OR TRAINING BEFORE
THEY CAN START ENROLLING ANY
ELIGIBLE CLIENTS. SO THEY HAVE
BEEN FULLY TRAINED- THEY'D HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE SAME KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONAL CONTROLS AS ARE
IN REMOTE WORKERS DO- BUT- WE'RE
LOOKING AT- EIGHT POTENTIAL THAT
CAUSAL IMPACT- IS NOT CHANGED
ORANGE COUNTY BUT WE HAVE
PROVIDED THE IMPACT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- AND- WE
ARE LOOKING. AT THE END
ACCOUNTING. ORANGE COUNTY. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH ELEVEN.
SEVEN MILLION- AND THE ESTIMATED
IMPACT FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE OF THE FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION ACTUALLY TAKE OUT REBATE
. ANOTHER THAT WAS VERY QUICK.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS- OPPOSED EXPANSION NOW
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF THE OTHER
ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE IN THAT
PACKAGE NOW WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ZERO NASH AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WITH
MARISSA AND ROSS. GOOD AFTERNOON
AMARISTA RAMOS THE CHIEF FOR THE
OFFICE DEBATE. AND THAT WILL
SPEAK ON- AB THREE OH SIX SO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUEST THREE POSITIONS
I'M FOR HONDA'S PLEASE SENATOR
PAN. IS IT A B. IT'S S. B. S. B.
DARI. SORRY ABOUT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUEST THREE POSITIONS
THAT FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND ON GOING. THE REQUESTED
FUNDING- AND PHYSICIANS ARE FOR
TO HEALTH PROGRAM SPECIALIST
ONES AND ONE ASSOCIATE CHAD
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST. WE
ARE REQUESTING THOSE POSITIONS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NEEDED TO MANAGE
THE INCREASE FOR WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE SP THREE OH SIX ALLOWING HIV
TEST COUNSELORS TO PERFORM ANY
H. I. B. H. C. B. OR OTHER STD
TESTS. THAT IS CLASSIFIED AS
WAVES UNDER CLIA. ANY QUESTIONS
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT PUBLIC HEALTH CODE
NINETEEN SP. THREE THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU HI THIS IS JAMES WHITE
AGAIN- THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH REQUESTS SHE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FROM THE STATE GENERAL FUND TO
FULLY COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF SB THREE THIRTY SIX. THE
STATUTE REQUIRES CDPH TO OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN AN EMAIL
DISTRIBUTION LIST. RIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITIES
NONPROFITS AND INDIVIDUALS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION REGARDING CHANGES TO
COVER NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS. IN ADDITION THE STATUTE
REQUIRES C. PH TO POST THE
ORDERS ON ITS WEBSITE. THE
REQUESTED FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
STAFF WHO WILL MANAGE THE EMAIL
DISTRIBUTION LIST. AVOID
CUSTOMER SERVICE RELATED TO THE
EMAIL SYSTEM AND YOUR QUESTIONS
FROM THE PUBLIC CANCER QUESTION
ABOUT HOW TO JOIN THE LIST TO BE
REMOVED OR ASK ABOUT. ORDERS AND
GUIDANCE. COORDINATE MESSAGES
FOR DISTRIBUTION AND POSTING ON
THE WEBSITE. I'M MANAGING
NECESSARY MODIFICATIONS TO THE
SYSTEM MONITOR SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE PROVIDE ANALYTICS
AND REPORTS AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS RELATED TO
THEIR OWN SP THREE THIRTY SIX OF
ORANGE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ISSUE NUMBER NINE DR
RADHAKRISHNAN. SURE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AT REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER NINE CLIMATE AND HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS CONSIDERED THE
GREATEST PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT OF
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND IS
IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS TODAY THIS INCLUDES
THE IMPACT FROM INJURY ILLNESS
DEATH WILDFIRE SMOKE EXTREME
HEAT DROUGHT LANDSLIDES EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS VICTOR BORNE
DISEASES AND MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS THE HARMS ARE ALSO
IMPOSE DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN CALIFORNIA. AS REFERENCED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TENTH
BLUEPRINT IT IS THE SECOND
pTACKLE AND AS REFERENCED BY
DIRECTOR I DON'T GO ON REGARDING
THE FOUR PILLARS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STRENGTHEN COLOR NUMBER ONE ECO
SOCIAL APPROACHFOR THE
CONDITIONS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT CREATE HEALTHY
OPPORTUNITIES. TO CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW IS ONE OF THE FEW U.
S. STATES THAT LACKS A STATEWIDE
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE MECHANISM
FOR KEEPING THIS AS AN EXAMPLE
AND OUR DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
UNABLE TO PROVIDE A REAL TIME
COUNT OF DEATHS OR ILLNESSES FOR
SOMETHING LIKE EXTREME HEAT.
DEVELOPMENT OF A SYNDROMIC
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM WOULD
PROVIDE NEAR REAL TIME DATA FROM
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
IDENTIFY THE ISSUES EARLY
MONITOR TRENDS TRACK AND TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE THIS WITH
MANY OFFICIALS AT THE STATE
LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC THEREFORE IN THIS ITEM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUESTS THIRTY POSITIONS AND
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE OF TEN
MILLION ANNUALLY. THESE
POSITIONS AND RESOURCES WOULD
ALLOW US TO DO THIS NEAR REAL
TIME NOTIFICATION FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS FIRST
RESPONDERS AND COMMUNITY FOR A
VARIETY OF INTENSIFIED CLIMATE
SENSITIVE DISEASES THAT DIRECTOR
ARTICLE MENTIONED WERE
INCREASING SCALE SCOPE AND
SEVERITY IN THE YEARS TO COME I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS IS
NOT JUST ABOUT EXTREME HEAT OR
WILDFIRES SMOKE THERE'S MANY
OTHER CLIMATE SENSITIVE VECTOR
BORNE DISEASES LIKE WEST NILE
VIRUS THERE'S WATER BORNE
DISEASES LIKE VIBRIO. FOOD.
BORNE ILLNESSES WHICH YOU
REFERENCED THE TERMS FOOD C. SO
. AND CALLED. YES FOREIGN FEE.
AND THE MAN HEALTH AND TAX. SO
WE WOULD. WITH THE FEDERAL CDC'S
. THE NATIONAL SYNDROMIC
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM THROUGH A
PROGRAM CALLED BIOSENSOR
PARTICIPANTS WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
COLLECT ANALYZE AND SHARE
ELECTRONIC PATIENT ENCOUNTER
DATA FROM EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN THIS PROGRAM AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT THESE FUNDS
WOULD ALLOW US TO DO SO. WE
COULD UPGRADE DATA SYSTEMS FOR
REPORTING ANALYSIS DISPLAY
COMMUNICATION DATA TRANSFER AND
SHARING WITH MANY PARTNERS. AND
ALSO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ACCESS
VIEW ANALYZE AND USE THIS DATA
ULTIMATELY THE AIM IS TO CREATE
PREDICTIVE ANALYTIC MODELS. FOR
NOT JUST THE INCIDENTS BUT ALSO
THE ABILITY TO PROACTIVELY
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME
CLIMATE. AND FUNDING WOULD ALSO
BE USED FOR THE FEES FOR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
TO PAY ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
VENDORS TO ESTABLISH THIS
CONNECTION. FINALLY WE WOULD
EMPLOY A COMMUNICATIONS
SPECIALIST TO HELP COMMUNICATE
OUT THE RESULTS FOR ACTIONABLE
SOLUTIONS. TO DIVERSE PARTNERS
INCLUDING THE MEDIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S JUST GO RIGHT ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN THEN AND NOW
HERE FOR MILLENNIA. THANK YOU-
SO AS MENTION CLIMATE CHANGE
AFFECTS MANY ASPECTS OF OUR
LIVES NOT JUST HEALTH BUT ALSO
LIVELIHOODS BUSINESSES CROPS
HOMES- CONTRIBUTES TO
UNEMPLOYMENT POVERTY AND THE
HOUSING CRISIS. THERE FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TEN REALLY FOCUSES ON
PUBLIC HEALTH REGIONAL CLIMATE
PLANNING. ON THE IMPACTS ARE
CASCADING ON MANY ASPECTS OF
HEALTH FROM CHRONIC AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASE TO MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES. AND TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A MORE PROACTIVE
IN PLANNING APPROACH WE
REQUESTED GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME. THIS WOULD
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE REQUESTED FUNDING AND
SUPPORT TO DO MORE PROACTIVE
WORK IN TERMS OF PLANNING. IT
ALSO ALLOWS THE FUND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND TRIBES
TO DEVELOP REGIONAL CLIMATE AND
HEALTH RESILIENCE PLANS. ON
DOING SO WOULD ALLOW RESOURCE
LIMITED HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
PREVENT AND REDUCE THE
INEQUITABLE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RISKS. EACH OF
THE FIVE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
REGIONS WOULD BE SUPPORTED TO
WRITE A CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HEALTH RESILIENCE PLAN THAT
WOULD BE COORDINATED I WANTED TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL- THERE'S A LONG
LIST OF THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN
AT THE REGIONAL LOCAL LEVEL THAT
I WON'T GO INTO BUT WE WOULD
PROVIDE. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FROM THE STATE TO THE AWARDEES
TO PRIORITIZE THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD BE MOST IMPACTED AND
ENGAGE THEM- IN THIS LOCAL
PLANNING AND AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL AND IF RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT- REGIONAL COALITIONS
COULD BEGIN. PROSPECTS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PLAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR INVITING
. L. SHE SHE CAN L. L. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CINEMATIC FROM THE
LA- WE JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT EACH OF THE PROPOSALS- ON
ISSUE NINE THE CLIMATE AND
HEALTH SURVEILLANCE PROGRAM WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS- PROPOSAL
DOESN'T DRESS- CURRENT GAP IN
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE RELATED- EVENTS AND
PARTICULARLY THAT THE HEALTH- IN
IN. MONITORING THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE RELATED
EVENTS IN THE PROPOSAL DOES HAVE
A NUMBER OF MERITS ONE WE KNOW
THAT THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW PARTICULARLY AS THE NUMBER
AND SEVERITY OF CLIMATE RELATED
WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE REAL TIME
ANALYSIS- ALLOWING FOR THE EARLY
DETECTION OF OUTBREAKS- IT WILL
ALSO FACILITATE BETTER PLANNING
BY INCREASING AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THE MAGNITUDE OF POTENTIAL
FUTURE MAGNITUDE OF SOME OF THE
VARIOUS. TYPES OF HEALTH IMPACTS
FROM CLIMATE RELATED EVENTS AND
HOW THESE IMPACTS REALLY
AFFECTS- BOTH DIFFERENT GROUPS
OF PEOPLE AS WELL AS DIFFERENT
REGIONS- AROUND THE STATE AND
THEN WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT IT
ALLOWS- OR WE HOPE THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR BETTER EVALUATION- FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS
THE VERY IS DATA COLLECTED WE
HOPE WOULD FACILITATE A MORE
ANALYSIS AND EVALUATION OF THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTIVENESS OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS
THAT ARE TAKEN TO REDUCE. THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- IN IN SPEAKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL-
WE WOULD JUST ALSO NOTE THAT
PARTICIPATION IN THE CDC'S BIO
SENSE PROGRAM REALLY ENABLES
CALIFORNIA TO PARTICIPATE IN A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE WITH OTHER
STATES AND THEN ENGAGE IN
CALIFORNIA CAN ENGAGE THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS IN A STATE
LEVEL COMMUNITY OF. PRACTICE-
THE ONE THAT THAT WE WULD RAISE
WITH THE PROPOSED WHICH IS THIS
IS A CREEK OF THE PROPOSED
ITSELF IT'S MORE MORE JUST A
COMMENT- SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT MAKES IT
POSSIBLE TO DETECT ISSUES AND
OUTBREAKS. EARLY AND DO THAT
SORT OF REAL TIME ANALYSIS THAT
WAS DISCUSSED. BUT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY DETERMINE WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT- BEYOND JUST SORT
OF NOTIFICATION- SO FOR EXAMPLE
HOW WILL THIS TO USE THIS
INFORMATION IN REAL TIME TO
ACTIVATE A RESPONSE BY THE
RELEVANT STATE AND LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES- IS AN
IMPORTANT SHOW- WERE YOU KNOW.
SORT OF FOLLOW UP QUESTION AND
IT. I THINK THIS MAKES THIS IS A
GOOD SEGUE ACTUALLY INTO OUR
COMMENTS ON THE NEXT PROPOSAL-
YOU KNOW WHICH REALLY INVOLVES
THE PLANNING. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE. AND BEFORE I
GET INTO SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON
THE PROPOSAL I'M GONNA TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE A GENERAL
POINT ABOUT NOT ONLY THIS.
PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER TEN BUT
ALSO A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- BUDGET AND IN
FACT THE SCHOOL MAYBE REDUCE THE
NEED HER TO CALL ON THE LA- ON A
NUMBER OF THE FUTURE- ITEMS- WE
JUST KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR THAT REQUEST
ONE TIME. FUNDING FOR A SPECIFIC
PURPOSE- SO IT INCLUDES THIS
PROPOSAL FOR REGIONAL CLIMATE
PLANNING- THERE'S ANOTHER
PROPOSAL- FOR BOOKS FOR CHILDREN
IN THE WICK PROGRAM SH THERE'S
ONE TO SUPPORT THE FITNESS KEPT
THE GOVERNOR'S FITNESS COUNCIL.
AND THERE'S ONE FOR EXAMPLE FOR
GRANTS FOR ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE-
PILOT PROGRAMS. AND WE WERE OUR
OFFICE WOULD JUST KNOW THAT ONE
TIME APPROPRIATIONS MAY MAKE
SENSE THIS YEAR FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
THE STATE DOES HAVE A-
DISCRETIONARY BUDGET SURPLUS
THIS YEAR. BUT WE HAVE NO
GUARANTEE THAT THOSE REVENUES
ARE GOING TO REMAIN AT THAT
LEVEL SH SO OUR OFFICE REGULARLY
CAUTIONS AGAINST- OVER
COMMITTING FUNDING TO ONGOING
PROGRAMS DURING GOOD TIMES THAT
CANNOT REALISTICALLY BE.
SUSTAINED DURING DOWNTURNS- IT
ALSO MAKES SENSE TO DO ONE TIME-
I DO HAVE ONE TIME AUGMENTATIONS
WANTED APARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE
WANTS TO TEST OUT A PROGRAM ON A
LIMITED BASIS TO SEE IF IT WOULD
BRING VALUE SH- SUCH AS
REDUCING- AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACT- HEALTH DISPARITY OR TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. SH
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT WAS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SPECIFICALLY ONE OF THE
HISTORIC CHALLENGES IN THIS
DEPARTMENT IS THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF THE FUNDING.IS PROVIDED
ON A ONE TIME BASIS FOR I'M
SPECIFIC PURPOSE. AND THEN WHEN
THE FOR GOES AWAY THE STAR OF-
EXTRA- THE VAL THAT THAT PROGRAM
BROUGHT- CAN ALSO SOMETIMES GO
AWAY. SO WE WOULD JUST SUGGEST
MAKING SURE THAT- THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED THIS YEAR SORT OF
- MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO LEVERAGE
KIND OF EXISTING RESOURCES IN
THE FUTURE. OR OR LAY A
FOUNDATION HAT CAN BE- ACTED
UPON- IN THE FUTURE WITH AN
EXISTING- RESOURCES. ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL SORRY FOR
THE LONG WINDED- SORT OF
COMMENTARY ABOUT ONE TIME
PROPOSALS BUT- ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE THINK IT
HAS A LOT OF MARRIAGE WE ARE
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT MANY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE THE STAFFER
EXPERTISE TO CONDUCT- PLANNING
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE. I'M A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WISH TO
CONSIDER OR ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT- WHAT ARE
THE POTENTIAL DRAWBACKS OF
HAVING THESE PLANS WILL BE
CREATED AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL-
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME
BENEFITS TO HAVING A REGIONAL
REGIONAL PLANNING IN PLACE
PARTICULARLY FOR AN ISSUE LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH DOES NOT
RESPECT COUNTY BORDERS- HOWEVER
THIS PROPOSAL ONLY INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN COUNTIES
EVEN THOUGH THE PLANNING WILL BE
DONE AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL. AND
OUR CONCERN IS- JUST ABOUT
ENGAGEMENT BY THE OTHER LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS WHO- WHO DO
NOT HAVE THE FUNDING TO
PARTICIPATE IN WHETHER THEY'LL
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO FULLY
ENGAGE. AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT WEWOULD RAISE IS IT'S JUST
HARD TO KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
AFTER THESE PLANS ARE IN PLACE-
WILL WILL THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THESE PLANS IF THEY
DON'T HAVE. THE RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO DO SO THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME THERE AND- FOR
ALLOWING THE COMMENTARY ON ONE
TIME AUGMENTATIONS AND- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WE
ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND I THINK WE'LL SHARE YOUR
YOUR CONCERNS AND HESITATION TO
ABOUT ONE TIME FUNDS AND THE YOU
KNOW SOMETHING REALLY GOOD
HAPPENS AND THEN A COUPLE YEARS
LATER IT GOES AWAY AND EVERYONE
SAYS THAT WAS SO GOOD- I THINK I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY TO THE-
INTERVENED N. H. DEPARTMENT ON
THAT PRESENTATION JUST THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
I LOST FRIENDS LAST YEAR WHO.
HAD BEEN LIVING WITH HIV AIDS
AND SHE WAS PROBABLY TWENTY FIVE
AND HE JUST DIED THIS YEAR AT
SIXTY SO WE KNOW THE WORK IS
GOOD AND IMPORTANT- AND I WOULD
SAY ON THE CLIMATE A MINUTE I'M
GLAD ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT WE HAVE. WE CAN
JUST. USUALLY WE DON'T HAVE TO
RECREATE SOMETHING FROM THE
WHEEL IS AT THAT AS I UNDERSTAND
IT WE'RE GONNA. BRING TO
PARTICIPATE WITH THE NATIONAL
MODEL TO BE ABLE TO SET
SOMETHING UP. AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS. DO WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY ALREADY AVAILABLE TO
BE ABLE TO. AS WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT TECHNOLOGY. TO BE ABLE
TO PRETTY SEAMLESSLY. PUT THAT
IN PLACE NOW IS MY QUESTION ON
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. YEAH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND I'LL
BRIEFLY ADDRESS MISS PATRICK'S
COMMENTS AS WELL SO- CURRENTLY
THERE ARE. EIGHTEEN COUNTIES
THAT HAD AT LEAST ONE FACILITY
THAT IS PARTICIPATING. IN THIS-
BUT- TO MAKE IT REALLY SPREAD
ACROSS THE STATE TEN THE- THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT FACILITIES AND
THERE'S OTHER TYPES OF
FACILITIES AS WELL- BERTHING
FACILITIES- AND OTHERS THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THE INCENTIVES IN THE
TRAINING IN THE ONBOARDING. BUT
THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN PLACE. ARE
ADEQUATE- IT'S JUST
INCENTIVIZING. LOCAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS TO GO THE NEXT STEP-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MODERNIZATION OF THE CDC
BIOSENSOR PLATFORM SO IT'S MORE
USER FRIENDLY WAS DESIGNED FOR.
BIOTERRORISM BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE. AND TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN WENT
THROUGH A LOT OF UPGRADES- AND
SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD TIME TAT
TAT TAT SPREAD THIS FURTHER. ON
BUT TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS MISS
PANICS POINT ABOUT SOME OF THE
DRAWBACKS- WE WOULD AGREE THAT
REGIONAL IS A GOOD PLACE TO
START IT'S NECESSARY BUT NOT
SUFFICIENT. ALL SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS HAVE. ON
THEIR OWN GENERAL PLANS HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS CLIMATE ACTION
PLANS. AND FUNDING PERMITTED- IT
WOULD BE IDEAL TO NOT JUST DO
THIS PLANNING AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL BUT- AT ALL OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL SINCE THAT THREAT WILL
AFFECT ALL CALIFORNIANS- WEEK
KNOWLEDGE THAT. CLIMATE CHANGE
IS NOT A ONE TIME ISSUE HAS
MENTIONED IT WILL INCREASE IN
SCOPE SEVERITY. AND SCALE- AND
SO- PLANNING IS ESSENTIAL WE
HAVE TO DO THAT BUT FUNDING
PERMITTING A WOULD DETERMINE HOW
MUCH WE'RE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
ASPECTS OF THOSE PLANS GOING
INTO THE FUTURE. THE YOU AND IF
YOU GET ALL RESPOND TO. MISTAKES
BECAUSE WHICH IS WHEN I ABOUT
AFTER WE- AFTER IF WE CAN IF WE
COULD PREDICT THINGS. OR OR IF
WE CAN EARLIER- IDENTIFY THINGS
BUT THEN ARE WE ALSO GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MEDICATE AND I'M
THINKING OF I LIVE IN A- AT THE
END IN THE AREA AND IN THE DELTA
WHERE WHEN IT GETS VERY HOT AND
THE WATER FLOW DOESN'T FLOW R.
BAR WATERS IN STREAMS GET FILLED
UP WITH. ALGAE THAT IS TOXIC AND
POISONOUS. AND SO THE
ANNOUNCEMENT JUST EVERYONE STAY
OUT OF THE WATER BUT THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS POSSIBLE SO WELL THEY'RE
ALSO THEN BE IT FOLLOW UP WITH
MEDICATION AND INTERVENTION AND
BEST. PRACTICES WE WERE ABLE TO
PREDICT. SOMETHING SOMETHING BAD
IS GETTING READY TO HAPPEN. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY AND YOU'RE REALLY
REFERENCING- THE PILLARS THAT
DIRECTOR OUTGOING MENTIONED
WHICH IS REALLY AIMING TOWARDS
PREVENTION RIGHT WE DON'T WANT
TO JUST. COUNT HARM CALIFORNIANS
FROM THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PREDICT IT MITIGATED AND
ULTIMATELY. PREVENTED THAT
FOURTH PILLAR. SO GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE WHEN IT COMES TO HEAT.
RIGHT NOW WHEN WE ISSUE A HEAT
WARNING. THAT'S BASED ON A VERY
NON PRECISE HISTORIC TEMPERATURE
AVERAGES IT HAS NO RELATIONSHIP
TO HUMAN HEALTH. FOR ABLE TO
BETTER QUANTIFY. IN A MICRO
CLIMATE REGION WHEN A PARTICULAR
TEMPERATURE THRESHOLD AFFECTS A
PARTICULAR VULNERABLE COMMUNITY.
THEN WE CAN HAVE. HEALTH RELATED
HEAT WARNINGS WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE. BE
MORE PROACTIVE AND THAT'S JUST
ON THE FRONT YOU MENTIONED TOXIC
ALGAE BLOOMS. AND THERE'S MANY
OTHER AS I MENTIONED WATER FOOD
AIR FUNGAL BORN SH- CONDITIONS
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO NOT
JUST COUNT REAL TIME. BUT
ULTIMATELY- PROJECT AS WELL AS
MEDICAID SO. SOME OF THE STAFF
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS
INITIATIVE. INCLUDES FOR THE
MODELING AND THE COMMUNICATION.
AND THE LEARNING THAT COMES FROM
THE REAL TIME INFORMATION- JUST
LIKE WITH CODING YOUKNOW
HAVING. SEQUENCING FOR THEIR-
NEWEST VARIANT ALLOWS US TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE TO MITIGATE. THE
SAME WOULD BE. TRUE FOR CLIMATE
THREATS MOVING INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU AND I GUESS IT'S FUNNY
I WOULD I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
AS WE'RE DEVELOPING THESE NEW
REGIONAL PLANS I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE WOULD USE INFORMATION ALREADY
AVAILABLE- THERE'S- YOU KNOW.
MEMBERS PASAL LOT OF BILLS THAT
BECAUSE ANIMALS REALLY RIGHT I
THINK WITH THAT. I WAS FROM
822-000-1718 I THINK A B. SIX
SEVENTEEN. I MISS GARCIA
PRESIDENT HAS A GROUP SET UP ALL
OVER THE STATE COMMUNITY GROUPS
ARE LOOKING AT AIR QUALITY AND
ISSUES LIKE THAT SO. JUST MAKE
SURE WE DON'T. THAT WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF THE TASK FORCE
AND COMMISSIONS AND EVERYTHING
IS ALREADY SET UP OUT THERE.
COLLECTING A LOT OF THIS DATA
AND THAT WE'RE ABLE TO JUST- NOT
NOT. NOT REINVENT THE WHEEL BUT
BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE THE
INFORMATION THAT IS ALREADY
BEING GATHERED. AND MAKE SURE
THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE INPUT THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY GIVEN ON A LOT
OF THESE TOPICS. ABSOLUTELY AND
I'LL SAY OF ALL THE PLANS THAT
EXIST WHAT'S OFTEN MISSING IS
THE WORD HELP. THERE'S HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS THERE'S-
GENERAL PLAN UPDATES LOOKING AT
CODE AND TRENDS- THERE IS. MORE
BROADER PLANS LIKE SP ONE
THOUSAND- THAT FOCUSES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
BUT- WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
CENTER NOW AS AS THE U. N.
SECRETARY GENERAL ISSUED A- CODE
RED FOR HUMANITY WERE CALLING A
CODE BLUE. ABOUT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS. AND REALLY PULLING ALL
THOSE PLANS AND DATA FROM A
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. AT THE
REGIONAL AND HOPEFULLY LOCAL
LEVEL. AND I WAS JUST ALWAYS-
AND I'M SURE DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS TOO IS WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT. STRESS PTSD MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES TO MAKE SURE THOSE ISSUES
ARE. CAN GET INTEGRATED INTO A
REGIONAL PLAN. THAT WE KNOW WHEN
THINGS ARE GONNA POP. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR NAMING THAT IT'S
AN EMERGING FIELD IS THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. ANXIETY
DEPRESSION FEAR OF THE FUTURE OF
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AFTER EXTREME EVENTS WILDFIRE
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR HOMES-
INTERACTS WITH MEDICATIONS IT
INCREASES. A HIGHER NIGHT TIME
TEMPERATURES VIOLENCE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE GUN VIOLENCE AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BETTER MONITOR PREDICT AND
PREVENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SO I JUST WANT
KNOWLEDGE AND YOU KNOW WE PASS
THROUGH THESE PRETTY QUICKLY BUT
FOR EXAMPLE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
HOW IMPORTANT IS TO TRY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND PREVENT
FRAUD- WITH- WITH THE PEOPLE
DOING THIS. SO CALLED SOME STYLE
TREATMENTS AREN'T REALLY STEM
CELLS- REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN
SAID DELVED IMPORTANCE OF-
BATTLING HIV JUST BECAUSE AND
THAT'S A REMINDER TO US THAT-
INSPECTIONS DON'T JUST GO AWAY
AND THAT THAT'S WHY WE CONTINUE
TO MITIGATE- AND- THAT BECOMES.
THE NEW NORMAL RIGHT SO-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN'T WE'LL
CONTINUE TO MAKE ADVANCEMENTS TO
ELIMINATE HIV AND AIDS FIVE. IT
STILL IN AN OF COURSE CREATING.
SP TSX WHICH THE BILL I AUTHORED
AND WE'LL GET DOWN THIS STD
RATES AS WELL- I DID HAVE SOME.
MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AROUND-
THE- AROUND THE- BY A SENSE
PROGRAM SO I REALIZE THAT IT'S
FRAMED HERE'S CLAIM IT- BUT MY
GUESS IS IT'S BROADER THAN THE
UTILITY OF THIS PLATFORM IS
BROADER JUST CLIMATE CHANGE. CAN
YOU MAYBE SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TOO
- THE- THE BIOSENSOR PROGRAM
WHICH IS- NATIONAL PROGRAM IT'S
GREAT THAT WOULD BE JOINING THIS
AND I UNDERSTAND- AS PART OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE ARE GOING TO-
AT LEAST- WE'RE GONNA HELP
SUPPORT FEES FOR SO I ASSUME ALL
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SINCE
IT JUST FOURTEEN OUT OF- THAT
SAID FORTY SIX OUT THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA HIT
THE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY-
PURCHASERS PARTICIPATING IN THIS
AS WELL AS I GUESS- YOU HAVE
OTHER FACILITIES WHILE URGING
KERR'S OTHER FACILITIES- CAN YOU
SPEAK TO. THE CAPACITY OF A
BIOSENSOR I KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT ITS ROLE CERTAINLY AN
INCLINE AND HEALTH BUT IN TERMS
OF OTHER TYPES OF- SO WHAT
CAPACITY DOES. PROTESTING ABOUT
CENTS PROVIDES STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YEAH AND I MAY TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE DANA MOORE FROM
THE CENTER OF HEALTH. STATISTICS
AND INFORMATION TO TALK MORE
BROADLY FROM A DATA STANDPOINT
ABOUT THE MULTIPLE USE CASES AS-
THIS PROPOSAL FOCUSED A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON THAT. CLIMENT
ASPECTS OF INDIAN PORTENTS OF
HAVING REAL TIME INFORMATION-
CERTAINLY IT'S USED AS PART OF A
COMMUNITY OF PRACTICE AS MISS
PATRICK MENTIONED. I'M AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL TO PICK UP A
VARIETY OF TRENDS SO WITH THE
PANDEMIC WHEN WE SEE SOMETHING
THAT'S A NEW INFLUENZA LIKE
ILLNESS- THAT SEVEN OF
TREMENDOUS INTEREST OBVIOUSLY TO
BE ABLE TO. QUICKLY PICK UP NEW
THREATS- SYNDROME SUBSET DRUMS
IN TO BE ABLE TO SHARE DATA
ACROSS STATES TO LOOK AT TRENDS
ON TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S IN NEW
AND EMERGING THREAT BE THAT
COMMUNICABLE B. THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL- AND SO THERE ARE
MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND HEALTH
FACILITIES ACROSS THE NATION-
FORTY NINE STATES- ABOUT 71% OF
EMERGENCY TO HIDE AWAY IT WOULD
BE. IT WOULD BE THE STATE NUMBER
FIFTY THEN WE'RE THE ONLY STATE
NOT PARTICIPATING. RIGHT NOW. ON
NO NINE STATES FACING OKAY IS IT
A STATE HAS NO FIRST. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE- A FEW DOZEN
FACILITIES ACROSS EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES BUT THERE IS ONE STATE
THAT HAS ZERO FACILITIES OKAY
SO. WE ARE STILL COUNTING THE
FORTY NINE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT
FULLY YES WE ARE OKAY. SO REALLY
THE DATA SHARING CAPACITY ACROSS
COUNTY STATE AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL FOR NEW AND EMERGING
THREATS- REALLY CREATES A WIDE
VARIETY OF USE CASES SOME IT CAN
BE USED FOR. OPIOIDS IT COULD BE
USED FOR PESTICIDES-
ENVIRONMENTAL AND COMMUNICABLE
BUT I'LL PASS IT TODAY ANYMORE
TO SHARE A LITTLE MORE AND THAT
AND I REALIZE. WE HAVE A LONG
AGENDA SO WE DIDN'T EVEN VERY
BRIEF AND MAYBE PROVIDE SOME
MORE WRITTEN MATERIAL BUT I AM
CURIOUS AS TO YOU KNOW I MEAN OF
THE FRAME IS CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
SELECT IS A LOT MORE WE CAN DO
DISASTER RELIEF CHRONIC DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE. CETERA MAYBE YOU
CAN YEAH YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
DATA MORE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
AND INFORMATICS AND ALSO CHIEF
DATA OFFICER AND STATE REGISTRAR
- BIOSCIENCE AS ROHANI TALKED
ABOUT DOES INCLUDE CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT IT ACTUALLY INCLUDES
A WIDE VARIETY OF SYNDROMES IT
CAN BE USED INFECTIOUS DISEASE
CHRONIC DISEASE SUCH AS OPIATE
OVERDOSE WHICH IS AN ISSUE LATER
ON IN THE AGENDA- AS WELL AS
THESE HEAT RELATED ISSUES- THIS
PARTICULAR REQUEST FOR FUNDING
REALLY WOULD ONLY FOCUS ON THE
STAND SLICE OF HEAT RELATED TO-
CONDITIONS THAT COME UP IN BIO
SIDE SO IT WOULD NEED TO BE A
MUCH BROADER COLLABORATION. WITH
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
AND INFORMATICS AS A DATE A
LEADER HI AND THEN PARTNERING
ACROSS THE CENTER WITH OUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE FORCED A
SYNDROMES BUT THEY WOULD BE
LOOKING OUT AS WELL OKAY SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ABOUT IT IN THE FUTURE MAYBE
IT'S NOT ME MYSELF FOR ITS
SUCCESSORS- AS WE. TALK ABOUT
OUR- I'M HEALTH DATA RIGHT. YES
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD. THANK YOU-
LET'S MOVE ON THEN. ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THAT'S ALSO WHAT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY- SO WITH THE
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY CREATING THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS SECRETARY GALLEY CO
CHAIRS THAT- INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
NOW AND DIRECTOR I DON'T OWN
SITS ON IT TO REALLY ELEVATE
THOSE FOUR PILLARS AGAIN THAT
WERE MENTIONED AND SO HOUSING
JUST LIKE MANY OF THE OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES IS
FOUNDATIONAL FOR THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. BEING
HOMELESS HAS TREMENDOUS NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON EVERY INDICATOR OF
HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND
CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE
DEDICATED STAFF TO FOCUS ON THIS
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO SUPPORT
COORDINATION FOR THE INTERAGENCY
WORKGROUP TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH INEQUITY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS- AS ESTABLISHED
UNDER ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA ANALYTICAL
SUPPORT FROM A VARIETY OF LOCAL
AND STATE PARTNERS INCLUDING US
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT. THROUGH
THEIR CONTINUOUS CARE PROGRAM
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
AND PROVIDING POLICY AND
PROGRAMMATIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE PREVENTION OF HOMELESSNESS
IN TERMS OF ITS HEALTH BENEFITS
AND COST SAVINGS SO THIS WOULD
ALLOW FOR TWO POSITIONS TO
REALLY GO DEEPER INTO
COORDINATION DATA ANALYTICS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
EFFECTIVE PARTICIPATION ON THIS
COUNCIL GREAT GREAT CONNECTING
OUR SYSTEMS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE ALZHEIMER'S
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE. AND
THAT IS WITH THE- DIRECTOR DIANA
ROSS. HI YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU MY
NAME IS DR DIANA ROSS AND I AM
THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CHRIST THESE PREVENTION IN
THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. WINDS ARE DPH IS.
HERE TO REQUEST A ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FIND
A POINT FIVE MILLION IN LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION EACH DAY OPERATIONS ARE
IN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY THREE BUT PROFESSIONAL
LANGUAGE FOR THE FUNDS TO BE
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ALLOCATE
GRANTS TO AN ADDITIONAL SIX
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE SIX LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
PARTICIPATING IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE PILOT
PROGRAM ALL OF WHICH ARE
CREATING PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR SPECIFIC
JURISDICTION THE P. H. WELL
ESTABLISH A COMPETITIVE REQUEST
FOR APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AND
THE LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
RECEIVING REFUNDS OR BREAK THE
FUNDAMENTAL PLANNING PRINCIPLE
OF ELIMINATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES COLLABORATING ACROSS
MULTIPLE SECTORS AND LEVERAGING
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE RESOURCES FOR
SUSTAINING IMPACT. WE WILL
CONTINUE USING THE HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE REP ROAD MAP THAT
OUTLINES THE AGENDA OF ACTIONS
FOR STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES AND THEIR
PARTNERS TO PROMOTE BRAIN HEALTH
A BETTER CARE FOR PEOPLE WITH
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT AND
INCREASED ATTENTION TO CARE
GIVERS AND BUILD CAPACITY. FOR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN AN
IMPORT PART PEOPLE LIKE IT WE
HAD SOME PILOTS ARE WORKING OR
WERE BUILT UPON IT THAT'S GOOD
NEWS. CONTINUING WITH THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST TO
CLARIFY SO THAT THIS IS FUNDING
THREE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND ALSO NOTE
THAT YOU HAVE A- YOU CAN GET
EVALUATION CONSULTANT TO OVER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND OVER THREE
YEARS. TO ALSO. SO- AND-
ACTUALLY THREE YEARS ALSO
OVERLAPS ON OF THE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO PUT THE
REPORT- SO IS THERE A PLAN TO.
SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
OUR LIPS OF ANALYST'S OFFICE
RESULTS OF THAT EVALUATION.
ABSOLUTELY YES ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK STICKING WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT BUT MOVING ON TO-
MARIA CHOICES AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- NUMBER THREE OPIOID
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
SURVEILLANCE. AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS OF OPIOID OVERDOSE IN
CALIFORNIA THE COMPLEX INVOLVING
OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC HAS LED TO
INCREASING OVERDOSE MORTALITY
DUE TO THE INCREASE IN SYNTHETIC
OPIOID RELATED DEATHS PRIMARILY
BUT NOT. DESPITE PROGRESS IN
REDUCING PRESCRIPTION DRUG
OVERDOSE WHILE STATE AND
NATIONAL DATA SHOW RAPIDLY
INCREASING RATES OF OVERDOSE
PRIMARILY RELATED TO FEND OFF.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS A
ONE TIME INCREASE AT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN OPIOID
SETTLEMENT PLANS TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND AWARENESS
AND OPIOID OVERDOSE RISKS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
OPTIONS. AND IMPROVE CITY PAGES
ABILITY TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
DATA. THE INCREASE INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WITH
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
THIS PROPOSAL SUPPORTS FORMATION
OF TWO NEW STRATEGIES TO PREVENT
AND RESPOND TO OVERDOSE AND
CALIFORNIA. STRATEGIES INCLUDING
THREE MEDIA AND HEALTH
COMMUNICATIONS AND AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS AND SYNDROME EXCEPT
SURVEILLANCE CAMPAIGN ONE WHAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOU
OPIOID ABUSE PREVENTION AND
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN AIMED AT
PREVENTING OPIOID AND POLY
SUBSTANCE USE BEFORE IT STARTS.
CAMPAIGN TO TWENTY POINT EIGHT
MILLION PROFESSIONAL RISK
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS TARGETING
PRIORITY AND AT RISK POPULATIONS
TO RAISE AWARENESS AND RISKS.
AND MEANS OF MITIGATING HARM
FROM THAT NOW. CAN'T PAINT THREE
NINE POINT TWO MILLION SHOULD
PROMOTE THE SHATTERPROOF ATLAS
TOOL TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
OPIOID USE DISORDER TREATMENT.
DURING THE PLANNING PROCESS WE
WOULD DEVELOP HE CAMPAIGN GOALS
TO MEASURE SUCCESS. IN ADDITION
THE BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS FOR IMPROVED
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE AND RAPID
REPORTING. THIS THREE POINT FIVE
FIRST CITY PA THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR CITY PAGE WHAT
DOCTOR ADMINISTER AND IMPLEMENT
THE BIOSENSOR PLATFORM IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALLOW FOR
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE AND
HEALTH CONDITIONS INCLUDING
OPIOID OVERDOSE. AND ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO DEVELOP A PUBLIC
FACING DASHBOARD WITH DATA
LINKAGES TO SYNDROMIC DATA
PROVIDED BY HIS BIO SENSE TO
PROVIDE ACTIONABLE DATA MORE
RAPIDLY. TO STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
DUCKWORTH. THANK YOU AND THE TO
SEE THAT WE'RE LINKING DIFFERENT
THINGS TOGETHER. GIVEN THE CAN
HOW HOW THE BIG. WITH THAT WE
HAVE EARLIER YOU KNOW- WITH- OUR
COMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC EDUCATION
COMMITTEE PARTNERSHIPS-
INITIATIVES THAT CD PH- THAT-
REQUEST THOSE BUDGET REQUESTS-
RELATED TO THE- THREE HUNDRED
MILLION SO. CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME OVERLAP
HERE WELL OVER LAST NIGHT DURING
WORK TIME. ALIGNMENT BECAUSE I
THINK- SO WHAT THE SYSTEM CAN
YOU JUST SPEAK TO- HOW THESE
EFFORTS WILL. LINE UP WITH-
BECAUSE AFTER ALL YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T WANT ONE PERSON SAYING HEY
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THAT NOW
ANOTHER PERSON TO COMMIT I'M
TIRED OF IT AND LIKE WELL OKAY
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE I'VE TALKED
TO RIGHT SO. ARE WE LOOKING AT
HOW WE COORDINATE- THIS THESE
CAMPAIGNS WITH THE OTHER
EXISTING CAMPAIGNS IN SIMILAR
NEIGHBORHOODS- AND TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT WE KNOW-
KNOWLEDGE OR BUILDING- TT DO
BOTH CORRECT ME OUT REACH
COMMUNICATIONS AND PARTNERSHIPS
. I TAKE THIS. AS DR KHAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU CAN ONLY
DIAL MAN I AM THE ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR SENATE FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF SYSTEMS ALREADY IN PLACE
WHERE WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE OFFICE OF COMMUNICATIONS
IT'LL BE LIKE OVERSEEING THAT
THAT LARGER- AND BUCKET OF
FINDING AND DEFINITELY YOU KNOW
WE LEVERAGE DIFFERENT CAMPAIGNS
THAT WE CAN WE ALSO HAVE AN
INTERNAL CD P. H. OPIOID
OVERDOSE WORKGROUP WHERE WE TALK
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT- PROGRAMS
THAT ARE WORKING IN DIFFERENT
AREAS YOU REGARDING- OVERDOSE TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT THEM DOING THE SAME THINGS
OR- OVERLAP OVERLAP BEING RATHER
THAN LEVERAGING OKAY WELL SO I
GUESS I DO I GET FROM THE MAIN
POINT IS THAT AND I REALIZE THAT
YOU THIS IS A BIT ABOUT CREATING
A MATRIX ORGANIZATION RIGHT HERE
WHERE WE'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS
TO DO COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND. EDUCATION AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH RIGHT- HERE WHAT'S A
FUN SOMEWHERE TO ABOUT THE
OPIOID OVERDOSE IN FENTANYL
FORTH. WHICH DOING OUTREACH AND
PARTNERS TO BE. RIGHT SO WE
DON'T WANT THE THAT TO BE IN A
SILO OVER HERE WHILE WE HAVE
ALSO. HAVE INITIATIVES TO. REACH
THE SAME COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE
LIVING COMMUNITY LIKE- THERE'S
THIS FROM. THAT CENTER RIGHT SO
JUST THINKING ABOUT BEING SURE
SO CERTAINLY ALL FOR THIS WE
NEED TO DO THIS. HOW WE CORD HOW
HOW HOW HOW WE LINK THESE
TOGETHER SO LIKE IF YOU HAVE
EXISTING PROGRAMS CAN BE
RELATIONSHIPS. HOW YOU LEVERAGE
THOSE AND SAID HAVING TO REBUILD
A NEW FOR THIS INITIATIVE RIGHT
OR VICE VERSA RIGHT SO. I'M JUST
HOPING THERE'S SOME THOUGHT
GIVEN TO NOT LIKE- WE'RE GONNA
CREATE A FENTANYL. OPIOID
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS IT'S IN THAT
SILO WHEN DO THESE AND YOU YOU
REALLY YOU YOU USE AFFECT THE
STATUS OF WORKS BUT IN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOODS THERE'S OTHER
THINGS GOING ON AND THEY'RE NOT
TALKING TO EACH OTHER YOU KNOW
LIKE. THIS IS ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
AND YET WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW. SO
THAT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT. CAN'T WE GET.
AGREE WITH YOU- AND WE'RE- WE
ARE. ALL READY. FOR BEHIND. THEM
KIND OF. BREAKING DOWN THOSE
SILOS AND WORKING TOGETHER
ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS BUT THE
COMMUNITY WITH THE LOCAL
HELICOPTER STATION. WITH OUR
LOCAL AN OPIOID OVERDOSE
PREVENTION COALITION SO. WE HAVE
A PRETTY ROBUST- LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY BUILT
THAT WILL JUST CONTINUE TO
LEVERAGE AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND WILL GO BACK
TO LOOK AT YOU WITH WITH THIS A
SEASON FINALE JUST THIS MAKING
SURE THAT WE DEVELOP ALL OF OUR
OUTREACH PLANS THAT WERE WE'RE
DOING ALL OF ALL OF THE NEW
MONEY THAT YOU WANT FOR ALL THAT
THAT THAT THAT WE'RE BREAKING
DOWN THE SILOS. IN ADDITION TO
SPENDING NEW MONEY OKAY ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN THE FITNESS
COUNCIL. HI DIANA ROSS AGAIN-
TEACHERS REQUESTING  ONE TIME
INCREASE OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND. THEIR
OPERATIONS TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADVISORY COUNCIL ON
PHYSICAL. FITNESS AND MENTAL
HEALTH. WELLBEING THIS INCREASE
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
LEARNING CONFERENCE OF
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. IN JUNE- SORRY IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE GOVERNOR'S
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON PHYSICAL
FITNESS AND MENTAL WELLBEING WAS
FORMED AND IS BEING LED BY THE
FIRST PARTNERED WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON ADVANCING PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
AND MENTAL WELLNESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. TO OVERSEE THE
FORMATION OF THE COUNCIL THE
HIGH LEVEL DELEGATION AND CROSS
SECTOR COMMUNITY SUPPORT COUNTER
DEVELOPMENT AND ENGAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES AS WORK OVERSEE
CONTRACTS FOR BOTH EVENT
PLANNING AND SOCIAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGNS IN PREPARATION FOR AN
ANNUAL REPORT- AT LEAST WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ALL
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. WE WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR A COUNCIL
MEETINGS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN CONFERENCE SERVED
AS WELL AS TRAINING SERVICES
THROUGH A SUBCONTRACT WITH THAT
SACRAMENTO STATE- OR FOR ALL
OTHER ACTIVITIES. AND WE WOULD
ALSO HAVE A- WE WERE ALSO
EXECUTED COMPREHENSIVE SOCIAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGN IN DESIGNATED
MEDIA MARKET I THINK COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE. AS WELL AS IDENTIFY
EVALUATION STRATEGIES TO MEASURE
CHANGE ATTITUDES IF YOU'RE-
ACTIVITY TO MEASURE. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE SOCIAL
MARKET. OKAY THANK VERY MUCH
LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEXUAL OR IN AND I X. FOR PILOT
PROJECT THIS IS FOR A. B. TEN
NINETY FOUR. ALLEGORY OF CHOICES
TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR INSTEAD OF
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT A REACHING
NINETY FOUR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY DATA
COLLECTION. SILENT TESTS SUCH AS
HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE ARE LEADING
CAUSES OF PREMATURE DATH AND
ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS OF YEARS
OF LIFE LOST DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE GBT COMMUNITY IS AT
HIGHER RISK FOR VIOLENT TEST BUT
DATA ARE LIMITED ON THIS
POPULATION WHICH LIMITS EFFORTS
TO PREVENT THESE FAST. BRIDGING
THE COLLECTING DATA. FOR A. B.
TEN NINETY FOUR OF DECEDENTS AS
CONSISTENT. IN A CONSISTENT
MANNER IS A CRITICAL STEP IN
FULLY UNDERSTANDING THE DEPTH OF
THIS PROBLEM AND GUIDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF METHODS TO
PREVENT DEATHS AMONG AMONG THE.
LGBTQ POPULATION. WHILE THE
CALIFORNIA BILINGUE DE REPORTING
SYSTEM STRUCK TO COME. THE
SEXUAL. ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY DATA IT'S ONLY
AVAILABLE WHEN IT'S PROVIDED
SOME A PRIMARY DATA SOURCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS A ONE
TIME INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE THOUSAND TOTAL
FINDING THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND
STATE OPS AND TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THOUSAND AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. TO ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER A THREE YEAR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
DATA COLLECTION PILOT PROJECT
FOR A. B. TEN NINETY FOUR. THE
PILOT PROJECT WILL BE AN ACTRESS
SIX COUNTIES TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH C. DPH FOR
TRAINING PARTNERS AND MEDICAL
EXAMINERS. ON THE IDENTIFICATION
AND COLLECTION OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER ID. DATA
IN CASES OF VIOLENT DEATHS IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFY AS
LGBTQ. WAS SELECTION OF AT LEAST
ONE COUNTY FROM EACH OF THE
NORTHERN SOUTHERN AND CENTRAL
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
CONSIDERATION OF REPRESENTATION
OF URBAN RURAL AND SUBURBAN
AREAS. WE EXPECT INCREASES WAIT
WE EXPECT TO INCREASE
PERCENTAGES OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION INFORMATION
ACCURATELY COLLECTED CLOSE
TRAINING. INCREASED KNOWLEDGE OF
COUNTY STAFF REGARDING THE
COLLECTION OF THIS DATA
INFORMATION. ON CD PHP REIMBURSE
COUNTIES FOR THE COST TO
PARTICIPATING IN TRAININGS AND
IMPLEMENTING CHANGES TO CURRENT
CORONER MEDICAL EXAMINER TOOLS
AND SYSTEMS TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THE PILOT CONTRACT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT WOULD BE REMISS
OF ME AS A THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LGBT CAUCUS TO NOT SAY THAT
THANK YOU. THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PASS BILLS THAT REQUIRE US TO
COLLECT THIS INFORMATION AND
EVEN THOUGH. THERE'S A LOT OF
OFTENTIMES REQUIREMENTS IT'S
STILL NOT DONE AND SO I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THIS- THIS ONE IS
BEING DONE TO. TO IDENTIFY
PEOPLE AFTER THEY HAVE DIED SO-
VERY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE LEVEL
OF VIOLENCE AND SUICIDE
OCCURRING IN LGBTQ POPULATION.
BUT AGAIN ALSO AND SOME OF THE
EARLIER AREAS WE TALKED ABOUT TO
BE ABLE TO BE MORE- PREDICTABLE
SURVEILLANCE- AND SO HOPEFULLY
WE CAN- INTEGRATE THE CHARGE
SHEET INFORMATION AND SOME OF
THOSE EARLIER. FACTORS AS WELL.
DR THANK YOU AND I DO RECENTLY-
THE WORKED ON HIM BUT I THINK
IT'S THE CHAIRS MENTIONED WE'VE
HAD A CHRONIC. CHRONIC PROBLEM
IS EVEN UNDERSTATEMENT. A REALLY
SEVERE PROBLEM WHERE- WE DON'T
HAVE DATA ON THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEING COLLECTED
AND I'LL SAY THAT PART OF THE
FAULT OF MY OWN PROFESSION RIGHT
WE THOUGHT THE DEATH
CERTIFICATES AND- AND- IT'S NOT
ALWAYS EASY TO ASK THAT
QUESTION- AND SO. IT DOESN'T GET
ASKED SO NOTHING GETS ENTERED SO
I DO APPRECIATE THAT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO. REACH OUT TO THE CORNERS
MEDICAL EXAMINERS AND. DO YOU
KNOW HOW YOU GET THERE YOU'LL BE
MONITORING TO THE RATE OF DATA
COLLECTION I MEAN THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE INVITE SO IF IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT ONCE ASKING A QUESTION
IT DOESN'T GET INTO THE
DATABASE. SO DO YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT THE STRATEGIES ARE TWO.
INCH TO RAISE THE- THE RATE OF
DATA COLLECTION OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT FIELD- THAT- IS THE
PERSONALITY OR THE WHAT THE
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY IS SO THAT- YOU KNOW SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. BLANK BOXES
NATIONAL THESE FIELDS RIGHT AND
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT THE PILOTS
ALL ABOUT. MAKING SPEAK MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE SPECIFICALLY AS TO
AND I GOT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
STAFF AND SO FORTH- ARE YOU ARE
YOU WILL BE REPORTING BACK FOR
EXAMPLE THIS YOU KNOW OF ALL THE
DEATHS. THIS IS A PERCENTAGE
THAT NEVER. HAD IT SO YOU KNOW
IN. THE GENERATE AND OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION FILLED OUT ON THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE FIELD. YES WE
DO PLAN TO REPORT DATA TO THE
BOARD O SUPERVISORS- FOR EACH
YEAR OF THE PILOT PROGRAM SO WE
WILL BE REPORTING THAT
INFORMATION THEY SAID OKAY TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- WHAT
ABOUT TWO OTHER ENTITIES THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MAY OR MAY
NOT MAKE THAT A PRIORITY FOR
THEM SO AND I GET THIS A PILOT
THE ONES WHO PARTICIPATE BUT
HOPEFULLY ARE TAKING THIS. TIME
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT LIKE HOW DO
WE BUILD THIS MOMENTUM. TO BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE COLLECTING
IT AND ALSO EDUCATING DOWN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY ANYONE WHO
FILLS OUT THERE'S A DEATH
CERTIFICATE SHOULD BE ASKING A
QUESTION HOW TO EDUCATE THEM TO
ASK THE QUESTIONS. A GREAT YES.
YOU DO HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THIS ONE- I CAN ADD. VALUE DOWN
AGAIN S. ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES. I THINK I'M JUST
YOU KNOW WITH WITH ANY
SURVEILLANCE THAT WE DO YOU KNOW
WE ALREADY NOW HAVE YOU KNOW
SOME BASELINE INFORMATION OF
WHAT'S NOT BEING REPORTED SO WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK. AT YOU KNOW
WHAT- WHAT'S NOT BEING RECORDED
YOU KNOW WHAT BOXES AREN'T BEING
CHECKED. AND THEN FOR THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SEE LIKE. YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING DACA
UPON IS. IS WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW
MANY ARE NOW REPORTING RIGHT
AFTER THIS PILE AFTER WEEK
PROVIDED THE TRAINING AFTER
WE'VE- YOU KNOW WORK WITH
COUNTIES AFTER WE'VE INFORMED
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. AND SO I
THINK AT THE END YOU KNOW ONCE
WE'VE DONE ALL THE SURVEILLANCE
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM AND HAVE
THIS EVALUATION AND ALL OF THIS
DATA. WE CERTAINLY WOULD
DEFINITELY- CREATE RECORD OUT
AND YOU KNOW. THEN THAT CAN
INFORM OUR POLICYMAKERS THAT CAN
INFORM OUR PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT THE MORE EXTREME
PREVENTION IT CAN HOPEFULLY
PURPLE IT CAN HOPEFULLY INFORMER
ACTUALLY PREVENTION EFFORTS SO.
THAT'S DEFINITELY A PART OF YOU
KNOW WHAT GOES INTO ALL OF. OUR
SURVEILLANCE EFFORTS. NOT JUST
COLLECTING BUT NOT I. THAT I
HOPE YOU THE BORDER SUPER. THIS
SURE THE ALSO REPORT THAT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THEN I'M
ALSO GONNA SAY SINCE I WILL BE
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHEN THIS IS
DONE BUT I WILL STILL BE A
MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
I HOPE YOU WILL REPORT THIS BACK
TO THE MEDICAL PROFESSION THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE
NEED TO NOW WE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
WE FAILED AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO FIX THAT AND YOU GOTTA FIGURE
THIS OUT THIS PILOT. SO THAT'S
ONE HOPING THAT YOU'LL ALSO COME
BACK TO MEDICAL TO ME SAID HEY
WE HAVE SOME IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO SHARE WITH YOU.
ABOUT THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO
BETTER SO WE CAN DO OUR JOBS IN
THAT YOU CAN ALSO DO YOUR JOBS
BETTER SO I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF AN ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN AIR QUALITY A. B. SIX
NINETEEN. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT AB
SIX ONE NINE AIR QUALITY THE
FREQUENCY SEVERITY AND DURATION
OF WILDFIRE SMOKE EVENTS HAVE
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA EXPOSING MILLIONS TO
DANGEROUSLY UNHEALTHY AIR. THIS
REQUEST WOULD GIVE CITY PH THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS THAT EIGHTY SIX
ONE NINE AND ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR CONSOLIDATED GUIDANCE ON
PROTECTIVE HEALTH MEASURES THAT
SHOULD BE TAKEN IN THE CASE OF
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY EVENTS
CAUSED BY WILDFIRES OR OTHER
SOURCES. THE GOVERNOR'S BADGER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REFLECTS
AN INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND IN GENERAL
FIND STATE OPERATIONS THE
INCREASE SUPPORTS THREE
POSITIONS TO CREATE AND MAINTAIN
AN AIR QUALITY PLAN AS MANDATED
BY EIGHTY SIX ONE NINE THE
FINDING IS ONGOING. CITY PH WILL
CREATE AN AUTHORITATIVE AND
UPDATED AIR QUALITY HEALTH PLAN
AND CONSOLIDATED GUIDANCE
IDENTIFY CURRENT INFORMATION
SURROUNDING SMOKE EXPOSURE AND
HUMAN HEALTH AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
COUNTY LEVEL INFORMATION ON
RESOURCE THIS RESOURCE SHORTAGES
AND NEEDS. ANALYZE COUNTY DATA
RESOURCE NEEDS AND ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRE SMOKE ON
POPULATION HEALTH SHE- WILL
PERFORM IN CONSOLE AND- ON OUR
REGION MATERIALS DEVELOPMENT
RELATED TO COMMUNICATION
REGARDING HEALTH. PROTECTION
DURING BONFIRE ADVANCE. DEVELOPS
BEST. FOR RESTAURANT PROTECTION
AND OTHER PROTECTIVE MEASURES
THAT PROVIDE CONSULTATION ON
RISK ASSESSMENT SELECTION AND
USE OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND- OTHER EXPOSURE
REDUCTION MEASURES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU.
WELL RICHARD ONLY I'M A DIVISION
CHIEF FOR THE TONIGHT THE
TRAINING PROGRAM THANKS TO THE
CHAIR AND TO THE SENATOR.
KENNEDY STUDIO SPEED BUDGET
SUPPORTS ACTIVITIES OF TWO MAJOR
PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR SENSES
THESE TESTING FUN. YOU WEREN'T
SCREENING AND PRENATAL SCREENING
ALSO KNOWN AS MBS YEAH. MINUTES
AGO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INSPECTED BY TRANSMITTING A LIVE
BIRTH WHICH OF DECREASED
RECENTLY SIGNIFICANTLY. AND ARE
PROJECTED TO STAY BELOW AVERAGE
FOR THE PAST DECADE. OKAY FOR
BOTH AMBIENCE YEAH THAT'S
EXPENDITURES AND REVENUES WHAT'S
ALL THAT TOGETHER. IN A
UTILIZATION BASED ON REVENUE BUT
ALSO INCREASE SCREENING TRAVELS
AWAY FROM BIOCHEMICAL SCREENING
. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S CHANGING
MORE THAN. SEVENTY MMHM TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BECAUSE OF.
YESTERDAY'S SCREENING
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WAS FUNDED
IN THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AFTER
ANYTHING IN ANY OF THE PRO. I
HAVE READ YOUR WORK OUTFIT TO
DENY US ALL FOR THE DNA. I MEAN
ALSO KNOWN AS NON INVASIVE
PRENATAL SPRINGER AND I. T. T.
AS A MUCH BETTER DETECTION RATE
AND ACCURACY GIVEN OUR CURRENT
BIOCHEMICAL SCREENING PROGRAM.
REALLY THE NEW STANDARD OF CARE
FOR MANY FOR DOWN SYNDROME
TRISOMY THIRTEEN. R. E. N. S.
PROGRAM OF THE VOLUNTARY BUT
STATEWIDE POPULATION BASED
PROGRAM MANDATED BY STATUTE- TO
SCREEN ACCORDING TO STANDARDS
SET BY ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS A
CAR. OKAY JENNIFER HARMAN
ALCOHOL SCREENING AVAILABLE TO
THE ENTIRE POPULATION. AND THAT
DOES INCLUDE COUNSELING DIET DR
BUT NOT TAKE SERVICES AS PART OF
A COMPREHENSIVE. SO IT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE. PREENING AND
FOLLOW UP PROGRAM- FOR
EXPENDITURE- IN THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR ARE AS DEPENDENT
CHANGED LITTLE OVERALL VERSUS
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
. HOWEVER FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE OUR ESTIMATE
REFLECTS SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE.
OF A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. ALMOST
ALL OF US TO GO TO- IT PRODUCES
A LOCAL SYSTEM. I THANK THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF- PROPER DNA
SCREENING- MAJOR SYSTEM REDESIGN
OF- CABANAS PROGRAM IN OUR-
INFORMATION SYSTEM AS- A
CHRISTIAN BECAUSE I MEAN. TO A
NEW FILE PLATFORM. WELL I DON'T
KNOW IF AND THEN WE GOT. THE
REVENUE SIDE ARE ESTIMATES FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TOTAL A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION A
DECREASE. OF ALMOST TWELVE
MILLION COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. I MERRILY
WITH THE CREASE OF THE CABINET
THE FINAL NUMBERS RIGHT- THIS IS
ALSO THE POTENTIAL NEGATIVE
EFFECT ON OUR PROJECTED ON
CONDITION WITHOUT. AND IF YOU
CHANGE THE CPO- MAKING PROCESS
SHOULD BE S. P. WILL PROPOSE A
FEE INCREASE. TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN
DOLLARS FOR NEWBORN SCREENING.
EMAIL TRAINING PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED A PROPOSED FIFTEEN OF
TWO HUNDRED POINT SIXTY FIRST
OFFERED TO DONATE ON SEVENTY
FIVE FOR BIOCHEMICAL AND SHOULD
BE SCREENING NOW PROPOSING
INCREASES TO GO TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS FOR BEAUFORT
AND I. AM EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS
FOR THE SCREENING. THING HAPPENS
A LOT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
CHANGE ARE TO THE FOURTH OF
OCTOBER. DUE TO PRESERVE LIFE
FOR- BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE
DEMONSTRATION BECAUSE BOTH OF
THEM WITH A CLOUD MIGRATION IN
OUR IN OUR SYSTEM THE DESIGN. ON
THE OTHER INCREASED EXPENDITURE
. BOTH OF THE FIFTY CHANGES AND
RESTRUCTURING WE PROJECT
REVENUES FROM TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE WILL TOTAL A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION BUDGET
INCREASE OF THIRTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. BUDGET ACT. WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL QUESTION AND- IF I
BURST IN GARB WE HAVE A BIG BONE
WHAT WE DECREASE THE COST CENTER
. WELL OUR OUR OUR EXPENDITURES
WILL ALSO INCREASE AT THE SAME
TIME BUT WE'LL TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THAT- IF WE DO HAVE A
TWO BEDROOM. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
NOT A BIT WELL THE
UNDERSTANDABLE CERTAIN FIXED
COSTS RIGHT SO THE BIRTH RATE
GOES DOWN THE STREET FOR THE
FIXED COSTS AND RAISE THE PER
UNIT COSTS SO THE PER UNIT
BECAUSE WE DID HAVE A BIG BOOM
THEN THE PER UNIT COST WOULD
DROP THE VX TOTAL EXPENDITURE GO
UP IF MORE CASES BUT THE FIXED
COSTS REMAIN THE SAME SO ANYWAY-
BUT AT LEAST I DON'T HEAR SEE
BIG BOOM COMING YET SO- BUT I
GUESS THE I GUESS THE- LONG TERM
QUESTION WE DON'T EXPECT YOU TO
AN ANSWER RIGHT NOW IS THAT
THERE ARE THERE ANY
OPPORTUNITIES IF. WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE DECLINING BIRTHRATE. TO
REDUCE OUR FIXED COSTS RIGHT NOW
SO- MOTHER DOES IT. I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A CERTAIN BASIC
MEDICAL ADMIN AND SO FORTH WHAT
HOW MANY SAMPLES YOU RUN BUT I
MEAN I THINK- IT TO TRY TO
MITIGATE FUTURE FEE INCREASES
YOU KNOW. THAT THE LOOK SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER PLACE IN THE
OPERATIONS IN TERMS OF FIXED
COSTS THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREATER
EFFICIENCIES AND- NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND SO FORTH AND
WHETHER CERTAIN INVESTMENTS IN
NEW TECHNOLOGIES WITHIN. ALLOW
THE PER UNIT COST TO GO DOWN.
BUT- IT WAS DONE SO- TYLER YES
YES TWO WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN WORK
THAT INTO THE EARLY DETECTION
AND SURVEILLANCE. ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AND DEALING WITH WICK
PROGRAM ESTIMATES. CHRISTINE
SULLIVAN DIVISION CHIEF. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THERE IS NO
GENERAL COMMENT OR WITH
CASTANEDA AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE ENOUGH FEDERAL FUNDS TO
COVER OUR LOCAL SERVICES AND
STATE OPERATIONS EXPENDITURES
SHE SAYS TWO MEN INCLUDES
DECREASES AND THE CURRENT AND
BUDGET YEAR THERE WAS A SLIGHT
DECREASE IN THE ACTUAL COST PER
PARTICIPANT IN THE PRIOR YEAR
WHICH IMPACTS OUR PROJECTIONS
FOR CURRENT AND BUDGET YEAR.
MUCH OF THE DECREASE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IS BEING OFFSET BY
THE INCREASE IN VEGETABLE
BENEFITS WHICH BEGAN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND CONTINUES THROUGH
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO SH
BASKETBALL INCREASED MAY
CONTINUE PAST MARCH ACROSS THE
NATIONAL BUDGET IN THE COMING
WEEKS. IN ADDITION THE ESTIMATE
REFLECTS A SLIGHT DECREASE IN
PROTECTED PARTICIPATION BUT WE
ARE STILL MUCH HIGHER. THAN PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS. I MONDAY AND
THIS WEEK U. S. A. ITS LATEST
THREE ON THE WORK. REACHED
YOU'RE QUITE HAS PERFECT TIMING.
THE LATEST REPORT IS. LOOKING AT
TWENTY NINETEEN DATA. THE
NATIONAL WEATHER COVERAGE RATE
WAS 50% 57% OF THE ELIGIBLE
POPULATION LOOKING AT TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
RATE WAS 69% UP FROM 67% IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OUR CONTEXT
TEXAS WHO HAS A CASELOAD OF
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA SIZE. FLORIDA HAS A
CASELOAD OF ABOUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA BOTH HAVE RAISED A
57% FOR YEARS OFTEN THE STATES
WITH THE HIGHEST COVERAGE RATE
SOMETIMES ALTERNATING WITH
VERMONT WHOSECASELOAD IS ABOUT
1% OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD THANK YOU
GLAD TO KNOW THAT WE WERE
GETTING UNDER DOCTOR FELT THE DA
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE LEADER IN THE COUNTRY IN
TERMS OF. GETTING ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE AND HELP. YOU PROJECTING
A DECREASE BUT- WELL IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE JUST DONE TUESDAY
WE HEARD FROM CAL WORKS AND WE
HEARD FROM CALFRESH THAT THEY'RE
EXPECTING AN INCREASE- AND SOME
OF THAT'S DUE TO PERHAPS YOU
KNOW THE UNEMPLOYMENT SUBSIDIES
GO GOING AWAY IN THE FALL AND
THEN OF COURSE THE- CHILD TAX
CREDIT FEDERAL CHILD TAX CREDIT
ENDED. AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
SO- SO GIVE IT THAT SO. I'M JUST
SORT OF THE LIKE OKAY- SIMILAR
POPULATIONS ALL THAT SOME
DIFFERENCES- WELL HOW DO YOU
COME OF THE DECREASE WHEN
PROGRAMS LIKECALFRESH AND- CAL
WORKS ARE ACTUALLY PREDICTING AN
INCREASE. IN CASE LAWS. SO OUR
OUR OUR PROJECTION AND DECREASES
THE VERY SMALL DECREASE YES AND
ALSO KEEP IN MIND THAT INSTEAD.
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE WERE SERVING
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND. INDIVIDUALS EACH.
MONTH AND WE'RE UP TOWARDS OF
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND NOW SO WE DID. HAVE
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY MANY WEAK STATE AND I
BELIEVE OTHER PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA SHE DID START TO SEE
A DROP OFF IN THEIR
PARTICIPATION AFTER THAT
INITIAL. PANDEMIC INCREASED AND
WE DID NOT WE MAINTAIN THE SAME
LEVELS WITH JUST. MINOR
DECREASES OUT. BUT I SO I THINK
THAT THAT MADE PLAY A ROLE IN
THAT WE'VE ALREADY BEEN AT THIS
MUCH HIGHER LEVELS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. HE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE
THAT DEBATE THAT THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
STAYING AT HOME THEY'RE FORMED
ROLLING AND SO FORTH OKAY WELL
YOU KNOW WHAT MY KEEP AN EYE ON
THAT I APPRECIATE AND I'M SURE
YOU KNOW THE DETAILS MUCH MORE
THAN I DO. BUT I YOU KNOW I JUST
SEE THOSE NUMBERS I GO OKAY WILL
IT WORK OR MIGHT BE DOWN TO I'M
SURE WE HAVE THE DISCONNECT
YOURSELF. THE PREVIOUS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN. THANK YOU- CELL ARE
EVEN BUDGET WAS NCLUDED IN IT
WE ARE REQUESTING TWENTY FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO CONTINUE
SUPPORT FOR WEEKS NEWLY
IMPLEMENTED SYSTEMS THERE IS NO
REQUEST FOR STATE GENERAL SIGNED
THESE POSITIONS WOULD BE FUNDED
BY OUR EXISTING FEDERAL WITH
GRANTS WITH THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW YORK
SYSTEMS INCLUDING THE NEW WEIGHT
CARD AT ITS CAMP COMPANION THE
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT. THE NEED FOR
CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR WITH
FAMILIES AND LOCAL AGENCY STAFF
HAS INCREASED IN ADDITION IT
WORKS SYSTEMS WILL REQUIRE
REGULAR UPDATES AND CONTINUOUS
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
VARIOUS TECHNOLOGY AND SERVICES
WITH THESE PERMANENT POSITIONS
OUR RELIANCE ON TEMPORARY
CONTRACTORS. WILL DECREASE AS
WELL. IN ADDITION TO EXPANDING
SERVICE THE OFFER IS OF NEW.
WILL ENABLE US TO EXPAND THE USE
OF BASS QUANTITIES OF NEW DATA
TO ANALYZE AND IDENTIFY TRENDS
AND ANOMALIES AND TO TARGET
THOSE IN NEED OF SERVICES. TO
IMPROVE THE WICK FAMILY
EXPERIENCE AND TO ENHANCE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY BY PREVENTING
DETECTING AND RESPONDING TO
FRAUDULENT OR ABUSIVE
ACTIVITIES. IN ADDITION TO THESE
CONCESSIONS AWAKE IS ALSO RE
DIRECTING INTERNAL VACANCIES AND
TO SUPPORT ONGOING. POST
IMPLEMENTATION WORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY NOW MOVING ON
FROM FOOD TO MY NEXT FAVORITE
TOPIC- BOOKS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
BOOKS FOR LOW INCOME CHILDREN.
THANK YOU. CDPH IS REQUESTING
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FINDING A WEEK WILL BE
PARTNERING WITH STATE AND COUNTY
FIRST FIVE COMMISSIONS TO
COORDINATE A BOOK DISTRIBUTION.
ARE LOADING CHILD LITERACY IS AN
APARTMENT AT HER AND LEVERAGING
EXISTING BUT FOR TO REACH
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES
IN A PLACE THAT IS FAMILIAR IS
IT IS A PROVEN SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGY BOTH NATIONALLY AND
CALIFORNIA. UTILIZING THE WEB
FORM IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO
INTRODUCE FAMILIES MANY OF WHOM-ARE NEW TO THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR COUNTRY TWO IMPORTANT EARLY
LITERACY PRACTICES BOOKS AND
RESOURCES. OF THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STATE OPERATIONS IS
NECESSARY FOR STAFFING COSTS.
FOR PROGRAM EVALUATION AND
PROCUREMENT ASSISTANCE AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THE LOCAL
AGENCIES WILL USE EXISTING WORK
POSITIONS BUT CANNOT CHARGE THIS
WORK WORK TO THE FEDERAL WAY
CRAMPED. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT WHICH WAS
AUTHORIZED ONE TIME FINDING A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SAME
TYPE OF EARLY LITERACY PROGRAM.
AND THIS NEW FUNDING WILL ALLOW
WORK TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM AND
EXPAND IT TO ALL OF ITS CHILDREN
PARTICIPANTS AND PROVIDE
MULTILINGUAL OPTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WOULD
KNOW. MS PEDIG UP PREVIOUS- ADD
CAUTION ABOUT USING ONE TO.
FUNDS BUT WE ALL AGREE UP WITH
THE URGENCY OF THIS PROGRAM TO
EXPAND. THANK YOU DEGREE PROGRAM
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN REACH OUT RE WHICH
IS SORT OF PEDIATRIC CLEVELAND
IF THEY COULD QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT- IS THIS ONLY AUTHORIZED
FOR TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SO SOME OF THE OTHER EYE ONE
TIME ITEMS WERE ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW THE CUPBOARD WHERE FOR
THREE YEARS SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY. AT LEAST IN OUR
ANALYSIS HERE. IT'S A GROUP THAT
HAS TO BE ALL SPENT BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY BY THE END OF.
THE FISCAL YEAR. SEP CORRECT. I
BELIEVE THERE IS LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE SECOND YEAR FOR
EXPANDING BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
CHECK WITH OUR TECHNICAL PEOPLE
FINANCE NO RIGHT NOW OR NOT-
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN AND-
MEMBERS SIGNALS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN CONFIRM THAT THERE
IS A MULTI YEAR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. OKAY SO THE
ALL RIGHT IT JUST WASN'T WRITTEN
INTO OUR HOUSES AND OKAY SOUNDS
LIKE EVERYTHING'S TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE BUT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER. TWENTY ONE DIANE
LINDSEY DIVISION CHIEF UNDER
MATERNAL CARE SERVICES TO
IMPLEMENT SB SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ROMEO I'M YOUNG
ASSISTANT DIVISION CHIEF OF
MATERNAL CHILD AD ADOLESCENT
HEALTH SITTING IN FOR VANDALISM
AND THEN SHE HAS SHE CAN PRESENT
TODAY. SB SIXTY FIVE WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST YEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR AND REQUIRE CD PH
TRIBUNE REQUIRED ON ALL MATERNAL
DEATHS. THIS NEVER CARMEL
INCREASED THREE FOLD THE NUMBER
OF MATERNAL MORTALITY REVIEWS
BEING CONDUCTED ANNUALLY. AS
WELL AS ADD ADDITIONAL
COMPONENTS OF UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY AND WE CONDUCT. INTERVIEWS
CONDUCTED ANNUAL. CDPH WILL ALSO
BE REQUIRED TO REVIEW SEVEN
THOUSAND CASES OF SEVERE
MATERNAL MORBIDITY THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE NOT CURRENTLY
DOING TODAY. TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB SIXTY FIVE
SIGNATURE QUESTIONER ON
EXPENDITURE ALREADY UP FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SIXTEEN POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. CAN I ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU- NO I THINK- I
KNOW FOR SURE THAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT WE GET THIS DATA
IS AND- AND UNTIL YOU'LL BE
ACTUALLY. REVIEWING EVERY EVERY-
EVERY CASE MATERNAL MORE OF
MORTALITY CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT YES ALL RIGHT. EXCELLENT
AND I GUESS YOU PRY PROVIDE
FEEDBACK BECAUSE IT'S YOUR
INVESTIGATING SOMETIMES YOU FIND
OUT SOME YOU KNOW WHETHER YOU
KNOW IT IT JUST ISN'T
APPROPRIATE SENTENCE STILL
SYSTEMATIC DATA COLLECTION I
BELIEVE THAT AS A CHILD DEATH
REVIEW TEAMS AS WELL SO. YES
OKAY THAT IS CORRECT YES
EXCELLENT RIGHT. JOHNNY MITCHELL
YEAH SORRY. I'M NOT THERE TO BE
DIRECTOR OF FAMILY HEALTH THANK
YOU FOR AN OPPORTUNITY JUST TO
CLARIFY THE RESPONSE TO- TO-
DOCTOR PRAGUE THE SENATOR COM
AND THAT IS THAT- WE WILL BE
ABLE WE WILL BE. ABLE TO THROW
OUR SURVEILLANCE PROCESS THESE-
DOOR REALLY GOOD JOB AT
IDENTIFYING ALL OF THE CASES-
THAT ARE DUST DURING THE TIME OF
PREGNANCY OR WITHIN ONE YEAR
PREGNANCY- WATCH- THE WE WILL BE
ABLE WE'LL BE DOING DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF IN DEPTH INVESTIGATION
FOR EACH OF THESE I DON'T WANT
TO IMPLY THAT EVERYTHING IS
TREATED ALL THE SAME OKAY
BECAUSE CERTAINLY YOU CAN
IMAGINE BUT PROCESS SEES FOR
LOOKING AT EVERY CASE OF SAY-
HOMICIDE DURING PREGNANCY MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. THAT
RIGHT LOOKING AT SAY A DOCTOR
THE PREECLAMPSIA DURING
PREGNANCY SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT. AND YOUR BUT YOUR
COMMENT WHAT IS THAT WE'RE NOT
LEAVE LEADING YOU ASTRAY NOW
BELIEVE THAT EVERY CASE GETS THE
SAME LEVEL OF SCRUTINY BUT WE
WELL. WE HAVE SOME REALLY
EXCELLENT METHODS FOR CASE
IDENTIFICATION IDENTIFYING
BECAUSE OF DOUBTS AND FORGETTING
SOMETHING SOMEONE NEXT LAYERS
AROUND POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PREVENTION. THE
CLARIFICATION THAT CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND RIGHT SOMETHINGS ARE
LITTLE MORE OBVIOUS THAN OTHERS-
AND- BUT ALSO DOING SOME INITIAL
INVESTIGATION BE SURE NOT LED
ASTRAY BUT YES OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THEN WE MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
ADJUSTMENT TO SUPPORT HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS AT TO. VISIT
YOU AGAIN MR. EXPANSION THANK.
SEEPAGE REQUESTS NINETEEN POINT
SEVEN COMPOSITIONS AND HIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING TO EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITING PROGRAM OR C. H.
REPEAT. SIX PP CURRENTLY SERVES
ABOUT THREE OUT OF. THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED FAMILIES ANNUALLY. THIS
FUNDING WILL ALLOW US BY YOUR
FIGHT TO SERVE AN ADDITIONAL%
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED ALL FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES. AS WELL
INCREASING OUR REACH BEYOND THE
TWENTY NINE COUNTIES WE CURLED
SIR. ABOUT 80% OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS ARE ENROLLED IN
MEDICARE. HOME VISITING HAS
DECADES OF RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATING THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR UP TO FIVE
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON SERVICES.
SIX PP HAS GRADUALLY EXPANDING
TO MORE COUNTIES AND RECENTLY
ADDED A THIRD MODEL FOR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES TO CHOOSE
FROM. IF APPROVED WE WILL
CONTINUE TO USE THE THREE
EVIDENCE ASED MODELS HEALTHY
FAMILIES AMERICA NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP AND PARENTS AS
TEACHERS. AND THESE MODELS ALLOW
IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES TO CHOOSE
FROM. HIGH QUALITY OPTIONS IN
SERVING CALIFORNIA PEPPERS CAN.
CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU
. DO WE KNOW OF IT JUST AS FAR
AS EVALUATION GOES DO WE KNOW
WITH THESE PROGRAMS- LIKE.
YOU'RE OUT IN PEOPLE'S HOMES DID
IN POPULATIONS THAT WE KNOW ARE
AT RISK- CAN YOU TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE OUTCOMES REALLY KNEW THAT
AND ALSO WELCOMES AS IT RELATES
TO. APT VACCINATION RATES.
HASN'T BEEN EFFECTIVE AS A AS A
TOOL TO GET OUT WITH PEOPLE. I'M
CONNIE I DON'T HAVE THAT AND MY
FINGER TIPS YOU CAN ASSIST. I
YES I THINK. I GET CONTINENTAL
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH. WE HAVE BEEN VERY
DILIGENT IT EMPLOYS EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS FOR WHICH THEY'VE
BEEN HIGHLY SCRUTINIZED SO THAT
IF YOU IMPLEMENT THESE MODELS AS
INTENDED YOU WILL HAVE IT SHOWS
THAT YOU SHOULD ACHIEVE THE
OUTCOMES THAT HAVE BEEN
PREDICTED AND SO- THOSE WOULD
BE- INCREASED PRESCHOOL READY
NOW. YOU'RE REDUCED EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS THAT WE DO
HAVE ALL WE DO KNOW WHAT THOSE
OUTCOMES ARE THAT WE HAD SHE
HOPED TO ACHIEVE- I'M NOT AS FAR
AS IMMUNIZATIONS. I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
DATA POINTS THAT WE TRACK
THROUGH HOME VISITING I CAN WE
CAN LOOK INTO THAT AND GET BACK
TO YOU. THEY'RE JUST AGAIN JUST
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WORK
SMARTER WE'RE OUT WITH PEOPLE
THIS IS NOT THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO DO
JUSTICE MORE THAN IS ALREADY ON
THE ON THE DAY THAT YOUR CURRENT
CLEARS A LOT OF HEALTH EDUCATION
THAT IT'S PROBABLY THERE I JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA AT MY
FINGERTIPS. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU MANAGER CDPH IS REQUESTING
SEVEN POINT TWO FIVE POSITIONS
AND TWELVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND ON GOING.
TO FURTHER EXPAND THE BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM OR B. I.
H. H. SERVICE PREGNANT AND
PARENTING BLACK BURNING PEOPLE
AND FOCUSES ON SOCIAL FACTORS
INFLUENCE MATERNAL AND INFANT.
HEALTH AND CAPACITY BUILDING.
ACROSS THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTS A
GROUP BASED CURRICULUM THAT
EMPHASIZES EMPOWERMENT- SOCIAL
SUPPORT STRESS REDUCTION IN
STRESS MANAGEMENT. CURRENTLY IN
VARIOUS PROGRAMS ARE ESTABLISHED
IN THIRTEEN COUNTIES WERE
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF BLACK
BERSERKER SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN HM SIR MANY FOUR HUNDRED
BLACK PERSON PEOPLE THIS ONE
ALLOW US TO EXPAND ANNUAL
PARTICIPATION FROM. ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THREE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PARTICIPANTS. WE WILL EXPAND
INTO AREAS NOT CURRENTLY BEING
SERVED AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO EXISTING THIRTEEN
COUNTIES TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS BASER. CAN I ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU ON THIS
ONE. BUT CAN. I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE- EXPANSION
PROGRAM THE THINGS WE'RE
LEARNING FROM THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS IN OUR HOUSES IT
INDICATES FOR EXAMPLE WE
LEARNED- IN THE PAST THAT- WE
START WITH A ONE ON ONE AND- WE
KNEW THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY WHEN
YOU. GIVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR- FOR
WOMEN TO CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER
ACTUALLY THAT WAS MORE EFFECTIVE
THAN ONE ON ONE ISN'T ALWAYS THE
BEST WAY ALONE- AND OTHERS AND
CERTAINLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ELLERY KNOWLEDGE THAT- WE
WERE ABLE TO GET SOME REALLY-
SIX. SOME SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS IN
REDUCING THE- THE RATE BUT
THERE'S THE DISPARITY STILL
CONTINUES AND THAT'S THAT'S
CERTAINLY BEEN FRUSTRATING RIGHT
THE DISPARITY STILL CONTINUES
SO. THEY REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK WE WANT TO GET MOR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SO IN
TERMS OF SIZE. LIST YOU KNOW
WHAT. TO DO OTHER THINGS WERE
DEFINING RELAYED THAT LEAD TO
SUCCESS IN TERMS OF REDUCING.
YOU KNOW WHAT. BOTH THE INTENT
AND- MATERNAL MATERNAL
MORTALITY. AND AND- HOPEFULLY. I
DON'T KNOW IF. I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN DOING EVALUATIONS IT'S A-
HOW I GUESS. ARE YOU- WHAT WE
DOING ON ON GOING BASIS TO TRY
TO CAPTURE MORE OF THE
INFORMATION YOU HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN GET IN TERMS OF TRYING AGAIN
ALERT TRYING TO LIMIT THAT.
TERRIBLE DISPARITY THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND THEN BLACK INFANT
HEALTH. BLACK INFANT MORTALITY
MORBIDITY. I THINK THAT REALLY
HELPED. YES HI THANK YOU. NO
PROBLEM- ROMEO DIDN'T SLL IT AT
THE LAST MINUTE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HIM DOING THAT YES- I
WE SPOKE JUST A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER ABOUT OUR MATERNAL
MORTALITY INVESTIGATION EFFORTS
AND WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN.
COLLEGE NATIONWIDE ARE ARE-
ABILITY TO. REDUCE OUR MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE STOP WE ARE ALL
LOWER THAN THE REST OF THE
NATION. HE CONSISTENTLY WE DO
HAVE A PERSISTENT DISPARITY-
BETWEEN. BLACK AND WHITE
BURSTING PEOPLE AND THAT
DISPARITY- WE DISCOVERED THROUGH
OUR INVESTIGATION. I'M ACTUALLY
WIDENED WHEN YOU WHEN YOU EXPAND
YOUR SCOPE FROM LOOKING OUT ARE
JUST DUST UP TO FORTY THREE DAYS
POSTPARTUM TO DOUSE TO ONE YEAR
WE FOUND THAT ACTUALLY THE
DISPARITY WIDENS. THAT WAS OUR
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN DATE OUT.
AND SO THAT'S WHEN WE REALLY
STARTED TO RAMP UP AND THANKS TO
ALL OF OUR EFFORTS- ACROSS
STAKEHOLDERS LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS THE SUPPORT- THE
GOVERNOR IN YOURSELVES- WE
IMPLEMENTED. AND EXPANDED OUR
EFFORTS AROUND THIS THE BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE PERINATAL EQUITY INITIATIVE
. AND A LOT OF WORK AROUND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH JUSTICE OUR
LATEST DATA. NOW TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AGAIN WE'RE A LITTLE
BIT YOU KNOW WE LIKE TO BE MORE
CURRENT WE'RE DOING AS FAST AS
WE CAN SHOW THAT WE HAVE
NARROWED THAT WE'RE STARTING TO
BRING THAT DOWN WE'RE STARTING
TO NARROW THAT DIFFERENCE IN
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND THAT
WE'RE MOVING YOU KNOW THAT'S A
GOOD TREND FROM SEPT. IN
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN AND WE
HOPE THAT THAT PROCESS BUT WE
HAVE TO BE REALLY HONEST AND I'M
HONEST ABOUT THIS EVERYWHERE IS
THAT THIS IS A RECALCITRANT YEAH
THAT WILL REQUIRE ON NOT ONLY
ARE AND IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS ACROSS THE SPECTRUM TO
ADDRESS ON A LOT OF I'M DOING TO
TERMS OF. SOCIAL POLICIES THAT
MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO- WE'RE
WORKING ON IT WE WERE STARTING
TO SEE SOME PROGRESS IN IN TERMS
OF VALUATION WE'RE DOING ONGOING
EVALUATION OF THE B. H. PROGRAM
WE HAVE A LOGIC MODEL WE
IDENTIFIED SOME INTERMEDIARY
MEASURES THAT WE WANTED TO
ADDRESS THAT WE THOUGHT BASED ON
THE RESEARCH WHAT THAT LEAD TO
IMPROVED OUTCOMES. AND OUR
EVALUATION DID SHOW THAT WE WERE
ACHIEVING OUR INTERMEDIARY.
MAJOR SO WE HAVE. I INCREASED
OUR CALL. IN THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM. THIS GROUP BASED
INTERVENTION MODEL. MATED
IMPLEMENTED BY THE COMMUNITIES-
THIS IS GOING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS BUT AGAIN WE'RE NOT ALONE
IT'S GOING TO TAKE ALL OF US
DOING A LOT OF WORK TO REDUCE
THIS BUT IT IS A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR US. THANK YOU ONE DAY AND
THE ANSWER YOU YOU KNOW AND-
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT NO IT'S
NOT THAT OLD NOW WHAT WHAT ELSE
SOMEONE BECOMES PREGNANT. AND
EVERYTHING'S STILL TO SELL I
MEAN THERE'S CHEMO IT THERE'S A
CUMULATIVE EFFECT RIGHT SO
THINKING OF. CHRONIC STRESS
FROM. CHRONIC SPLITTER TO RACISM
AT CETERA. ADULT WHO IS EXISTING
BEFORE THEY GOT PREGNANT AND
THEN IT'S GOING TO IMPACT YOU
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS DURING
PREGNANCY AS WELL SO THAT THE
INTERVENTIONS CAN'T HAPPEN JUST
DURING PREGNANCY ARE MERELY A-
PREGNANCY. WE USE THE LIFE
COURSE FRAMEWORK RIGHT. AND THAT
WE'VE FOCUSED NOT ONLY JUST ON
RISK REDUCTION THROUGHOUT THE
LIFE COURSE BEEN RESILIENCY
PROMOTION. AND THAT IT IT TAKES
MORE THAN JUST HEALTH CARE OR
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE ALL OF THOSE CHANGES IN
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH- PROBABLY EVEN BEFORE
CONCEPTION SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S OUR FRAMEWORK. MULTI
GENERATIONAL OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S MOVE ON
TO- ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
ESTIMATE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SCOTT ABOUT
IT AND I AM AN ASSISTANT TO THE
DIRECTOR IN THE CENTER FOR
HEALTH CARE QUALITY. C. SIX
YEARS RESPONSIBLE FOR REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OF LICENSED HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES AND HEALTH ARE
PROFESSIONALS TO SERVICE THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE. OFFER
QUALITY AND SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SIX SIX YEAR FOR
FILTERS ROLE BY CONNECTING CURLY
INSPECTIONS INCOMPLETENESS
CATIONS OF HEALTH FACILITIES. TO
DETERMINE COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. C. SIX ZERO
LICENSES AND CERTIFIES OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIRTY DIFFERENT
LICENSURE. AND CERTIFICATION
CATEGORIES. C. SIX. IT'S
CONCERNS FOR WITH THE REGULAR
UNDER GRANT BUT THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE MEDICAID SERVICES FULL
SERVICE FACILITIES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAWS ND
REGULATIONS AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA SUMMARY IT SURE DOES
CONTRACT LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
SURVEY- FOR SIRI AND SEARCH I
HOPE YOUR PLACE LOCATED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. IN ADDITION TO
IN ADDITION TO- JUST MENTION
SIXTY TROOPS OVERSEAS
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS HOME HEALTH
IS ANYONE ELSE'S TECHNICIANS.
THE LICENSING OF NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATORS. THE MAJORITY OF
C. SIX YEARS ACTIVITIES ARE
SUPPORTED BY LICENSING FEES
COLLECTED FROM THE HEALTH
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
. BEFORE I GET TRUE THEY
BASICALLY PRESENTATIONS THE
COMMITTEE ASKED A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SEE SEE SEE
SECURES VACANCY RATE AND TELLING
US TO COMPLAIN ABOUT. AS OF
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TRUE
THE CURRENT VACANCY RATE WITHIN
THE ENTIRE CENTER PROCEDURE IS
FIFTEEN POINT 7% THE VACANCY
RATE- BECAUSE ASKED BY THE
COMMITTEE FOR OUR NURSING DIARY
SERIES IS FOURTEEN POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. WHICH IS AN 11%
INCREASE FROM FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC SO
WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
RETIREMENTS- AND TO MAKE AS-
KIND OF EXPERIENCE THE TURNOVER
WORKS. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THAT THIS IS THE LAST YEAR OF
MY- GET SOME POSITIONS FROM
LET'S SAY SURE COME IN SO THAT
THEY CAN SEE RATE IS. IN HER IN
THIS NEW POSITION- IN ADDITION
THE COMMITTEE ASKED ABOUT
COMPLAINTS THE RESTRICTION ON
TIMING US. AS OF QUARTER ONE OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. 61% OF LONG TERM CARE
COMPLAINTS CAN BE COMPLETED
WITHIN OUR STATUTORY SIXTY EIGHT
SIXTY DAY REQUIREMENT. WE KNOW
THAT OVER 96% OF ALL OF OUR
IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY CASES HOWEVER
ARE INITIATED. WITH THE
STATUTORY TIMELINES FOR
INITIATION. KOURNIKOVA 1972% OF
OUR LONG TERM CARE COMPLAINTS
ARE BEING COMPLETED TIMELY AND
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- THERE'S A THERE'S A
REDIRECTION OF FOCUS ON. BIDDING
TOWARDS INFECTION CONTROL
ACTIVITIES. WE WERE
INVESTIGATING IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY
COMPLAINTS AS HIGH PROFILE.
INSTANCES BUT- RESPONSIVENESS
FOR CONGRESS FUNNY TRUE COMPLETE
TYPING THIS DIDN'T DECLINE
DURING THIS PERIOD OF PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT. AFFECTED APRIL TWENTY ONE
OF. TWENTY ONE- WE WERE THINK
BACK TOWARDS AN EFFORT TO GET
INTO OUR BACKLOG GENTRY'S
THROUGH- WHOLESALE
INVESTIGATIONS OF OUR COMPLAINT
TO SCHEDULE AN INTEGRAL ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR BACKLOG.
WHAT'S YOUR MAJOR COMPLAINTS HAS
. IT'S BASICALLY 7% SO WE'RE
PRETTY EXCITED THAT WE'RE
FINALLY GETTING INTO SOME OF
THE- OLDER COMPLAINTS THAT ARE
IN OUR SYSTEM AND RESOLVE THEM
AND MOVING FORWARD AND WE'LL
MAKE WHILE MAINTAINING. THE
SKETCHES ARE NEWER NEWER
COMPLAINTS COMING. IF THERE ARE
NO QUESTIONS OF WHAT I JUST
PRESENTED ALL GO AHEAD AND TURN
TOWARD THE STREETS. WELL I GUESS
BUT I MEAN I GUESS I WOULD JUST
SAY YOU'VE YOU'VE HAD A PORT SO
A LOT OF OPEN CASES RIGHT
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING IN THE
NEWS ABOUT ABOUT SKILLED
FACILITIES AND THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. AND SO WHEN YOU SAY
YOU HAVE ALMOST A 15% VACANCY
RATE AND I GUESS YOU'RE GONNA
TRY TO FILL THAT BUT- WHAT. WHAT
WHAT'S THE BRIDGE PLAN TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE
ALL. I MEAN AND I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE MOST
SERIOUS ONES ARE DEALT WITH
QUICKLY. BUT WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HUGE BACKLOG AND THE LACK OF
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO CARRY OUT
YOUR FUNCTIONS. YOU COMPLETELY
AGREE AND WE AND YOU KNOW THIS
IS AN EFFORT TO THE CENTER HAS
LONG SINCE ONE INSURE DRIVE IN
TWO WEEKS WHEN THERE'S THAT MANY
ON THE REPORT SAYS YOU MAY WELL
KNOW. THROUGH THE YEARS ABOUT
CAR TIMING US OF INVESTIGATIONS
AND SO AS WE MENTIONED. DURING A
YEAR OR SO AGO WE REALLY DEVICE
IMPLANTED TO TRACK MONITOR AND
SHE WILL BRING FOR OUR TIMING
WAS OVER MEDICATIONS AND GET
INTO THE- THOSE SERVICE STATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN LINGERING FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. AND SO. MY SURE
BASIC AND WANTED. AND BUNDLING
COMPLAIN YOU KNOW TOGETHER SO
WHEN YOU GO INTO A BUILDING. YOU
KNOW JUST DOING THE MOST
IMMEDIATE COMPLAINT THAT YOU
HAVE TRUSTED TAKING THREE OR
FOUR WAS THAT OUR OLDER-
PROTESTATIONS THAT SO WE HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS AND I
THINK THAT OUR DATA SHOWS THAT
WE ARE. REALLY DIVING INTO OUR
BACKYARD COMPLAINTS. WE HOPE TO.
YOU KNOW HAVE THESE RESULT. THE
NEAR TERM A- WE GET ANOTHER
NUMBER TO A LOT OF COMPLAINTS
AND TO SUPPORT THE BUSINESS
WORLD. UPWARDS OF TWENTY
THOUSAND EACH YEAR SO WE ARE
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO BE CURRENTLY ON OUR
CURRENT COMPLAINTS. WILL ALSO
HAVE OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT
WE NEED TO GET INTO THOSE AGING
COMPLAINTS AND RESOLVE THE FOUR
COMPLAINTS. SO I THINK THEY WERE
FIGHTING BOTH FRONTS. I'M PRETTY
WELL- HER VACANCIES YEAH WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE. YOUR EFFORTS TO
HIRE NURSES SOMETIMES THAT WE
ARE COMPETING WITH INDUSTRY
ESPECIALLY IN THE TORAH CODE
WERE YOU KNOW YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A NURSE TO COME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SERVICE BUT THE
SELLERS ARE SURE THAT WE HAVE
AND SO WE HAVE SOMECOMPETITION-
BUT WE ARE MAKING EFFORTS TO
HIRE RESULT IN HIRING AND
ONBOARDING TRAINING OVER NEW
NURSES- STARTED- GOT MENTIONED
EARLIER WE ARE TRYING TO.
UTILIZE NEW TECHNOLOGIES. TO
HELP US. TO COMPLETE THIS. WERE
TRAINED OPERATE SO THAT TO ME.
SCHEDULE PROCESSES WHICH WERE
MOSTLY WHEN WE ARE NOT ALL THE
KINKS WILL ALLOW US TO DO THOSE
COMPLAINTS FASTER. SO WE ARE
LOOKING FOR NEW WAYS OF
STREAMLINING ANYMORE FISHER WELL
OUR STAFF. WHILE WE STILL HIRE
THOSE PEOPLE TO DO OUR ONGOING
COURSE CERTAINLY WORKS FOR
RECERTIFICATION. AND CAN RELAX
FOR. THANK YOU AND A DIFFICULT A
DIFFICULT DR OKAY. THANK YOU
AND- AND I KNOW THERE'S MANY
AUDITS AND I BELIEVE- THE FED
SEVERAL HEARINGS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ASSEMBLY SIDE BUT- SO
KEY. THE TERMS IF YOU DIDN'T
MENTION DO YOU HAVE A VACANCY OF
ABOUT 15% FORTY POINT 7% WHAT'S
THE TURNOVER RATE. FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR NURSES SO WHAT PERCENTAGE
IN EACH YEAR ARE YOU. LOSING AND
THEN TAKE IT SO. SO WITH THAT
TURNOVER RATE HOW MUCH WE CAN
GET YOU I CAN GET YOU THE
HISTORICAL DATA I DON'T HAVE IT
HERE BEFORE ME I KNOW THAT WE'RE
TRACKING IT- I WANT TO SAY.
MEMORY OUR TURNOVER RATE SEEMS
TO BE AROUND FOUR OR 5% FOR A
NURSE. SO THAT WAS. BASICALLY
KEEPING WITH WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT FROM A HEALTHY WORKFORCE
RIGHT. I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT HAS
BEEN OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. I
KNOW THAT WE ARE TRACKING THAT
DATA SO. IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME I
WILL PROVIDE THE DATA.
AFTERWARDS TRUE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- ON OUR TURNOVER RATES FOR
NURSES. AT ANY IS OBVIOUSLY
BEING A NURSE INSPECTOR IS A
SPELL IT'S NEEDED STAPLE IN THE
NURSERY I MEAN THERE'S VERY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING FOR THIS
FOR THEM TO BE AN EFFECTIVE-
LAST YEAR SO IT'S A- ONE TO ONE
LEAVES YOU. KNOW THAT TAKES A
LOT OF WORK TO BRING SOMEONE UP
TO SPEED RIGHT. EXACTLY SO ARE
YOUR NORMAL NURSING EDUCATION TO
BE IN. A NURSING. HOME
INSPECTORS EXACTLY. I'M STILL IN
CONCERT TO. NOT SHORT TERM. ON
BY OUR NURSE NURSE. WHO HAVE TO
LEARN THE MYRIAD NUMBERS OF
REGULATIONS BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE. AND HOW TO APPLY THEM AND
DO THE INVESTIGATION THAT WILL
STAND THE TEST OF A CHALLENGE
FROM A FACILITY OR COURT. IF YOU
GET TO COURT. SO IT'S A VERY
TOUGH JOB THAT WE HAVE FOR
NURSES TO PERFORM. ONCE THE
TRAIN WE DO WE HAVE TRUNCATED
THREE YEARS OF SOME OF THE
PANELISTS. AS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD. OF YOU'RE FREE WE HAVE.
REALLY TRIED TO TRY. OUR
TRAINING PROGRAM. AND PROVIDE.
SPECIALTY TRAINING THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS TO UNDERSTAND SO THEY
CAN GET UP AND RUNNING FASTER.
AND TO HELP US GET INTO RECORD
THESE TAKE US A LONG TIME FOR US
TO GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
TRAINING PROCESS GOING ON THE
DOWN TO MAYBE A SIX WEEK.
TRAINING PROGRAM. AND SO.
GREENLIT TRYING THEM OUT BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT IT DOES TAKE A VERY
SPECIALIZED PERSON TO KNOW HOW
TO DO THAT INVESTIGATIVE.
TECHNIQUES HOW TO ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO KNOW WHERE TO LOOK
IN THE RECORDS FOR THE FINDINGS.
AND THEN TO DIG DEEPER SO. IT'S
NOT AN EASY JOB- BUT WE HAVE A
DEDICATED WORKFORCE AND I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND HAPPY THAT I
ASSOCIATE WITH THE PROGRAM RIGHT
WELL TYLER I THINK FROM AN HR
STANDPOINT THINKING ABOUT BY-
THAT'S WHY IT'S ASKING THE TURN
HELLO- UNDER SORT OF ALTERNATIVE
WORK ARRANGEMENTS SO THAT YOU
CAN. RETAIN PEOPLE EVEN IF
THEY'RE SO THAT YOU HAVE ALWAYS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU TRAIN
THEM DO YOU HAVE A SPECIALIZED
POOL RIGHT SO HOW DO YOU STAY IN
TOUCH WITH THEM. EVEN ONES WHO
MADE DECIDED WHY DO THAT FULL
TIME ARTS CENTER BUT I JUST
THINK THAT THAT BUT THE I GUESS
THE NEXT QUESTION IS THAT. HE
DID MENTION THAT PRIOR TO COPE
WITH THAT YOU'RE ON TIME RATE
WAS 72% AND THEN IT PROBABLY
WENT DOWN IT'S HOPEFULLY YOU'RE
GETTING IT BACK BUT- I HAVE TO
SAY IF YOU'RE 72% I'M THINKING
LIKE OH WELL THAT MEANS OWN YOU
KNOW. OVER A QUARTER OF ALL
COMPLAINTS ARE NOT ON TIME YOU
KNOW DEALT WITH ON TIME- IS
THERE A GOAL TO GET THAT HIGHER
AND WHAT SHOULD BE THE NORMAL
HON TIME- AND INSTIGATION I
REALIZE SOME PEOPLE WILL SAY YOU
KNOW. SO IT'S A 100% I MEAN
REALISTICALLY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
STILL SOUNDS LIKE IT'S- FAIRLY
LOW AND THAT MAYBE SHOULD WE BE
DOING NEED MORE PEOPLE SO WE
CAN. SO WE HAD A HIGHER TARGET.
SO WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
APPROPRIATE. ON TIME
INVESTIGATION RIGHT. CHECK YOUR
PREMIER TO SPOT. WELL I AM BUT I
MEAN THAT BUT SOMEONE'S LOOK AT
SEVEN TO GET UPSET I GONNA BE
BECAUSE- AS IT IS NOT TO BE A
HIGH. PERCENT BUT- THEY DON'T. I
HAD. 2% YOU'RE FROM. WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME
CHRIS HAS. OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO BE- YOU KNOW REALISTICALLY I
WOULD SAY THAT IF WE WERE IN THE
HIGH EIGHTY PERCENTILE FOR
ONLINE I'M CIRCLING TIMING
DECISIONS. PRETTY DARN GOOD WE
ALWAYS KNEW THAT SOME OF OUR
INVESTIGATIONS WILL REQUIRE MORE
EFFORT TRUE. TRUE OR DO A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION. YOU
MIGHT NEED IT WE MIGHT NEED TO
GO TO A HOSPITAL OR SEVERAL
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE ON VACATIONS
TO GET THAT FINAL INTERVIEW WE
MAY NEED FOUR CORNERS REPORT US
THERE'S A DEATH INVOLVED. SO YOU
. ME PERSONALLY I WOULD SAY IF
YOU GIVE HER THE HIGH EIGHTIES.
EARLIER CRITIC YOUR METRICS
PRESS THE START. DO WE NEED MORE
POSITIONS. YOU KNOW THERE'S
ALWAYS A TOUGH QUESTION AND
IMPOVERISHMENT DOES DO THAT
IRISH EACH YEAR RIGHT SO PART OF
IT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO DO IS
COME BACK LET'S SAY SURE SAY.
HERE'S OUR WORKLOAD HERE'S-
HERE'S OUR BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS
CHOOSE THE POSITIONS THAT WE
NEED. TO GO FOR. THE FACT THAT
WE ARE MAKING PRETTY STRONG-
REDUCTIONS IN OUR COMPLAINT
BACKLOG WHICH DOES HE DIDN'T
SURE HOW MANY POSITIONS THAT WE
NEED. WHAT ARE YOU FOR THE FACT
THAT WE MAYBE TEMPERING OUT IN
YEARS TO COME RIGHT. SO IF WE
HAVE A. 14% VACANCY RATE. IF YOU
GET DOWN 2% ZERO EIGHT FOUR
ORDERS WE GET THE- WHILE WE
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN. CON DIVING
INTO OUR OUR BACK ON YOUR
CLIENTS. YOU KNOW I CAN'T TELL
YOU WHAT WILL BE NEXT YEAR NEXT
YEAR WE MIGHT BE. A LITTLE
HIGHER ON THAT. ON TIME
COMPLETION RATE- SO AS WE AS I
MENTIONED EVERY. YOU KNOW WRAP
UP THOSE OLD COMPLAINTS THAT
MEANS THAT STAFF CANNOT TRAIN TO
NEW COMPLAINTS SO I CAN'T
PREDICT BUT THAT'S THE PURPOSE
OF THE S. BUT THAT'S A PERSONAL
COMMITMENT IS THE SUREST TOTELL
YOU KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT WITH
OUR WORK WHAT LOOKS LIKE. OKAY
SO IT IS CRUCIAL OKAY SO
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT MY FIRST
TIME AROUND THIS RODEO SO FOR
EXAMPLE I KNOW THAT BACK WHEN I
WAS CHAIR OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE THERE WAS AN ISSUE AND
THEN TURNED OUT SOMEONE HAD TO
DO WITH HOW THEY CLOSED OUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND SO FORTH AND
SOME OF THE PROCESS IS OVER SO
YES IT'S NOT ALL THAT'S RIGHT
THE WORK FORCE SO THIS COULD BE
YOU KNOW AS A NUMBER OF
POSITIONS THAT. PEOPLE YOU KNOW
NOT SIMPLIFYING DATA ON TIME ARE
YOU HAVING DIFFICULTY ACCESSING
THE DATA TOOK BILL COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION ETCETERA BUT
WHAT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL TO US SO
WHAT WORKS FOR YOUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IS AND- WHAT ARE
THE THINGS THAT ARE STOPPING YOU
FROM GETTING TO THE OTHER DAY
FOR EIGHTIETH PERCENTILE IS A
NUMBER OF POSITIONS IS IT DO WE
HAVE TO TURN TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE AND SAID GUESS WHAT WE
NEED SOME LEGISLATION GIVE YOU
MORE OF A HAMMER TO GET THE DATA
YOU NEED ON TIME TO CLOSE THE
INVESTIGATION ON THE TIMELY
MANNER IT'S ADDRESS SO THAT TYPE
OF ANALYSIS IS. ALWAYS GOING TO
BE HELPFUL TO US SO WE CAN HELP
YOU BUT WHEN YOU'RE NOT AT THAT
UP 480% OR WHATEVER- AND I KNOW
I PUT YOU ON THE SPOT TO SAY
WHAT WHAT SHOULD BE YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA SAY SO WHAT DO YOU
NEED IF YOU DON'T COME BACK AND
TELL US THIS IS THE THING THAT
WE NEED YOU WE NEED YOUR HELP
AND TO GET IT AND WHEN I SAY
WELL WHY AREN'T YOU THERE SO- IF
WE SEE YOUR YOUR
STRAIGHTFORWARDNESS AND YOUR
ANSWERS AND I CERTAINLY KNOW
DURING COVE IT'S BEEN
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING. AS
WELL- BUT THEM PLEASE HELP US
HELP YOU BECAUSE WHAT YOU DO IS
SO VERY IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC AND WE WANNA BE
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS YOU NEED TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO- WITH THAT
AGAIN APPRECIATE IT BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING SOME MORE
INFORMATION FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT
SETS ARE ALL YOU ARE THE US
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
SO WE WANTED TO BE SURE WE'RE.
HITTING THE QUALITY THAT THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT. THANK YOU
SIR. WE SOLICIT. THOSE RECENTLY
. WILL AND- THE- THAT. HAVE A-
FROM SISTER SO. AGAIN WE- THAT.
UNDER YEAR ON FOR THE NEXT TWO
ISSUES. I AM ABSOLUTELY SCROLL
DOWN THROUGH THE NEXT ITEM SO
OUR FIRST BASICALLY THAT WE'RE
PRESENTING- IT SHOWS REQUESTING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY- FROM.
FROM THE LISTINGS OR KITCHEN
FUND FOR EIGHTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
EXTENDED AUGMENT THE
DEPARTMENT'S HEALTH CARE
FACILITY CERTIFICATION CONTRACT
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY- THIS
MONEY IS TO. ACCOUNT FOR
INDIRECT COSTS INCLUDE BENEFIT
RAISING PERSONAL COSTS AND THESE
COSTS HAVE INCREASED. THIS WOULD
BE A ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF THE
CURRENT THREE YEAR CONTRACT. SO
WE'RE NOT SURE IF YOU'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE- GENERALLY WE
- I HAVE A THREE YEAR CONTRACT
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY HOW TO
PERFORM SURVEYS OR KITCHEN WORK
IN. CHARACTER THIS IS LOCATED
THERE- THIS UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR
JUNE THIRTIETH CONCLUDES OUR
THREE YEAR CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE
HAD IN PLACE. THEY WERE ASKING
FOR A ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF THAT
THIRD YEAR OF THE CONTRACT WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO BUILD BUILD
ANOTHER BRIDGE OUT FROM OUR CALL
AND RESPONSE- ENTERPRISE TIME TO
NEGOTIATE ANOTHER THREE YEAR
CONTRACT WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
. SO BECAUSE COVERT HIT US
PRETTY HARD AND WE HAD TO PIVOT
FROM OUR NORMAL WORK FLOW TO
CODE RESPONSE WORKERS SCHOOLERS
IF LAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OR
SO- WE DIDN'T HAVE STRONG
METRICS TO SEE HOW WELL LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WAS PERFORMING.
THROUGH THEIR CORE WORKLOAD- THE
LAST TWO YEAR CONTRACT TO
PROVIDE. US I THINK INCREASE AND
FUNDING FOR ALL THE COUNTY. FOR
THEM TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
GOING TO TRAIN THEM TO DO OUR
CORE WORKLOAD AND WHAT WE HAVE
UNTIL SHE COULD SEE. HOW WELL
THEY WILL PERFORM IN A POST
PANDEMIC WORLD SO AS WE BUILD
OUT THIS YEAR AND RETURN TO A
NORMAL WORK- WE WILL WE'LL GET A
SENSE ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
PERFORMING- AND WE'LL USE THAT
INFORMATION OVER THE NEXT TWELVE
MONTHS OR SO. TRUE NEGOTIATE
ANOTHER CONTRACT WITH LOS
ANGELES SO THIS IS BASICALLY A
PLACEHOLDER- FOR WHEN YOU'RE
BRIDGING CONTRACT WELL WE. BUILD
OUT FROM KOBE RESPONSE. DR
ANDREA YET SO ACTUALLY THE- THE
MY QUESTION IS HOW THE DAILY DO
BEFORE COVE IS THAT SO YOU TOLD
THE 72% FOR DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING LA OR IS L. I WILL IS
ONLY DOING- THE PHOTO IN.
INTERNET SERVICE EVERYTHING YORK
LATEST CATIONS. FROM THEIR
DESTINATIONS RIGHT YEAH WE'RE
INTERESTED STATE. NANCY IS THEY
WERE NOT PERFORMING AS WELL AS
THE STATE AND I WILL SAY
ARGUABLY THAT'S BECAUSE THEY
WERE UNDERFUNDED AND
UNDERSTAFFED OKAY I THINK THE
WEEK KNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THE
LAST FOR YOUR CONTRACT WILL
RECOGNIZE WHAT WE LOOK TO THE
WORKLOAD. OKAY SO THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT EQUITATION AND SO
YOU KNOW THEY WERE NOT
PERFORMING AS WELL AS THE S.
RUSSELL ST AND- WHAT WE HAD
HOPED. TO PANDEMIC DIDN'T.
THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE IS THAT THEY
WOULD LOOK MORE LIKE THE REST
SIX THREE. SIX REPORTERS AT THE
END OF THREE YEARS RIGHT. WE
CAN'T REALLY TELL HOW THEIR
COMPANY UNTIL. WE HAVE MORE TIME
TO KIND OF SEE WHAT LOOKS LIKE
OKAY AND I MEAN THAT'S A SIGN I
MEAN BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING AWAY
OBVIOUSLY LARGER IMPACT ON
SENIORS SENIORS INSTITUTIONS AND
SO FORTH SO- THERE'S REALLY
ISN'T A POST CODE BUT I GUESS
IT'S UP. NORTH WHEN THINGS ARE
MORE STABILIZED- SO BASICALLY
YOU SAID THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WIN YOUR EXTENSION AND YOU.
SHARE WITH US SOME DATA AND THEN
PROPOSE WHAT YOU'RE GONNA GET IT
AND THEN YOU'RE NEGOTIATING A
NEW THREE YEAR CONTRACT CORRECT
SIR. SIX NEXT YEAR ABOUT THIS
TIME WILL COME BACK. TO YOU AND
WILL HAVE WORK SPACE ABOUT.
COUNTRY BECAUSE SHE- AND- WHAT
WE SAW HAVE MORE INFORMATION THE
COMMITTEE- ONCE THIS TIME NEXT
YEAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY
AND THEN A DIRECTOR MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX HEALTH
FACILITIES OVERSIGHT. OKAY C.
DPH REQUEST SIX HUNDRED FORTY
FOR THE LICENSING CERTIFICATION
FOR UNDER THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
RESEARCHING A POTENTIAL
ACTIVITIES AND TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AN
ANNUAL- AFTER TO FIND TWO
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE QUALITY
ASSURANCE IN NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATOR PROGRAM.
PERSONALLY THIS PIECE OF PAPER
AND RIGHT SIZE TO HELP US ISSUE
INSTRUCTIONAL SECTION BY OPENING
ON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CONTRACT WE HAVE WITH THE C.
DAVIS. IN FRONT. OF DISTAL SIX-
TRANSACTION PROVISIONS FOR ONE
YEAR TO CONTINUE OFFERING
EXPANDED I. T. SERVICES
INTERXION PREVENTION SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IT WILL
ALSO FIND TWO FOR THE NURSING
HOME ADMINISTRATOR PROGRAM.
ESPECIALLY THE STAFF TRUE
OVERSEE AND HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
THOSE NURSING ADMINISTRATORS
UNDER LICENSE BY CDPH. SO JUST
LOOK AT IT HERE FOR THE TREES
ARE FACING EACH OTHER COMMITTEE
ISSUED A SECTION. USED TO
PRIMARILY- PERSONAL PERSONAL
SERVICES AND HOSPITAL SETTINGS
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THEY WERE
SO LOOK FOR. DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE REALIZED THAT. THEIR SKILLS
WERE NEEDED. IN OTHER ARENAS- SO
THEY HAVE BEEN INSTABILITY AND
HELPING US. WITH SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AS WELL AS HIS
LICENSE BY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO PREVENT INFECTION
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AND
MONITORING CEREALS AND GUNS SO
WE ARE WE ARE SEEKING TO RIGHT
SIZE OF THE PROGRAM A LITTLE BIT
WE'RE SEEKING. IS NATIONAL SIX
YEAR FUNDING FOR SIX POSITIONS
FOR ONE YEAR TO KIND OF CONTINUE
OUR GOOD EFFORTS FOR FIGHTING-
INTERXION PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THE OTHER
TWO POSITIONS THAT WERE ASKING
FOR THE NURSING. THIS IS A SMALL
UNIT WITH AN ART CENTER BUT IT
ALSO SERVES A VITAL ROLE TRUE
EACH NURSING HOME HAS TO HAVE A
NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATOR. AND
THIS PROGRAM HASN'T HAD A LOT OF
BRITISH TO STAFF. IN TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF WORKING WITH THE CENTER
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR TWO
POSITIONS TRUE ADDRESS. OR
SELECTIVELY COMPLAINANTS CATIONS
AND- THE- THE ABILITY TO BRING
NEW NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATORS
IN TWO. RATIONS AND LAND LICENSE
AND OVERSEE THEM SO THIS
POSITION IS BASICALLY WHAT FUN
TO POSITIONS TO HELP CONTROL US
THAT WERE COLLECTED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AND
THAT IS DANNEMORA IMPLEMENTING
SP THREE EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR PAM TINA
MOORE YOU DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
INFORMATICS CHIEF DATA OFFICER
AND STATE REGISTRAR. OUR CENTER
IS SPONSORED FOR THE
REGISTRATION OF VITAL EVENTS
ISSUANCE OF LEGAL VITAL RECORDS
DOCUMENTS AND COLLECTION
MANAGEMENT AND CURATION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IDLE STATISTICS
DATA. ARE WE ARE ALSO CHARGED
WITH OVERSIGHT OF THE END OF
LIFE ACTS. AS PART OF SP THREE
EIGHTY S. BILL PERMITS AN
INDIVIDUAL TO QUALIFY FOR
PRESCRIPTIONS AID IN DYING DRUG
BY REITERATING THE HORRIBLE
MORAL REQUESTS THE ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN FORTY EIGHT HOURS
AFTER MAKING THE INITIAL
REQUEST. INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
DURATION OF FIFTEEN DAYS. THE
BILL ALSO ELIMINATES. WITH A
FORTY EIGHT HOURS PRIOR TO STOP
MINISTERING THE AID IN DYING
MEDICATION. ALSO THIS INCLUDES
GENDER NEUTRAL LANGUAGE CHANGES
TO THE INTERPRETER FORM
SUBMITTED TO CDPH-
IMPLEMENTATION OF SP THREE
EIGHTY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH REQUESTS ONE
POSITION AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. THAT'S ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH IN THE
SPELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
CAN'T PREDICT THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE USING IT MAY GO UP BUT
THAT THAT THAT JUST SHOWS THAT
THE LEGISLATION WAS IMPORTANT
PEOPLE WILL ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO-
UTILIZE THE PROCESS YES. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS WE WANT
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
CANNERY INSPECTION PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES. HI GOOD AFTERNOON I
AM IGNORING CLIENT I'M THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
AND I WILL ACTUALLY BE COVERING
THE LAST- FIGHT ISSUES. ALSO
WITH ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT THE
CAMERA INSPECTION PROGRAM SO
THIS IS A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
TO OUR APPROPRIATION. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUEST AN INCREASE OF
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
CAMERA INSPECTION FUN. BEGINNING
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AN UNCLE IN. EACH BATCH OF
CANNED PRODUCTS. MUST BE- MUST
BE INSPECTED. BEFORE BEING
RELEASED INTO COMMERCE TO MAKE
SURE. THEY ARE PROPERLY PROCESS
AND WILL NOT RESOLVE. THE GAMES
FOR BARNSLEY ILLNESSES. CAN BACK
FROM HAVE GONE BY IN THE LAST
YEAR. RESTAURANTS THE SPECIAL
FROM APPROPRIATION IN THE
CANNERY IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT TO
COVER ALL OF THE EXPENSES. ANY
QUESTIONS. YES DOCTOR BROWN
DINER STANDARDS A
MISAPPROPRIATION NATIONALLY FOR
THE FOOD SAFETY FUND AS OF THIS
THE FOOD SAFETY FUND GOING TO BE
I GUESS THE REIMBURSED FOR THOSE
MISAPPROPRIATION FROM THE
CANNERY FUND OR IS IT ARE WE
JUST GOING FORWARD NOW WE'RE
TAKING OUT THE COUNTY FUND SO WE
MAKING UP THE DEFICIT AND THE
FOOD SAFETY FUN- BUT THAT THE
SHORT ANSWER IS WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY MAKING UP A DEFICIT.
AND CREATE OUR IDEAL THE END OF
MISAPPROPRIATION SIGHT WORD I
DON'T USE THE WRONG WORD BUT
PROVIDES. I WOULDN'T USE THE
WORD MISAPPROPRIATION WHAT-
THESE THE STAFF IN THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE FOOD SAFETY PROGRAM
IS SO LARGE AND IT HAS A NUMBER
OF KIND OF PROGRAMS UNDER THE
FUND. THE FOOD SAFETY FUND- AND
THE STAFF ARE ASSIGNED TO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS I THINK WHAT
WE DISCOVERED IS THAT. THERE
WERE TIMES WHERE STAFF WERE
ASSIGNED TO ONE PROGRAM BUT THEY
WERE ASSISTING WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS. AND AT THAT TIME THE-
SYSTEM BACK WE HAD IMPLEMENTED
FOR- CAPTURING THE EXPENSES FOR
EACH PROGRAM WAS NOT AS ADEQUATE
AS WE THOUGHT SO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE IMPLEMENTED A- NEW
MORE ROBUST- TIME ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM. SO NOW WHAT EACH STAFF
DO YOU IS IT A FRAMEWORK- THAT
DETAIL IS THEY ASSIGN THEIR TIME
TO A SPECIFIC PROGRAM SO THIS IS
JUST ON THE PLAYERS I'M GOING TO
DO IS JUST GOING FORWARD WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO BACK IN TIME AND
SEE HOW WE NEED TO READJUST
CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY THAT'S IT
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE FLOOR US
COPIES. PARTITION NUMBER TWO
NINE- ANY WAY OVER ONE BECAUSE
AND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOR
THOUSAND BEGINNING FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
CALLING FROM THE RADIATION
CONTROL ON THE SYSTEM
IMPLEMENTED EIGHTY THREE FIFTY
SIX STARBUCKS HAS A NEW MANDATE
ISSUE BACK TO LICENSED DOCTORS
AT ONE TIME NONRENEWABLE TWELVE
MONTH TEMPORARY PERMIT TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE OR SUPERVISED.
TORRES COULD BE EXTRA QUICK MIND
IF THE DOCTOR HAS AT LEAST FORTY
HOURS OF EXPERIENCE IN USING
KERR ASKED ME EXTRA EQUIPMENT
THIS WILL ALLOW LICENSED DOCTORS
TO CONTINUE PRACTICING WHILE THE
DOCTOR COMPLAINS THAT REQUIRE
EXAMINATION PROCESS FOURTEEN
SEPARATE. CALIFORNIA FOR US. ANY
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING TO END HIM. CAN SOME
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF INDUSTRIAL HIM
- THIS REQUIRES G. PH
TEMPERATURE LIKE THE USE OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS THE BILL HAS AN
EMERGENCY CLAUSE WE'RE TAKING A
PHASED IN APPROACH TO OUR
RESOURCE REQUESTS TO START
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR WHAT'S ELEVEN POSITIONS AND
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING SEVEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR A TOTAL
OF EIGHTEEN ESSENTIALS AND FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FROM THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS. AND THEN SEVEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR A TOTAL
OF TWENTY FIVE SESSIONS AND FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AN ON CALL WAITING AND THAT
WILL BE FROM THE INDUSTRIAL
HAMPTON ROLE. MEANT AN OVERSIGHT
SPECIAL FUN. WELL ALSO.
REIMBURSEMENT PART OF CANNABIS.
AND TO. SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING
AND THIS IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO TEST
INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTS. FOR A RANGE
OF CANNABINOIDS FOR CD PH
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS ALL OF
THESE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED FOR
SEEKING INTERESTED YOU ARE RICH
EDUCATIONAL. REGULATIONS
LICENSING. OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS.
INSPECTION AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES. ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL BE INTERESTED
IN THIS GOING FORWARD AS IT SAT
AT THE END A NEW AREA CALIFORNIA
IS GOING INTO. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE PRIORITY INLAND WATER
CONTRACT RECREATION SITES FOR A.
B. TEN SIXTY SIX. CANSECO CBS
REQUEST AND ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION. OF A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
FROM THE CHANNEL ON- MAYBE TEN
SIXTY SIX REQUIRE . PH TO COOK
CHAIR. AND WORKING GIRL WHAT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD LEVEL STUDY WATER
RECREATION PASSERS AT WATER
CONTACT RECREATION SITES AND
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER QUALITY
MONITORING COUNCIL. BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE COUNCIL
IN CONSULTATION WITH CITY PH
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO PROPOSE TO THE WATER
OR- RECOMMENDATIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A MICROBIAL
WATER MONITORING PROGRAM. FOR
RECREATION SITES. ANY QUESTIONS
. HI 30% JUST QUICK QUESTION IS
THIS ALSO APPLY TO I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE RIVERS WITH WORRY
ABOUT RIVERS ARE NOT I MEAN IT'S
MOVING WATER BUT IF SOMETHING'S
UPSTREAM OF SLOWS DOWN SO IT'S
JUST APPLYING TO CLOSED INLAND
OR DOES IT APPLY TO THINGS LIKE
RIVERS AND STREAMS WERE TO MIGHT
BE RECREATIONAL FACILITIES. I
BELIEVE THAT APPLIES TO ALL- ALL
WATER SOURCES THAT ARE
CONSIDERING CREATION ALL FRESH
WATER ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN THE
FINAL- ISSUE FOR TODAY IS
COMMERCIAL FISHING INSPECTION S.
B. EIGHTY CRAB TRAPS. OKAY LAST
ONE TO PATRICK REQUEST THREE
POSITIONS AND SEVEN HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND AND- AS FOR YOUR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M CALLING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. THE
RESOURCES WERE ADDRESSED ALONE
ACCOUNTS OF THE VENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S DUNGENESS CRAB
INDUSTRY THAT'S JUST A SAMPLING
TESTING AND AUTHORIZED INVESTOR
RIGHT SEAN BY COMMERCIAL
PROCESSORS. TO ENSURE SAFE
PRODUCTS CONTINUE TO ENTER ENTER
THE MARKET PLACE. SANTA MONICA
ASSET AND CRAP LIKE USUALLY IT'S
PRIMARILY IN THE BEST ROUTE.
THEREFORE IF TESTING SHOWS THE
CONTAMINATION IS NOT PRESENT IN
THE MEAT FROM LOOKING THE BEST
ROUTE CAN RESULT IN CRAP. THAT
IS STILL SAFE CONSUMPTION. ANY
QUESTIONS. I KNOW WE THANK YOU
FOR CLAY US WITH THAT WITH WITH
THE CRASH- WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T REMARK THAT ARE FINE
ANALYST WAS EXCITED TO DO THE-
EVALUATION FOR THIS BECAUSE YOU
GET TO GO ON A TOUR OF A CRAB
AREA AT ONE TIME AND REALIZED
THAT THIS THERE IS AND I'M SURE
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THIS- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THAT THIS IS A MOVIE
WAS MADE ABOUT. THIS ISSUE. WELL
IT'S AS SPECULATED. THAT
WEREN'T- TESTAVAILABLE AT THE
TIME WAY BACK WHEN HITCHCOCK
MADE HIS MOVIE THE BIRDS. BUT
IT'S SPECULATED THAT SOME
STRANGE BEHAVIOR AT THAT TIME
BUT THE BIRDS MAY HAVE BEEN
ATTRIBUTED TO A DEMONIC OUTSIDE
OF AUNT MAY HAVE BEEN OKAY. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT WE TAKE OUT THE
PATROL AND JUST DISPOSE OF IT
AND JUST DON'T THROW IT AWAY-
ARE CRABS IT MAKE SURE. THE
GOODWILL OR NON PROFITS FOR THE
FANTASTIC CRAB FEEDS WILL ENJOY
SO MUCH AND MAKE SURE THE BIRDS
STICK TO THEMSELVES. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND FOR OUR-
ANALYST WHO HAD HELPED ME.
UNDERSTAND THAT BETTER- SO THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH- I DON'T SEE
YOUR HAND UP MISS PRODUCTS SO
I'M THINKING YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS. OKAY ON ALL
THE ONES THAT WE DID AND WE
CERTAINLY THINK THE DEPARTMENT-
FOR THEIR- FOR INTERNAL THE-
FOR. A LISTING. AND ESPECIALLY
FOR JUST THAT ME MAINTAINING. OF
CALIFORNIA PART A PUBLIC HEALTH
AS WE HAVE. OUR IN OUR THIRD
YEAR NOW OF THE PANDEMIC AND
HOPEFULLY OUR LAST AS WE AS WE
GO INTO THE- ENDEMIC. SO I WOULD
DENT NOW ASKING CAN AGAIN
CAUTION PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK FOR HER TO GO
INTO PUBLIC COMMENTS RIGHT NOW-
AND SO AGAIN THAT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR WITH THE ACCESS
CODE. OF THREE FIVE THREE ONE
TWO. EIGHT THREE. AND AGAIN I
WILL SAY YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE IN
WHICH SPEAK BUT IF YOU DON'T GET
TO SAY EVERYTHING YOU WANT. THEN
PLEASE CONTACT OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR MORE. INPUT OPERATOR
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO WE HAVE ON
THE LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS
TIME- I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT A
LIVE IN IN Q. OKAY LET'S GO GET
GOING WITH THE FIRST ONE. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA REGION
INTERFERED WITH THAT THE HMO
HERE TODAY BUT A COMMON ITEM
THIRTEEN IN A NUMBER THE TRAGIC
IMPACT OF THE OPIOID CRISIS
EVERY DAY. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
OPIOID AWARENESS CAMPAIGN YOUR
AVAILABLE THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TO THE NEXT LINE OPERATED
BY. ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK'S TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
SEVERAL CLIENTS FIRST THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING TODAY AND THE
TIME AND ATTENTION THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE AN ISSUE AT THE
IRVINE COUNTY CALIFORNIA THE
BOARD THAT THE PROVIDERS OF
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA AND
ADDRESS THE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
TO THE STATE. AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
HERO INITIATIVE THAT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE RIGHT THE REST
OF MY COMMENTS WILL BE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION. COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS THE COURT
ISSUED THREE ISSUE FOR ISSUE
NINE ISSUE TWELVE ISSUE THIRTEEN
ISSUE TWENTY NINE I HAVE
COMMENTS ON THREE ADDITIONAL
ITEMS ON IF YOU CAN ACT OF
COURSE THE IMPACT THAT THE
REGIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH PLANNING
ANALYTICAL CONSIDERATIONS RAISED
BY THE LA L. UNDERSTAND ABILITY
AND ABILITY FOR HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ARE NOT. GOING TO BE
PLANNED ON ISSUE TWENTY TWO
JACKSON COURT INCREASED FUNDING
TO HELP VISITING PROGRAM YEAH
BUT THE FUNDING FIRST GO TO
SHORE UP EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR
COMBATING PROGRAMS AND ENCOURAGE
THE PAGE TO EXPLORE ADDITIONAL
MODELED IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
REACH THE MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES. FINALLY ON ISSUE
TWENTY THREE TRACK RECORD
INCREASE FUNDING FOR BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM ENCOURAGES
TBH TO PROVIDE ONGOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FACILITY PRESS ACTORS
SHARING PUBLIC LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BEFORE IMPLEMENTING
ANY CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU SO. MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN SO PLEASE AHEAD. THANK
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BUT I
THINK NOW THE HAPPENED I FAMILY
. ON ISSUE TWENTY WE'RE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE PROPOSED BUT
NOT HOME VISITING. ANGELS BUT I
POPCORN OR SPONSOR PARTNER
DELIVERING EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING SERVICES WHICH
EXPERIENCED DEPOSIT EXPECTED
GROWTH THROUGH THE PANDEMIC LIKE
SO MANY OTHER CRITICAL SERVICES
THE PROPOSAL OF THE GREAT PARTS
REACH OUT MORE FAMILY BELIEVED
TO BE BASED ON FIRST PARTY
MEDICAL BIRTH. NUMBER COULD BE
EXPANDED WE'LL BE SUBMITTING A
FORMAL REQUEST BUT. THE PROCESS
AND PROCEDURE ATTENTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NO CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN FOR EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CRAIG
PULSIPHER ON BEHALF OF A. T. L.
A. HELP AND THE EPIDEMICS A
STATEWIDE COALITION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO ENDING
THE EPIDEMIC THAT H. I. B. S. G.
I.'S VIRAL HEPATITIS OVERDOSE WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO ALLOCATE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. AT THE
SAME TIME HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT WILL
REMAIN UNDERFUNDED AND LET THE
STATE DEDICATE SPECIFIC
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THE COALITION HAS PUT
TOGETHER A COMPREHENSIVE BUDGET
PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES TARGETED
FUNDING TO ADDRESS. EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE THANK YOU THE SIMPLE
ACT AND CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
RISING OVERDOSE DEATHS AS WELL
AS ONGOING TRANSMISSION OF
HEPATITIS B. M. G. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PRIORITIES ARE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
YOU'RE RIGHT NINE WE'VE AHEAD.
ANY HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT TO THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WELL THE
COMMITMENT IS INTEGRAL TO THE
FUTURE HELP IN CALIFORNIA WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO DEDICATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT UNDERSTAFFED
AND UNDERFUNDED FOR DECADES
DESPITE THE COMPLEX DIVERSE AND
NECESSARY RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDERTAKE THESE WORKFORCE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC THE RESPONSIBILITY
PLACED ON LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR EXAMPLE THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAD THE
LOWEST RATIO OF LICENSED HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONAL FOR ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION
HIGHLIGHTING AN INCREASED NEED
FOR ROBUST PREVENTION AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE. DESPITE THE
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEIR ROLE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL TEACHING YOU
TO BE OVERLOOKED AS THEY ARE
PROHIBITED FROM PARTICIPATING
AND LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
AFFORDED A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THE CREATION OF A LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WOULD
HELP RECRUIT AND RETAIN PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THE MOST PUBLIC
HEALTH POSITIONS REQUIRE HIGHER
LEVELS OF EDUCATION INCLUDING
POSTGRADUATE DEGREE DESPITE THIS
THERE ARE NO CURRENTLY EXISTING
PROGRAMS FOR NON LIFE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PERSONNEL TO HELP WITH
THE COST OF THEIR EDUCATION WE
ASKED THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
SUPPORT A DEDICATED LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH THANKS
HOPEFULLY. PLEASE THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LAYING UNDER THE SAND CAN BOARD
OF. AND SUPPORTED TO ONE I THINK
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING A
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND THE HERO PROGRAM BUT I CAN
USE THE CODE I SUPPORT BOTH FULL
HEARTEDLY AND I WOULD SAY ON
BEHALF OF THE MERCED COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ITEM THAT
THAT YEAH I'M A LOBBYIST AND
SPOKE TO ON WORK FORCE. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS OFTEN CUT HIM
IN PART TO A COUPLE DIFFERENT
ALI COUNTIES INCLUDING WORKSITE
IN STANISLAUS AND WENT OUT OF
THE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ACTION ON
THAT FRONT THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT TWENTY THREE IS GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH- HELLO
MY NAME IS ALONG THE CHALLENGE
AND I'M CALLING TODAY ON HOW THE
ULTIMATE HELD SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH EQUITY
RACIAL JUSTICE. ARGUMENT IS THE
LARGEST INDEPENDENT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA OPERATING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
IN CARING FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS SOME OF THE
MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. WHAT
THE HELL BACK BE A RACIAL THAT'S
FINE BECAUSE IT IS. A UNIQUE AND
BOLD FONT THAT WOULD DEDICATE NO
LESS THAN A HUNDRED MILLION TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CAN MAKE. AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS. BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
CRUCIAL BECAUSE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS NOW THE
COMMUNITIES THAT. ARE TRUSTED IN
BEST POSITION TO SERVE- THEIR
UNIQUE LOCAL NEEDS. IN A
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
TAILORED WAY. THANK YOU. WE
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR BEING
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
HEALTHEQUITY RACIAL JUSTICE FUN
AND URGE YOU TO AGAIN INCLUDE IN
YOUR IN YOUR BUDGET TO ADVANCE
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AT NINE FIFTY ONE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
CHAIRS FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON TRICKY RETREAT FROM
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE I
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
HEALTHEQUITY RACIAL JUSTICE FUND
THAT WOULD PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CLINIC AND TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
TO IDENTIFY THE MOST PRESSING
INEQUITIES AND INJUSTICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND TAYLOR
BEST PRACTICES TO ADDRESS THEM
LOCAL LEADERS KNOW COMMUNITY
NEEDS THAT MAY NOT SHOW UP IN
COUNTY OR HOSPITAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IMPORTANTLY THE KNOW
HOW TO TAILOR BEST PRACTICES TO
BE MOST EFFECTIVE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR EXAMPLE SHE DEALS ARE
IN THE BEST POSITION TO KNOW
THAT THE SOLUTION. TO FOOD
INSECURITY IN ONE NEIGHBORHOOD
IS TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
LOCAL GROCERY STORE TO BECOME
WITH PROVIDER IN ANOTHER IT'S TO
TRANSLATE OUTREACH MATERIALS TO
REACH THE LOCAL CAMANCHE UNITY
IN ANOTHER IT'S DETAINED THE
TIME SCHOOL BREAKFAST SERVED
EVERY COMMUNITY IS DIFFERENT.
LONDON LOCAL LEADERS TO
COLLABORATE WITH. LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. WE HELP CONNECT WITH
AND INTO. ACROSS STATE IN THIS
TIME OF. MATCH FOR CALL. WE
DON'T TO TAKE THANK VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CALL MAY OPERATE ON A
CALLER. I THINK YOU RYAN FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALLISON HOMICIDE EIGHT
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN THE CAR
AND THE HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND WE REPRESENT SIXTY
FIVE CLINICS OPERATE OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE AND ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION LOW INCOME
AND YOUR EXPECTATIONS I LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HEALTHEQUITY
RACIAL JUSTICE FINE. DEDICATE
CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND CLINICS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT LOCAL SOLUTIONS TO
LOCAL ISSUES. THANK YOU TO THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW I URGE YOU
TO INCLUDE THE FUNDING. IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COURT
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GERRY GRUPO REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION MY
COMMENT IN THE GROUP MY COMMENT
IS IN RESPONSE TO ISSUE TWELVE
THE ALZHEIMER'S HEALTHY BRAIN
INITIATIVE. THAT'S GREAT NEWS-
SUCH GREAT PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER
CURRENT SIX AWARDED COUNTIES AND
SHOT THE PROPER DOCUMENTS AND
CLARA LA. INDIGO ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FIVE DOLLAR ONE TIME FUNDING
PROPOSAL BUT WE WOULD ALSO
ADVOCATE THE NEED FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM PROGRAM.
EVENTUALLY EXPANDED TO A POLICE
STATE BY PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOHN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE FROM THE OTHER THAN
THAT I THOUGHT I'M CALLING IT
THE CORE OF THE HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CONNECTION TYPE ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER COMMUNITY BACKED INTO
A UNIQUE LOCAL NEEDS IN A
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
TAILORED WAY I URGE YOUR
LEGISLATORS TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
FIND A- UNIQUE- FUNDS THAT WOULD
DEDICATE NO LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED MILLION TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS CLINICAL
TYPE ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY SIX PLEASE
CALL AT. IT HAPPENED OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
CHECK THE PARK THE VARIOUS
REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FOR STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH- BOB
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND REALLY
NEEDED HOWEVER HE CONTINUES TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE WHOLE-
CRACKLES DIRECT 25% OF THEIR
COMMUNITY BENEFIT DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH BUT HE ALREADY HAS
ALREADY BEEN EXPRESSED DURING
TODAY'S HEARING- REGAL AND
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK CONCERN IN
ADDITION THE PROPOSAL COULD
RESULT IN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING POTENTIAL
REDUCTION. IN EFFECT FOR PRIMARY
CARE ACT IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES BUT YOU CONTINUE TO BE
BY DAVID AND REQUIRE CAN YOU
HELP ME WITH THE FACT THAT THE
PRIORITY. FURTHER ADMITTED
YESTERDAY NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
AND LOWERING YOUR NEED NOTHING.
LESS RESOURCES DURING. OUR MORE
INVESTMENT. BUT TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE AN OFFER COMMENT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH FOR ONE
MORE CALL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END OF THE ROW AT
THIS TIME. OKAY AND I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY WE THINK
EVERYBODY WE THINK THE STAFF
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENTS AND OF
COURSE ALL THE PUBLIC WHO CALLED
IN TODAY. AND THAT CONCLUDES
THIS BUDGET SEPT THREE HEARING-
WE ARE. ADJOURNED.